la séance est reprise et la parole est
au président rénal je suis saisie d'une
deux pardon monsieur le Président
excusez-moi
bien Madame la Présidente mes chers
collègues donc
c'est une information pour la mission
suivante
donc c'est après la mission qui nous
occupe cet après-midi nous aurons donc à
examiner la mission agriculture sur
laquelle plus de 80 amendements sont
déposés compte tenu de leur gage la
quasi-totalité de ses amendements sont
en discussion commune on a eu ce débat
tout à l'heure avec l'amendement de
Monsieur sotarel
en effet l'adoption de certains
amendements ferait sinon tomber les
amendements suivants sans que les
auteurs et même pu les présenter
cependant suite aux échanges que nous
avons eu en commission des finances ce
matin des échanges qui étaient très
simples on a eu dans le dans les
missions passées là hier par exemple
des espèces de tunnels avec en
discussion commune des fois 40 30 40
abandonnements discussion commune ce qui
fait qu'à la sortie c'est arrivé sur
santé par exemple
vous étiez chers collègues
tout d'un coup vous savez plus on en
était quoi c'est à dire il y avait
quatre ministres bons qui répondaient
dans un sens dans l'autre enfin c'est un
souk infini et en même temps c'est notre
manière de fonctionner puisqu'on est
obligatoirement en discussion commune
donc afin de clarifier le plus possible
de nos débats je propose un lien
évidemment avec la séance d'appeler par
priorité certaines de ses amendements
pour les regrouper autour de deux
grandes thématiques que nous avons
identifié de manière à avoir des débats
ça empêchera pas que vote le vote se
fera sur l'ensemble bon donc on mettra
un thème autour de la restauration
collective et un thème autour des moyens
de l'Office National des Forêts ceci
faisant deux paquets extrêmement
importants dans l'ensemble ainsi les
rapporteurs et le ministre pourront
donner leur avis sur ces deux ensembles
d'amendements j'allais dire de manière
séparée et de manière qui est que les
que les interventions se fassent de
manière
construite et que ça soit pas
un peu un peu passant notamment à un
autre et d'une thématique à une autre je
vous indique enfin que plus nous
terminerons tôt la mission RCT ça je
peux pas m'empêcher évidemment cet
après-midi plus vite nous pourrons
enchaîner sur la mission agriculture
dont le nombre d'amendements est
particulièrement élevé cette année
c'est-à-dire qu'on a deux missions avec
beaucoup d'amendements et donc ça oblige
à tenir compte dès maintenant de ce fait
et donc comme d'habitude en m'excusant
de le faire ainsi vous appelez à la
sobriété dans la présentation de vos
amendements pour laisser le temps de
parole n'ont pas au rapporteurs qui vont
aller vite mais à la ministre pour
qu'elle donne la réponse du gouvernement
voilà je voulais vous dire en cet
instant merci monsieur le Président
quelle est la vie du gouvernement sur
cette demande de priorité madame la
ministre
le gouvernement est d'accord avec
monsieur le rapporteur et bien la
priorité est ordonnée alors nous
reprenons la discussion de la mission
relation avec les collectivités
territoriales dans la discussion nous
sommes parvenus à l'article 45 et nous
avons une demande de parole de Monsieur
Lamini
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre monsieur le président de la
commission des finances messieurs le
rapporteur chers collègues alors cet
article 45
concerne la répartition de la DGF ça a
été largement abordé aussi par tous les
collègues
en rappelant que la DGF fait partie des
différents transferts financiers de
l'État ou collectivité territoriale ces
transferts financiers s'élèvent à
hauteur de 107,6 milliards d'euros dans
le PLF 2023 soit plus 1,7 milliards
d'euros par rapport à l'année
2022 et c'est inscrit aussi par
référence à l'article 12 que nous avons
étudié en première partie
alors la DGF représente en
20226,8 milliards d'euros dont 18,3
milliards d'euros pour le bloc communal
et intercommunal et 8,3 milliards
d'euros pour les départements avec une
hausse 320 millions d'euros sur les
composantes de péréquation de la DGF
dont 200 millions ou titres de la
dotation de solidarité rurale à noter
également donc c'est très forme de la
dotation de solidarité rurale la réforme
des dotations attribuées également aux
communes d'outre-mer augmentation de
leur niveau les modalités de calcul de
l'effort fiscal et du potentiel
financier qui sont aussi importantes
injustement des critères d'éligibilité
d'éligibilité de la dotation politique
de la ville qui vise à soutenir les
communes confrontées à des charges
particulièrement lourdes au regard de la
politique de la ville mécanisme de
garantie également pour le fond le pic
fondateur équation
euh répartis entre les collectivités
locales au niveau des intercommunalités
fondation de permis équation des des MTO
pour les départements avec perte de
compensation enfin de la taxe foncière
sur les propriétés bâties enfin le
mécanisme de garantie prévu au niveau de
la suppression de la CVE voilà donc je
soutiendrai cet article merci monsieur
laminy nous passons à l'examen de
l'amendement 605 rectifiés monsieur
Savary oui bonjour Je présente
l'amendement de Monsieur Mounier que je
soutiens bien volontiers puisque le
département de la Marne est concerné par
un certain nombre de structures qui
hébergent des militaires madame la
ministre cet amendement propose de bien
clarifier la loi par rapport à la prise
en compte de la population maliaire dans
les casernes ou dans les centres de
formation qu'elles soient bien rattachée
à la population au calcul de la
population des GF de la commune comme
comme il est implicitement dit à travers
les modifications qu'au lieu entre 1999
et 2019 donc cet amendement précise bien
que les militaires rentrent dans le
cadre du calcul de la population des GF
de la commune dans laquelle il réside
merci Monsieur Savary avis de la
commission monsieur le rapporteur oui
c'est un lendemain de proposé par
Monsieur Savary en fait s'appuie sur une
recommandation de l'Insee qui date de
2019 simplement nous aimerions savoir si
cette recommandation était techniquement
envisageable et nous avons besoin de la
vie du gouvernement
à vie du gouvernement
merci madame la présidente
monsieur le sénateur Philippe Moulié sur
l'amendement 65 vous proposez d'inclure
dans la population des communes
indicateurs pris en
parce que j'avais entendu que c'était
monsieur Savary vous parlez
en son nom excusez-moi monsieur le
sénateur
vous proposez d’inclure dans la
population des communes indicateurs pris
en compte pour le calcul de la dotation
globale de fonctionnement de l'ensemble
des collectivités les militaires vivant
dans les casernes ou dans des camps et
bases militaires vous avez raison les
militaires qui vivent et travaillent
dans les communes doivent être pris en
compte dans le décompte de la population
utilisée pour la répartition de la DGF
c'est en fait déjà le cas les militaires
vivants casernes étant inclus dans la
population des communautés prises en
compte dans le recensement de l'Insee
utilisé pour le calcul et la répartition
de la DGF donc votre amendement est déjà
satisfait je vous demande de bien
vouloir le retirer autrement nous y
serions défavorables merci madame la
ministre monsieur Savary contenu des
engagements de Madame la mini je retire
bien volontiers l'amendement je vous
remercie la maman 650 rectifiée retirés
trois amendements identiques le 231 pour
commencer madame mikolo
merci madame la Présidente c'est
amendement vide a intégrer la majoration
de la taxe d'habitation résidence
secondaire dans le potentiel financier
non pas en tant que produit mais en tant
que potentiel merci
le 319 rectifié identiques
défendu merci beaucoup chers collègues
le 630 toujours identique
Marie oui merci madame la Présidente
très rapidement la taxe d'habitation sur
la résidence secondaire est une des
rares taxes sur laquelle collectivité
peuvent encore agir et percevoir des
ressources parfois conséquentes le seul
problème comme ça a été indiqué
précédemment c'est que son régime est
désincitatif pour les communes puisque
une majoration de THRs accroît le
potentiel fiscal de la commune et a donc
des conséquences sur les autres
dotations c'est la raison de cette
amendement portée par mes collègues et
moi-même merci chers collègues
monsieur le rapporteur à ville de la
commission ah Monsieur le Président
porteur dans ce cas je suis rapporteur
donc écoutez d'abord on voit que ces
amendements sont largement consignés
donc on verra mais je me lancer quand
même dans une réponse avec plutôt une
demande de retrait
sur ces sur cela donc il s'agit
effectivement d'ajuster le mode du
calcul du potentiel financier pour ce
qui concerne la prise en compte de la
majoration de la taxe d'habitation sur
les résidence secondaire alors faut bien
voir que effectivement la fille 2022
mais c'est pas le seul cas d'ailleurs à
intégrer cette recette potentielle
fiscale c'est-à-dire qu'on se retrouve
avec des éléments de potentiel et des
éléments finalement de produits qui sont
sommets ce n'est pas le seul cas dans ce
qui se fait aujourd'hui en termes de de
fiscalité locale et de comparaison de
potentiels et sur différents outils
alors pourquoi l’hypothèse l'évolution
proposait ne semble pas opportunes bon
d'abord parce que comme toujours
si elle est favorable à certains elle va
être défavorable à d'autres ça c'est un
premier premier sujet
d'ailleurs je suis pas toujours certain
quand je vois les noms de nos collègues
que certains que tout le monde soit bien
dans le cas qui leur bénéficie pourrait
y avoir des surprises c'est à dire que
sur si on voyait le résultat et si on
faisait les analyses peut-être que
certaines des signataires
retireraient leur signature je dis ça
j'ai rien dit
mais enfin ça mériterait d'être regardé
ce que je suis étonné que certains
territoires qui n'ont pas du tout de pas
du tout très peu vraiment de résidence
secondaire voilà manifeste un intérêt
pour certains pour cette amendement
alors deuxième sujet c'est que d'abord
d'abord je pense que ce n'est pas de
nature à comment dire faire basculer
c'est à dire que la perte qui est d'un
côté mais certainement pas compensés par
le gain de l'autre c'est à dire qu'on
n'est pas du tout dans les mêmes dans
les mêmes échelles quand on instaure la
THRs bon le gain de THRs est largement
supérieur par rapport à l'impact que sur
l'ensemble des collectivités que l'on
peut avoir sur sa propre collectivité
sur la une baisse de dotation ailleurs
donc je pense que c'est pas dans les
mêmes échelles et puis enfin c'est une
c'est un système qui est issu d'une
délibération précise du comité finance
locale et donc moi j'appellerai plutôt
retrait en demandant plutôt puisque au
CFL il y a des représentants de tous les
territoires que ce sujet soit porté en
CFL pour une éventuelle un éventuelle
débat un éventuel chiffrage et une
vision claire du sujet je pense qu'on ne
peut pas le faire de mon point de vue au
détour d'un amendement c'est un sujet
qui peut être posé mais je pense qu'il
faut d'abord le poser au CFL et plutôt
ensuite revenir statuer éventuellement
merci merci monsieur le rapporteur
madame la ministre avait du gouvernement
merci madame la Présidente
[Musique]
monsieur le madame la sénatrice mikolo
donc simplement ne pas développer les
mêmes arguments qui viennent d'être
développés par monsieur le président et
rapporteur vous dire que la vie du
gouvernement c'est une demande de
retrait pour les raisons invoquées et
sinon on a vidé favorable du
Gouvernement
merci Madame la Ministre alors au vu des
arguments madame micoulot vous maintenez
je retire vous retirez donc le 231 est
retiré madame Joseph
retiré pour le 319 et le 630 monsieur
Marie
vous le retirez je vous remercie et donc
le 630 est retiré quatre amendements
faisant l'objet d'une discussion commune
le 230 rectifié madame mikoulot
merci madame la Présidente c'est
amendement visa ne pas fléchir les 110
millions d'euros de DGF supplémentaires
sur la seule DSR mais sur l'ensemble des
composantes de la DGF
si Madame Joseph pour le 317 mais
argument donc défendu merci le 364
madame pansemonge merci madame la
Présidente alors c'est amendement
propose effectivement de fléchir
l'abondement de 110 millions d'euros de
la dotation globale de fonctionnement
non pas sur la seule dotation de
solidarité rurale mais de manière
équilibrée et équitable entre cette
dernière et la dotation de solidarité
urbaine si nous nous félicitons de la
décision du gouvernement d'abonder la
DGF afin de permettre la hausse tant de
la dotation de solidarité urbaine que de
la dotation de solidarité Solidarité
rurale à hauteur de 90 millions d'euros
chacune le parti pris consistant à
augmenter la seule dotation de
solidarité rurale de 110 millions
d'euros supplémentaires ne se justifie
pas
en effet cela
entérinerait un découplage inédit entre
l'évolution de la DSU et celle de la DSR
et ce alors même que précédemment le
législateur s'était employé ces
dernières années à une augmentation
identique des deux dotations de
péréquation en effet il n'y a guère
d'éléments permettant de justifier un
besoin de solidarité moindre envers les
communes de banlieue principalement
principal bénéficiaires de la dotation
de solidarité urbaine que de l'autre de
tassion cet amendement qui fait
consensus au sein de l'Association des
Maires ville et banlieue de France a été
suggéré par la métropole de Lyon et
diverses communes autour
merci avis de la commission monsieur le
rapporteur
oui merci madame la Présidente
mes chers collègues 190 excusez-moi j'ai
sauté un amendement monsieur le
rapporteur il manque le 190 madame
loisir
merci Madame la présente Madame mamie
moi ça ne m'étonnait pas parce que mon
amant ne vit mon amendement ne vise pas
du tout la même chose mais bon puisque
au contraire mon amendement vise à
consolider la DSR pour laquelle il y a
une augmentation de 200 millions prévus
à l'alinéa 8 de l'article 45 lors de
l'examen à l'Assemblée nationale le
gouvernement a prévu en fait que 60% en
moins de la hausse de la DSR sera
affectée à la fraction de péréquation ce
que je salue cet amendement en fait il
est totalement différent des précédents
vise à compléter cette répartition en
fixant un minimum de 20% pour la
fraction cible qui je le rappelle et est
amené à permettre de soutenir les
communes rurales les plus fragiles moins
de 10000 communes sont considérées dans
le cadre de cette fraction cible et
l'intérêt de la démarche effectivement
d'éviter madame la ministre que même si
on verse 60% pour la péréquation et bien
cueillez peut-être 35% pour les bourses
et que c'est 10000 communes en grande
situation de difficultés ne se
retrouvent qu'avec 5% de cette DSR voilà
donc un amendement de répartition de
répartition de l'ADSR merci merci Madame
Loisier et là monsieur le rapporteur
pouvait nous donner la vie de la
Commission sur ses amendements oui
effectivement je pense que ce dernier
amendement devait être avec pour les
raisons qu'a évoqué précédemment le
président rénal mais bon en ce qui
concerne les deux premiers amendements
et d'ailleurs une partie de
l'argumentation ira pour le troisième
donc les deux premiers amendements vise
à flécher l'abonnement exceptionnel de
110 milliards d'euros de 110 millions
d'euros pardon de la DSR sur l'ensemble
de la notation d'aménagement ce qui
reviendrait donc à réviser profondément
l'objectif de cet abonnement puisqu'il
nous
à cet égard elle nous paraît pas
important
de revenir sur cette mesure qui est très
attendue par le monde rural et il
convient quand même de rappeler que pour
l'instant la DSR cumulativement n'est
qu'un milliard 9 alors que la DSU est à
2 milliard 6 alors c'est pourquoi je
demanderai le retrait de ces amendements
en ce qui concerne l'augmentation pour
l'amendement 364 de la dotation de
solidarité urbaine ça ferait passer
quand même
l'enveloppe de 90 millions à 200
ce qui ferait quand même un rythme de
progression particulier pour la DSR qui
est déjà bien augmenté et comme nous
l'avons évoqué tout à l'heure
la DSU n'est quand même pas en mal de
d'augmentation puisqu'elle est quand
même toujours devant la DSR même si on
devait les comparer donc ce sera
également une demande de retrait
quant à l'amendement
490 de Madame Loisier bon c'est
amendement prévoir d'augmenter de 200
millions la DSR dont 60 francs 60%
fléchés sur la fraction péréquation par
dérogation droit commun alors j'aurais
simplement lui dire que effectivement on
peut comprendre la demande mais de toute
façon si on adoptait votre amendement ça
enlèverait un peu toute l'attitude au
CFL qui a qui normalement fait ce choix
et en plus en toute état de cause il l'a
toujours fait dans ce sens on voit pas
pourquoi il le ferait pas et dans la
pratique je dois vous dire qu'il est
satisfait puisque on arrivera à cet
effet je regarde à cet égard
les gens qui siègent au CFL qui ont
l'habitude de ce genre de pratique c'est
pourquoi je vous demanderai à retrait
parce que il est tout à fait satisfait
d'avoir
monsieur
madame la ministre merci madame la
Présidente donc une réponse pour les
amendements 230 317 et
364 sur lequel la position du
gouvernement sera un retrait sinon
défavorable en fait pour rappel
l'article 45 du PLF prévoit que la
hausse de la DGF en 2023 est répartie à
hauteur de 200 millions d'euros sur la
dotation de solidarité rurale la DSR et
de 90 millions d'euros sur la dotation
de solidarité urbaine et de 30 millions
d'euros sur la dotation
d'intercommunalité cette répartition est
calibrée de telle sorte que le maximum
de communes voit leur DGF augmenter ou
rester ça stable en 2023 je vous disais
95% des communes je ne pense pas me
tromper en faisant l'hypothèse qu'une
très grande majorité sénateurs ici
présent souscrit à cet objectif
l'augmentation plus forte de la DSR que
nous proposons par rapport à la DSU
permet également d'amorcer un
rééquilibrage entre ces deux dotations
je rappelle en effet que la DSU est à la
fois plus conséquente et plus concentrer
que la DSR en 2022 elle représente 2
milliards 6 répartis 851 communes
éligibles contre un milliard 8 réparti
sur 33000 communes pour la DSR et qui
bénéficieront donc presque toutes de
l'augmentation or les hausses passées de
la DSI de la DSU ont déjà permis
d'améliorer sensiblement la situation
financière des communes bénéficiaires
dont l'écart en termes d'épargne brute
avec les communes de plus de 10000
habitants ne bénéficiant pas d'adsu
c'est resserré entre 2017 et 2020 malgré
cette relative concentration des mesures
nouvelles sur la DSR son enveloppe
globale restera inférieure de près de
700 millions d'euros à celle de la DSU
donc nous vous demandons de bien vouloir
retirer ces amendements sinon le
gouvernement prendra une position
défavorable pour ce qui est de
l'amendement 490 qui est porté par la
sénatrice Anne-Catherine Loisier
je voudrais juste m'appuyer sur la
position du rapporteur simplement
insisté sur le fait que votre mesure
aurait pour effet de réduire encore le
pouvoir de la loi que le pouvoir de la
loi confère au Comité des finances
locales de répartir la hausse de la DSR
entre ces trois fractions seul 20% de la
hausse prévue en 2023 pourrait être
ainsi répartie par le Comité des
finances locales donc notre avis est
aussi retrait sinon défavorable merci
merci Madame la Ministre madame
Micoulaud
retirer donc c'est le 230 le 317 madame
Joseph il est retiré le 364 même pensé
mon je vous le maintenez donc je vais
mettre on voit le 364 qui est pour
ah pardon monsieur delcro explication de
vote
merci oui sur ces amendes alors j'ai
bien entendu que la métropole de Lyon
proposée qu'en diminue qu'en diminue la
part des SR finalement dans
l'augmentation de la DGF à hauteur 320
millions d'euros mais très franchement
les chiffres ont été rappelés et par
rapporteur et par Madame la Ministre
aujourd'hui l'enveloppe consacrée à la
DSR qui concerne en a dit 33000 communes
et largement inférieures à celle de la
DSU donc vouloir avoir une augmentation
symétrique ne correspond pas à la
réalité des choses donc je pense que il
serait malvenu de venir réduire
l'enveloppe de péréquation destinée aux
communes aux communes rurales et quant à
j'en profite pour la lendemain de
Anne-Catherine Loisier je trouve que il
a du sens parce qu'il vient parachever
en quelque sorte ce qui a été déjà fait
sur la répartition des 200 millions
puisque le 60% pour pour la part
péréquation a été acté et là il s'agit
de cibler 20% pour la par cible
si chers collègues monsieur Billac
oui merci madame la Présidente il y a un
an dans cette émission que je proposais
alors que le gouvernement proposé 90
millions d'euros pour la DSR et 90
millions d'euros pour la Dhu un
amendement augmentant de 20 millions la
dotation de faire rurale pour commencer
on rattrapage madame la ministre vous
avez ajouté 1-0 à ma proposition de
l'année dernière donc je vous en
remercie mais je crois que c'était
nécessaire d'assurer en rééquilibrage
vous l'avez dit parce que un pauvre des
champs et bien il vaut bien pauvre des
villes
je vous remercie monsieur Marie
merci madame la Présidente nous ne
soutiendrons pas cet amendement 364 à la
fois pour les raisons qui ont été
évoquées par le rapporteur spécial et la
ministre considérant que les montants
initiaux sont clairement différents et
que ça pénaliserait l'ADSR or nous avons
ici connaissance des difficultés qui
peuvent être rencontrées par les
communes notamment au regard de ce que
nous avons évoqué précédemment
l'augmentation de l'inflation et donc de
leur charge par ailleurs cela pose toute
une série de questions que nous
évoquerons plus tard sur la sanctualité
la sanctuarisation d'une partie de la
DSR effectivement en direction des
communes rurales alors qu'aujourd'hui
dans les commissions d'attribution on
constate un éparpillement de cette DSR y
compris au bénéfice de PCI qui n'en ont
pas nécessairement besoin et donc je
crois qu'il fera revenir sur ces
critères pour les resserrer au bénéfice
des communes rurales
si la parole est à monsieur le Président
Longeot
je crois que le conflit qui pouvait y
avoir ou les divergences qui doit y
avoir entre le monde urbain et le monde
rural je crois que si nous vote qui ont
ces amendements ben nous reviendrions à
une guerre entre le monde rural et le
monde urbain et je pense que le monde
rural a aussi besoin effectivement qu'on
abonde cette DSR et donc je pense qu'il
ne faut pas voter ses amendements il
serait d'ailleurs important de les
retirer merci Madame
bien
puisque j'ai défendu cet amendement
c'est vrai que c'était tout simplement
on disait que
la dotation supplémentaire devait être
donné de façon égale ou deux bien si
l'objectif maintenant est la convergence
des deux tentations disons-le et on le
fera donc en planification sur 10 ans
puisqu'il y a un écart mais comme on
n'avait pas perçu que c'était l'objectif
enfin les objectifs quand ils sont pas
transparents c'est quand même un petit
peu difficile de se déterminer nous on
pensait que on devait garder l'égalité
de la dotation bien sûr que comme il y
avait plus de dotation pour leur rural
vous dites que c'est une demande pour
diminuer le rural mais au départ c'est
pas une demande pour diminuer le rural
c'est pour dire que les dotations
supplémentaires doivent être réparties à
égalité alors j'entends sans être une
grande spécialiste que vous êtes dans
une trajectoire de convergence bon bah
alors si vous êtes dans une trajectoire
de convergence si ça devient pertin et
en toute état de cause pour ne pas quand
même que vous puissiez alimenter la
guerre justement des métropoles parce
que moi je vous rappelle que c'est
plutôt des banlieues dont j'ai parlé
alors la métropole c'est pas il y a de
la pauvreté il y a des besoins aussi
dans la dans la métropole donc je retire
cet amendement pour pas avoir une fausse
interprétation qui est en filigrane de
vous de vous interventions merci chers
collègues et donc le 364 est retiré le
490 madame Loisier
je vais même l'impression que je ne vais
pas le retirer parce que moi j'entends
votre argument madame la ministre qu'en
fait qui interdit au Parlement enfin qui
suggère au Parlement de ne pas
s'autoriser ce que vous mène vous vous
êtes autorisé à savoir de pondérer
l'affectation de la DSR et j'insiste sur
le fait que il me semble absolument
nécessaire de sanctuariser en fait la
part qui reviendra au 10000 communes les
plus défavorisées de France et je dirais
que si nous ne votons pas cette
répartition qui est dans le champ de nos
compétences légitimes et bien je vous
invite à nous retrouver dans quelques
semaines après effectivement la
ventilation pendant par le CFL et puis
nous constaterons où en sont les 10000
communes les plus défavorisées de France
merci chers collègues je vais donc
mettre au voile amendement
490 rectifié je vois pas de main qui se
lève 490 réactifié qui a reçu donc un
avis défavorable de la commission et du
gouvernement qui est pour
qui est contre
qui s'abstient il n'est pas adopté
l'amendement 489 rectifié madame Loisier
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre donc à la suite de la réforme
de la dotation d'intercommunalité un
mécanisme de lissage a été mis en œuvre
afin de limiter en fait les variations
individuelles à travers un tunnel de 95
garantie minimale et de 110 hausse
maximale cette situation crée de fait
des effets de transfert massif du
secteur rural en situation cumulée
décrètement vers le secteur urbain en
situation cumulée de garantie à titre
d'illustration pour les seuls PCI de
moins de 30000 habitants 125 d'entre eux
bénéficieront en 2023 d'une dotation
d'intercommunalité inférieure à plus de
50% de leur dotation théorique au regard
de l'écart important qui existe entre
leur dotation théorique et celle
effectivement perdue perçu la mise en
oeuvre de ce tunnel conduit à des
situations préjudiciables pour de
nombreuses PCI ruraux ou Perry urbain en
effet certains d'entre eux devront
atteindre plus de 30 ans avant d'arriver
à la dotation calculée selon les
modalités issues de la Réforme et du
tunnel c'est pourquoi cet amendement
propose de fixer le seuil décrètement à
120% du montant perçu l'année précédente
au lieu des 110 pour atténuer en fait
cette situation sans remettre en cause
l'architecture générale de la dotation
ainsi ce seuil plafond de 120 est
identique à celui en vigueur pour
d'autres composants de la dotation
aménagement du bloc communal tel que la
DSR dont nous venons de parler pour
laquelle le présent PLF a proposé deux
plafonner pour le coup à 120%. je
j'ajoute que finalement
contrairement ce que j'ai pu indiquer
cette mesure aujourd'hui est financée de
par le vote de l'amendement 373 du Sénat
en première partie qui je le rappelle
index l'évolution de l'enveloppe des 25
milliards sur l'inflation plus 4,2% et
donc il nous amène à disposer de crédits
supplémentaires passons donc de
l'enveloppe supplémentaire de 320 à 798
je vous remercie merci
Monsieur le
[Musique]
en même temps j'étais en train de
digérer la dernière phrase de Madame
Loisier que j'avais pas intégrer dans
mon raisonnement et qui me crée un petit
doute c'est toujours désagréable pour un
rapport temps spécial d'avoir une doute
ce qu'on doit afficher des certitudes
bon alors le présentement vise à faire
passer de 30 à 61 millions d'euros le
montant de la hausse de la dotation
intercommunalité et élargir son tunnel
d'évolution actuelle etc qui passerait
de 95 à 110 à 95 à 120
alors il est clair que plusieurs
remontées du terrain vous en avez eu
nous en avons eu évidemment montre que
le plafonnement à 110% ralentit
fortement le déploiement des effets de
la réforme de 2019 qui doit permettre de
renforcer son caractère péréquateur et
de remédier à certaines iniquités entre
les différentes catégories de PC
nous avions d'ailleurs approuvé cette
réforme lors de l'examen du PLF 2019 ce
plafonnement à 110% a été intervenu en
cours de navette par le biais d'un
amendement adopté à l'Assemblée
nationale et c'est comme ça qu'on avait
réduit ce qu'on allait ralenti le
système alors bon on peut dire plusieurs
choses
d'abord dire que les dotations de
péréquation cette année connaissent on a
eu ce débat est-ce que c'est trop est-ce
que c'est pas assez etc très bien trop
personne ne le dit mais est-ce que c'est
suffisant ou est-ce que on doit faire
plus mais il y a donc une augmentation
de 320 millions d'euros dans ce PLF qui
sont financés c'est ça la particularité
par crédit frais si on peut dire en tout
cas directement du gouvernement et non
pas par minoration des dotations
forfaitaires
et donc
qu'il pouvait noter mais votre dernière
phase m'ennuie un peu je dois le dire
parce que je n'ai pas intégré dans mon
raisonnement que cet amendement
impliquerait de revenir sur ce principe
c'est-à-dire sur le principe de non
minorations des dotations forfaitaires
qui est le principe posé pour les
intercommunalités autrement dit si on
applique votre amendement sur les
intercommunalités il y a bien une
perception
sur les dotations forfaitaires des
intercomté pour financer cette
augmentation de 30 à 61 millions d'euros
voilà donc sur le sur le principe
on y est donc défavorable plus
exactement pour être plus positif une
demande de retrait et pourquoi je dis
demande retrait parce que je vous
demande de vous renvoyer je me permets
de vous renvoyer à trois amendements
identiques qui sont un peu plus loin
pour des raisons d'organisation de la
séance qui sont les amendements 131 429
et 626 sur qui qui reviennent qui sont
sur ce même sujet mais avec un système
qui ne prélève pas si vous voulez sur
sur le les dotations forfaitaires donc
on vous renvoie à ces trois amendements
qui sont à peine un peu plus loin 131
429 626 sur lequel on donnera un avis de
sagesse si vous voulez bien retirer le
vôtre vous verrez sur des questions
similaires merci monsieur le rapporteur
madame la ministre
[Musique]
déjà décidé par amendement au présent
projet de loi de finance d'abonder
directement de 30 millions d'euros
l'enveloppe de la masse à répartir au
titre de la dotation d'intercommunalité
en 2023 et non par redéploiement sur les
composants de forfaitaire de la DGF
comme appliqué les années
précédentes votre proposition privée une
grande partie de l'abonnement direct de
la dotation d'intercommunalité par
l'état de 30 millions d'euros donc je
vous renouvelle notre souhait de vous
voir retirer cet amendement à défaut
nous y serons défavorables
merci Madame la Ministre madame
cukkermann vous avez la parole oui je
vous remercie madame la présidente
madame la ministre mes chers collègues
sauf si bien évidemment notre collègue
Anne-Catherine loisir retiré son
amendement mais sinon nous le voterons
moi je me permets à ce moment-là de la
journée quand même que nous ayons une
petite réflexion nous l'avons vécu avant
la coupure des genets je crois que nous
avons un débat dans le cadre du projet
de loi de finances qui devient
surnaturel et José Péret malheureusement
que peu de gens nous regardent à cet
instant là que peu de gens nous
regardent parce que nous avons quand
même vécu avant la coupure le fait de
devoir retirer un abonnement et de ne
pas le voter parce que sinon le votion
nous pourrions en faire tomber d'autres
qui étaient intéressants pour les
collectivités nous sommes là aujourd'hui
à cette heure là plutôt à négocier du
fait de retirer des amendements pour
pouvoir les rediscuter ensuite et
finalement les rendre plus effectifs
alors je veux bien que nous laissions
entendre que finalement les
parlementaires que nous sommes faisons
tout et n'importe quoi avec des montants
excessifs mais je veux et je veux le
faire y compris pour le compte-rendu
puisque les débats que nous avons sont
rendus publics nous sommes aujourd'hui
des sénateurs
contraints dans le cadre du débat de loi
de finances sur un certain nombre de
logiques d'amendements qui nous obligent
soit à l'écran t à tel moment du débat
soit elle est gager de telle ou telle
façon ce n'est peut-être pas la
meilleure des orthodoxies qu'il faudrait
en matière de comptabilité budgétaire
mais puisque nous sommes pas à Byzance
pour discuter ici du sexe des anges
j'invite vraiment chacune et chacun
à nuancer les arguments qui peuvent être
donnés quand les uns sont favorables ou
défavorables sur tel amendement parce
que on va finir la journée sur des
rejets d'amendement qui simplement sont
liés au fait qu'ils ne sont soit pas
bien crantés soit pas bien gagés en
oubliant comme une demi-heure l'intérêt
pour les collectivités et les Français
merci beaucoup madame Loisier vous
maintenez votre amendement
allez-y
oui d'abord je remercie le rapporteur à
Madame la Ministre pour l'explication
apporter quelques éléments alors d'abord
dans mon amendement initial il ne s'agit
pas Madame mamie je le rapporteur de
prélèvements supplémentaires puisque au
contraire le souhait était de venir
abonder la dotation complémentaire des
30 millions mais de fait comme je le
signalais comme nous avons voté en
première partie un amendement qui
élargit la masse disponible et bien ce
supplément n'est plus nécessaire donc il
n'induit pas au regard de ce que le
Sénat a déjà voté il n'induit pas de
complément financier et enfin sur le
fond de la mesure c'est à dire encore
une fois une mesure de justice
financière puisqu'il s'agit d'établir un
niveau de traitement qui est pratiqué
pour un certain nombre d'autres
intercommunalités et juste les effets
modestes non non madame la miss moi je
me suis pas j'allais dire un musée non
mais en tout cas essayer de faire la
projection sur ce que ça donnerait sur
un département comme le mien à ce jour
seulement deux EPCI sont au niveau de la
dotation théorique à laquelle il
prétendre avec ce système à 120% ce
serait plus de la moitié des EPCI qui
seraient au niveau de la dotation
théorique à laquelle ils ont
effectivement droit merci donc vous
maintenez votre amendement vous
maintenez votre amendement monsieur le
rapporteur spécial
non je voudrais dire à Madame loisirs
que c'est une vision extrêmement
positive que vous avez quand on a voté
une augmentation des gels de 800
millions j'ai pas entendu le ministre au
bon donner un avis favorable et lever le
gage j'ai pas entendu ça donc à partir
de là c'est bien sur une somme fictive
que vous voulez prélever quelque chose
bon voilà donc donc
non voilà donc je crois que je crois
qu'il faut faire attention il faudrait
pas qu'il y ait plus les 800 millions
mais que votre amendement pas ça par
hasard vous voyez
merci
Monsieur Vial vous avez la parole
oui merci madame la Présidente la
ministre mes chers collègues juste un
mot sur ce sujet je me râlerai à la
sagesse de la Commission sur cette
amendement notamment sur le dispositif
j'entends ce que je vous dites et puis
avec ma collègue Gatel et kerouche on
fait partie des amendements que vous
citiez tout à l'heure sur lequel vous
avez donné un avis de sagesse et pour
lequel je vous remercie néanmoins il
s'agit d'un vrai sujet cette dotation
d'intercommunalité c'est la valise RTL
c'est la somme qu'on dit aux communes
qu'elle pourrait gagner mais qu'elle ne
gagneront jamais avec ce mécanisme c'est
à dire c'est 30 ans pour l'obtenir si
tout se passe bien s'il y a pas
d'évolution d'ici là je voudrais juste
dire un mot madame la ministre c'est
pour ça que je voulais réagir c'est en
entendant vos propos tout à l'heure en
disant que c'était un mauvais amendement
parce que on y perdrait plus qu'on y
gagnerait c'est la formule je crois que
vous avez utilisé juste vous rappeler
madame la ministre que la moyenne de la
dotation d'intercommunalité c'est
environ 22,8 euros par habitant
les comités de communes les plus rurales
touchent en moyenne 16 euros alors que
les communautés urbaines sont à 34 euros
madame la ministre nous avions jusqu'à
hier une ministre de la ruralité je vous
félicite pour votre promotion mais je
crois avoir compris aujourd'hui que nous
n'avions nous avions perdu cette
ministre de la réalité
merci
monsieur je propose de mettre aux voix
l'amendement 489 rectifiés qui a reçu un
avis des favorable de la commission et
du gouvernement qui est pour
qui est contre
qui s'abschait n'est pas adoptée le 479
rectifiés c'est Monsieur buffet monsieur
le Président avoue la parole merci
madame la Présidente c'est un moment
très au critères d'accès à la fraction
Bourson de la dotation de solidarité
rurale qui ont été ces critères en
particulier cristallisés au premier
janvier 2014 je ne rentre pas dans le
détail des communes qui continuent d'en
bénéficier ce serait sans doute un peu
surabondant au moment de ces débats mais
je voudrais quand même attirer votre
attention sur le fait que en se référant
à la date du 1er janvier 2014 la loi omi
de considérer la situation très
particulière des communes situées en
marge extérieures de la métropole
départementale de Lyon créée en 2015 ce
qui fait que les périmètres de certains
cantons limitrophes qui ont évolué au
1er janvier 2015 indépendamment de la
réforme nationale de la carte cantonale
entrée en vigueur en 2015 ont perdu le
bénéfice de cette dotation et l'objectif
de l'amendement est de réparer une forme
d'injustice
merci chers collègues monsieur le
rapporteur
merci madame la Présidente
mes chers collègues monsieur buffet de
toute façon la prise en compte du d'une
date de référence pose forcément des des
problèmes nous en convenons mais c'est
un sujet national mais effectivement
vous évoquez une sorte de spécificité
lyonnaise
en la matière parce qu'il y en a
d'autres bien entendu
mais
cette spécificité justifierait donc pour
vous un traitement particulier comme
nous n'avons pas pu l'établir nous avons
besoin l'avis du gouvernement pour
connaître la pertinence de cet amende
madame la ministre ravie du gouvernement
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Président François Noël buffet
vous proposez d'apprécier les limites
territoriales des cantons 1er janvier
2015 pour les seules communes qui sans
appartenir à la communauté urbaine de
Lyon appartenait au 1er janvier 2014 à
des cantons regroupant des communes
membres de la communauté urbaine de Lyon
vous indiquez que les communes
chefs-lieux des anciens cantons ou qui
rassemblaient au moins 15 % de la
population de leur canton au 1er janvier
2014 sont restés automatiquement
éligibles depuis lors or cela n'est pas
exact le seul critère d'éligibilité à la
fraction boursante de la DSR qui a été
figée au 1er janvier 2014 et le statut
de chef-lieu de canton en revanche même
si les limites territoriales des cantons
sont appréciées au 1er janvier 2014 le
poids de chaque commune dans la
population de son canton et réévaluer
chaque année par ailleurs votre
amendement crée une rupture d'égalité
problématique
il vise en effet apprécier les limites
territorielles des cantons au 1er
janvier 2015 pour les seules communes
qui n'étaient pas membres de la
communauté urbaine de Lyon au 1er
janvier 2014 tout en appartenant à des
cantons regroupant des communes membres
de la communauté urbaine de Lyon or les
limites territoriales des cantons
évoluent en de nombreux endroits depuis
2014 en particulier mais pas seulement
lors de la réforme nationale de la carte
cantonale de mars 2015 aucun motif
d'intérêt général ne permet de justifier
que son introduite une différence de
traitement entre les cantons de l'ex
communauté urbaine de Lyon et les autres
cantons qui ont connu une évolution de
leur lit territoriale depuis le 1er
janvier 2014 il ne paraît donc pas
possible de dégeler l'appréciation des
limites territoriales des seuls cantons
de l'ex communauté urbaine de Lyon il ne
me paraît pas non plus envisageable de
dégeler l'appréciation des limites de
l'ensemble des cantons l'objectif du gel
au 1er janvier 2014 étant d'éviter des
effets de bord sur la répartition de la
DSR Bours centre qu'entraînerait la
prise en compte de la réforme cantonale
de 2015 donc le gouvernement a une
position soit de retrait si vous voulez
bien sinon défavorable merci madame la
ministre monsieur le rapporteur même
avis
mais ma vie je pas d'explication
pas d'explication de vote
madame ku Karman madame la Présidente
mais oui si ça mérite quelques
explications parce que madame la
ministre dans les réponses que vous
apportez tout d'abord nous sommes dans
un cas très spécifique qui est celui de
la création de la métropole de Lyon et
il nous appartient pas ici de revenir
sur la pertinence ou non de la métropole
de Lyon et donc vous faites un
parallélisme des formes avec des cantons
qui certes ont été tous redécoupés mais
vous ne pouvez pas comparer un
redécoupage dans tous les autres
départements de France qui ont qui ont
prévalu au fait que vous aviez
redécoupage avec évolution des EPCI et
donc y compris des passages en
communauté d'agglomération en communauté
urbaine en métropole au sens métropole
hors métropole de Lyon si on peut les
définir ainsi je sais plus quoi j'en
perds mon latin parfois y compris mais
avec la situation très spécifique qui
évoque
notre collègue président de la
commission des lois François Noël buffet
qui demeure inévitablement le besoin
d'une réponse exclusivement spécifique à
la situation de l'ancien département du
Rhône et au redécoupage des cantons du
Rhône et à la création de la métropole
du Rhône et vous ne pouvez pas avoir une
réponse madame la ministre qui est un
paralysme des formes avec tout ce qui
s'est passé ailleurs puisque par
principe même partout ailleurs nous
avons certes subi le redécoupage des
cantons certes subit le redécoupage des
EPCI et l'intégration d'un certain
nombre de communes dans des EPCI d'un
niveau supérieur sachant que infini nous
avons vécu quoi ils ont vécu puisque la
saint matrice qui gêne que je suis
n'oserait surtout pas à sa part sa
parenté au département du Rhône et nous
voulons bien garder nos différences mais
en tout état de cause dans le départ du
paiement du Rhône il y a eu une
évolution particulière qui nécessite une
adaptation de la loi pour prendre en
compte cette
issue de la création de la métropole du
Rhône donc j'inviterai simplement à mes
collègues dépositaires de l'amendement
quand même à réagir parce que je pense
que ce n'est pas qu'ane anecdotique la
réponse qui vient de nous être faite
merci monsieur le Président du fait
remercier madame je ne saurais dire
mieux que ce qu'elle vient de dire et
madame la ministre il y a une
particularité à Lyon la création de la
métropole de Lyon en 2015 lui a fait
changer de nature elle est passée d'un
établissement public de coopération
communale un statut de collectivité
locale donc ces conditions-là les
relations évidemment avec les communes
directement limitrophes ont été
profondément modifiées et effectivement
la situation est très particulière j'en
conviens parfaitement elle n'est sans
doute pas celle l'équivalente à
n'importe quel autre sur le territoire
national elle est très particulière mais
il se trouve de ce fait que les communes
en la commune en question ou les
communes en question se sont retrouvés
avec une perte d'argent en monnaie selon
tes trébuchante alors qu'elles n'y sont
pour rien qu'elles n'ont rien demandé et
qu'elle dépendait en réalité au départ
d'une collectivité ou d'une commune
principal qui est resté dans la
métropole de Lyon donc c'est bien à un
moment un ajustement qui est nécessaire
de faire à défaut de considérer que
finalement les communes n'ont qu'à
s'appauvrir mais là c'est un autre débat
explication de vote
merci madame la Présidente je suis
désolé de prendre la parole après le
président buffet qui connaît mieux les
choses que moi mais je voulais réagir en
disant que en fait ce qui ce que nous
étudions présentement c'est en réalité
un dommage collatéral de la création de
la métropole de Lyon on pouvait
peut-être pas s'en rendre compte au
moment de la fabrication de la loi ça
c'est clair mais c'est en avançant qu'on
apprend les choses et quand il faut
faire des corrections il faut être
humble et se dire on a fait une erreur
on corrige voilà donc moi ce que
j'aimerais simplement c'est que si
monsieur le rapporteur veut bien
m'entendre c'est que au vu des
explications
je voudrais attirer l'attention du
rapporteur c'est au vu des explications
de Madame kukermann et du président
buffet au moins que monsieur le
rapporteur change ton avis et mettre un
avis de sagesse ce qui nous permettrait
de voter sereinement merci Madame Di
Folco monsieur le rapport
e pas le rapporteur de l'amendement en
question qui s'exprimera et qui dira ce
qu'il souhaite ce que je voudrais quand
même dire toujours sur les questions
métropoles de Lyon
il y a des aspects comme toujours dans
toute modification qui est faite il y a
toujours des choses favorables et des
choses défavorables donc
je pense qu'il faut toujours avoir peser
les choses dans ces discussions là et on
peut pas dire
que dans certains cas on prend le côté
favorable et que pour d'autres choses on
souhaite vider le côté défavorable
deuxième sujet je rappelle simplement
que si on a juste comme vous le dites
enveloppe constante ça veut dire que
tous les autres perdent je le rappelle
juste voilà donc au moment des votes
vous voyez mais je pense que le sujet
métropole de Lyon c'est un sujet très
important qui a été mené qu'à donner
lieu à des discussions extrêmement
fortes je le rappelle d'ailleurs en
m'excusant mais c'était dans cette mise
au que ça s'est passé les discussions
entre le maire de Lyon de l'époque et le
président du Département de l'époque
permettez permettez mon nous deux moi de
vous dire que ça s'est passé dans les
couloirs
et qu'on a été on a été mis devant ce
truc il y avait un accord bon
voilà voilà on a été positif ce truc
mais après de grâce il faut pas venir
nous le rattraper et puis le reprendre
sur tout le monde voilà c'est mon avis
merci Monsieur Reynal alors
s'il n'y a plus de demandes
d'explication de vote je vérifie quand
même je vais mettre au bois l'amendement
479 rectifiés qui a reçu un avis
défavorable de la commission et du
gouvernement qui est pour
alors on va compter lever bien les bras
qui pour
allez on lève les bras là 1 2 3
qui s'abstient il est adopté
6 amendements faisant l'objet d'une
discussion commune
avant de commencer la présentation de
ces six amendements monsieur le
rapporteur vous avez la parole
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre mais chers collègues nous
allons effectivement maintenant examiner
plusieurs amendements relatifs à la
réforme de la dotation de solidarité
rurale proposée par l'article 45
cette réforme visa a remplacé le critère
de longueur de voirie communale qui
compte pour 30% dans le calcul des
fractions peréquations et cibles la DSR
par un critère de superficie pondéré par
la population et la densité comme toute
réforme des dotations celle-ci fera
nécessairement des gagnants et des
perdants ce constat est imposé nous
devons collectivement comme face à tout
projet de réforme des dotations nous
poser deux questions premièrement la
modification des critères est-elle juste
et deuxièmement l'ampleur des transferts
qu'elle entraîne est-elle suffisamment
limitée pour ne pas fragiliser les
collectivités perdantes
s'agissant du premier aspect les travaux
du Comité des finances locales ont mis
en avant de bonnes raisons de ne plus
utiliser le critères de la voirie en
effet la dessert n'a pas pour vocation
de compenser la charge particulière
d'entretien des routes mais les charges
générales auxquelles font face les
communes rurales
la longueur de voirie était utilisée
comme un indicateur réputé entre autres
refléter ses charges
or ce critère posait un problème
puisqu'il introduisait un biais
pénalisant comme une membre de
communauté de urbaine ou de métropoles
qui étaient tenu de transférer leur
route à l'interco c'est la principale
raison pour laquelle le CFL a travaillé
une solution de remplacement avec un
critère plus général de superficie pour
narré par la population de la densité
par ailleurs le critère de voirie aurait
tendance à ses paradoxalement mais à
favoriser les communes rurales les plus
urbanisées
à la seconde question sur les effets
concrets de la réforme d'après les
simulations présentées par le CFL qui a
plusieurs fois à travailler sur ce sujet
les effets sont limités
s'agissant s'agissant de la DSR
péréquation la masse financière déplacée
représente moins de 2% du montant global
de la fraction
s'agissant de la DSR cible celle-ci
représenterait 6 % du total les faits
sera en pratique inférieure car
l'article 45 propose en parallèle
d'appliquer un tunnel d'évolution à la
fraction cible en toute état de cause il
conviendra de relever que dans un
contexte où l'enveloppe globale de DSR
est en constante augmentation les
perdants ne seront en réalité que de
moindre gagnant
pour toutes ces raisons la commission
des Finances n'a pas souhaité revenir
sur cette réforme découlant expressément
des délibérations du CFL et je donnerai
je demanderai donc en son nom le retrait
de tous les amendements poursuivant cet
objectif qu'il supprime ce critère ou en
institut d'autres où on rajoute d'autres
voilà je vous remercie pour votre
attention merci monsieur le rapporteur
nous allons pouvoir maintenant débuter
l'examen de ces amendements de
discussion commune en commençant par le
39 rectifié de terre monsieur Delcros
merci Madame madame la présidente madame
la ministre comme l'a rappelé le
rapporteur Charles Guénet la question
porte sur la répartition
de la DSR non pas sur le montant de la
DSR mais sur sa répartition et seulement
pour les fractions péréquation et cible
ça me concerne pas du tout la fraction
en boursante dont on a parlé tout à
l'heure actuellement cette répartition
pour les parts péréquation et cibles
repose sur quatre critères dont un
critère de voirie qui n'est pas
prépondérant parce qu'il n'intervient
qu'à hauteur de 30%. donc il est loin
d'être prépondérant même pas un tiers de
la répartition se fait en fonction du
critère longueur de devoirille ce qui
est proposé dans le projet de budget que
nous examinons c'est finalement de
supprimer ce critère de longueur de le
voirie et de le remplacer par un critère
qui qui prend en compte à la fois de la
densité de la superficie qu'on peut
entendre mais tout ça pondéré par un
coefficient de population
or les autres critères autre que la
voirie aujourd'hui autre que la longueur
de voirie prenne déjà en compte le
critère de population je trouve que
venir renforcer le critère de population
dans le cas de la répartition de la DSR
ça me paraît être une mesure qui ne
tient pas du tout compte de la réalité
des territoires la longueur de voirie la
longueur de voirie ça fait partie des
caractéristiques des caractéristiques
des communes ça fait partie des charges
générales des communes comme ça a été
exprimé tout à l'heure nous savons que
dans les communes rurales à très faites
densité de population mais il y a
souvent beaucoup de superficie et
beaucoup de longueur de voirie on en a
parlé ce matin à travers une proposition
qui a été faite pour créer un fond
spécifique pour la voirie on sait que
c'est un sujet vraiment important et que
les petites communes ont beaucoup de mal
à faire face à l'entretien à la
rénovation et de leur voirie donc je
franchement je je défends cette idée que
prendre seulement à hauteur 30% le
critère de longueur de voirie comme
c'est le cas aujourd'hui ça me paraît
que le minimum pour tenir compte de la
réalité de ce que vivent les communes
rurales
le 472 rectifiés monsieur Joly madame la
Présidente
j'irai dans le sens des propos de
Bernard delcro à l'instant prendre en
compte le critère de densité et donc
deux populations c'est d'une certaine
manière favoriser les communes les plus
denses donc les communes les plus
urbanisées c'est une évidence et
d'ailleurs
les chiffres des simulations nous le
démontrent puisque globalement les
communes de moins de 1000 habitants sont
perdantes particulièrement les communes
de 500 amis habitants parce qu'elles
perdent à la fois sur la DSR et sur la
DSR cible ADSL peréquation et pour les
moins de 500 habitants le perturent la
DSR cible pire équation pardon à peine
compensé par la DSR cible donc
globalement il y a une perte équiliée au
fait effectivement qu'on ne prend pas en
compte les charges liées à la superficie
et dont un critère effectivement qui
permettait de l'appréhender était le
critère d'avoiri correspondant et on l'a
dit ce matin à deux réels charges on va
à l'encontre des objectifs de cette
dessert qui était de renforcer la
péréquation et permettre aux
collectivités de disposer des moyens
nécessaires pour faire face à leur
charge et faire en sorte que leur
population soit traitée de manière
équitable visiblement et à travers les
échanges qu'on a eu ce matin il y a un
vrai besoin de réforme de ces dotations
de rénovation de critères et qui
permettent aussi non seulement d'avoir
des objectifs soit des objectifs
d'équité mais également de lisibilité on
commence à se perdre et les simulations
d'ailleurs et le rapporteur spécial les
requêtes tout à l'heure les simulations
montrent que les communes
habitants perdraient
mais perdre moins parce que l'on a pris
en compte dans la dans la dans les
simulations le montant supplémentaire de
de crédit à répartir et généralement
quand on fait des simulations on le fait
à périmètre constance qui n'est pas le
cas et malgré tout il y a une perte pour
les collectivités de moins de 1000
habitants dans les conditions que je
viens d'évoquer je vous remercie donc
dès lors ma demande de suppression alors
le 475 rectifié toujours identiques oui
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre monsieur le rapporteur
il s'agit dans cet amendement de réparer
selon moi une erreur comme il Comité des
finances locales dans le nouveau mode de
calcul de la DSR en supprimant la
référence longueur de voirie
puisque ce comité de finance locale a
voté à l'unanimité apparemment la
suppression sans la vie des mers ruraux
je le dis très sincèrement les mères
ruraux souhaitent conserver
ce critère voirie parce que toutes les
communes monsieur le rapporteur n'ont
pas transféré la voirie aux communautés
de communes et souvent dans les budgets
de nos communes rurales la voirie c'est
le principal budget d'investissement
et quand vous parlez superficie moi je
connais des grandes communes où il y a
que des départementales qui traversent
donc finalement il y a pas de travaux de
voirie mais il y a aussi des communes
moins importantes qui ont 25 30 km de
voirie entretenir et moi je trouve que
la DSR était un moyen de compenser
justement cette possibilité de financer
une part de une part de l'avoirie donc
je souhaite vraiment qu'on supprime cet
alinéa pour qu'on revienne aux critères
de longueur de voirie
[Musique]
exprime ce critère alors monsieur le
rapporteur nous avons sujet côte à côte
au Comité des Finals locales et je
respecte et je connais très bien cette
institution je rappellerai quand même
que sur 30 demandes il n'y a que deux
représentants des communes de moins de
2000 habitants
madame la ministre la dotation
forfaitaire des communes dans sa
fraction cible et péréquation et d'une
grande importance pour nos communes
rurales afin d'assurer des potentialités
de fonctionnement des services pour des
communes ayant peu de revenus et des
bases d'imposition faible le Comité des
finances locales a proposé de supprimer
la composante voirie qui entrait pour
30% dans le montant de la DSR et de la
remplacer par une composante dépendante
de la surface de la population et de la
densité de la commune relativement
ancestrate cette proposition présente
deux inconvénients majeurs dont on a
fait mention je n'y reviendrai pas pour
permettre de corriger ses défauts le
présent amendement élaborant
collaboration avec l'Association des
Maires Ruraux de France proposent donc
une nouvelle rédaction de l'article
l23422 en remplaçant la formule de
calcul de l'ADSR qui se base sur trois
points premier point la DSR serait
répartie pour 20% de son manteau
proportionnellement à la longueur de la
voirie classée dans le domaine public
communal en l'état la rédaction parle de
charge de centra côté la charge de
ruralité existe aussi il faut aider à la
remplir aussi ma proposition vise à
remettre cette dotation de voirie pour
20% du montant de la DSR deuxième point
elle sera répartie pour 20% de son
montant proportionnellement à la part
superficielle notée il serait dorénavant
proposé de supprimer toute référence à
la densité et de modérer la croissance
due à la population et enfin troisième
point la suppression de la quatrième
composante superficielle de la DSR
relatif à l'écart entre le potentiel
financier par hectares de la commune et
le potentiel financier moyen par hectare
des communes de moins de 10000 habitants
merci Madame Noël et pour terminer cette
série le 634 rectifiés monsieur ah non
pardon chers collègues
merci madame la Présidente
cet amendement vise à intégrer un
critère de taux de logement sociaux dans
le calcul de la deuxième fraction de la
dotation de DSR dites DSR péréquation en
cohérence avec le même amendement
portant sur la fraction dite boursorante
notre pays connaît un important déficit
de logements sociaux on le sait tous et
considérant et on considère que la crise
économique et sociale induite par
l'épidémie de covid-19 va entraîner un
besoin croissant de logement abordable
pour nos concitoyens et donc il apparaît
pertinent de récompenser les communes
rurales qui prennent leur part de la
solidarité nationale en produisant de
telles logements
ce critère de taux de logement sociaux
au regard du taux moyen de logements
sociaux des communes de moins de 10000
habitants seraient fixés à 15% avec la
possibilité qu'il soit minoré ou majorée
de 5 points selon les règles de droit
commun comme les autres critères merci
et Madame arrive nous passons maintenant
à la vie de la Commission et peut-être
monsieur Raynal demander la parole tout
à l'heure
en explication de vote ensuite monsieur
rénale donc monsieur le rapporteur vous
avez la parole pour la vie de la
Commission
oui simplement bon j'avais dit que je
demanderai simplement un retrait pour
chacun des amendements mais simplement
compte tenu de ce qui vient d'être dit
je voudrais quand même affirmer que il
n'y a pas eu de coup de force auprès du
cffl je veux dire le dossier était
présenté plusieurs fois et avec des
simulations je veux dire c'était quand
même et les meilleurs héros je suis au
CFN ils ont été invités
il ne semble pas avoir répondu à cette
invitation mais bon on ne peut en être
comptable simplement il faut bien
comprendre que en fait ce remplacement
par un nouveau critère provient du fait
surtout que tous ceux qui ont effectué
un transfert de leur varie en
particulier dans les métropoles sont
absolument pénalisés par le système et
qu'il fallait trouver une solution
le critère qui a été substitué et qui
prend la superficie et était et la
densité et assemblé beaucoup mieux pour
appréhender non pas les charges de
voirie parce qu'il ne s'agit pas
de compenser les charges de voirie mais
de compenser les charges de la ruralité
en fait et donc
il est apparu que la superficie et
quelque chose combiné avec la densité et
bien sûr
pondérer par la population parce que
quelque part on ne peut pas prendre que
la densité permettait d'atteindre au
mieux cette notion
de charge pour la ruralité et c'est
ainsi que on a retenu cela on est même
allé on a continué à majorer d'ailleurs
pour les communes de montagne on a
majoré de deux fois par deux fois la
et les simulations ont appréhendé tout
cela et c'est pour cette raison que nous
pensons que c'est un critère qui qui
nous apparaît voilà mais nous n'ignorons
pas que nous touchons à la symbolique
avec
des charges de ruralité se limitaient à
la charge de voirie je pense que ça
saurait mais le problème c'est de savoir
si ça représente effectivement
les charges de la réalité je crois que
ça imposerait une réforme globale de la
fiscalité et surtout de la DGF pour la
rendre plus contemporaine et je pense
que c'est là que devrait être notre
travail et effectivement je pense que la
la réforme qui a été faite et
probablement incomplète mais il fallait
bien retravailler cette notion voilà
c'est simplement une explication
complémentaire que je voulais donner
bon madame la ministre vous avez la
parole merci madame la Présidente donc
je vous propose des éléments de réponse
sur les amendements de 39 472 475 724 et
74 donc certains des éléments que je
vais indiquer rappel un peu ce que vient
de dire monsieur le rapporteur mais en
synthèse le PLF propose cette réforme à
la suite d'une délibération vous l'avez
compris du CLF et le gouvernement
respecte sa décision premièrement
deuxièmement le critère de voir une
excusez-moi je n'entends pas ce que vous
dites donc je vous dis que simplement
notre position c'est de respecter la
décision du CFL deuxièmement le critère
de voirie ne pouvait pas être maintenu
le transfert de voirie était obligatoire
pour 1500 communes il fallait modifier
ce critère
troisièmement le nouveau critère de
spatialité qui reprend une notion
défendue par les sénateurs Charles
gainer et Claude Reynal et je salue leur
travail qui se critère de spatialité qui
me semble effectivement plus moderne à
population quatrième élément et on peut
ne pas partager les mêmes convictions
sans problème à population équivalente
une commune dans la superficie est plus
grande sera plus aidé et pour finir je
vous rappelle on l'a tous un peu dit
plus de 200 millions d'euros sur la DGF
95% des communes qui auront une hausse
de la DGF ou DGF identiques c'est
l'année où il fallait le faire compte
tenu de la contrainte que le critère de
voirie ne pouvait pas y être maintenu la
vie du gouvernement et donc défavorable
merci
merci Madame la Ministre alors
juste vous dire qu'on a déjà quatre
demandes d'explication de vote après la
prise de parole de monsieur le Président
rénal 5 même prise de parole et que
avant ces prises de parole nous demande
de prise de parole nous sommes à 10
amendements en 1h10 sans compter ses
prises de parole ça vous met en
perspective la suite donc que chacun
prenne la parole mais essayez de voilà
de condenser vos propos ça nous
permettra peut-être de ne parvenir en
deuxième semaine
donc
on commence par Monsieur Richard
madame la Présidente
c'est Monsieur Raynal
S et donc on peut on peut se tromper
d'abord intervenir en tant que président
voilà on va pas s'affoler le thème des
collectivités locales au Sénat est un
thème important et donc simplement on
prévoit que samedi matin on va se
retrouver pour finir tranquillement
voilà non parce que on va
absolument pas ah non non je sais le
dire quand c'est un peu non non je dis
il y a aucune chance voilà il y a aucune
chance donc c'est pas la peine d'essayer
de rentrer de toute force dans un temps
qu'on a pas voilà et je sais la passion
de tous pour le débat sur ces sujets pas
de problème donc je crois qu'on va se
préparer et ça serait un miracle dû à la
présidence
d'arriver à nous rentrer là-dedans donc
je n'y crois pas beaucoup et il faut s'y
préparer c'est pas une menace et on aura
beaucoup de plaisir à poursuivre ce
débat
et on rappellera pas des articles déjà
votés rassurez-vous en deuxième des
livres non on fera pas ça
sur le sujet indiqué voilà ce que je
veux dire par là c'est un sujet ça a été
dit je veux le redire c'est un sujet qui
a été pris de loin c'est pas d'ailleurs
moi je l'ai assez peu suivi ce débat là
parce qu'il était un peu mais c'est je
sais que mon collègue gainait sur les
effectivement tout ce qui est spatialité
etc
m'avait fait partager cet un nombre
d'idées moi ce que je crois surtout
c'est que vous savez comment c'est et
c'est une application grandeur nature
d'une part on connaît le vote à la
sortie on n'est pas dans un débat sur le
vote sincèrement on va pas convaincre
l'assemblée quasiment à unanime de voter
contre donc de retirer donc on sait lire
des amendements et quand on voit qu'ils
sont signés par tout le monde on sait le
traduire bon donc c'est pas le sujet de
mon intervention si j'ai mon
intervention c'est que chaque fois qu'on
modifie le moindre bout de quelque chose
et bien ceux qui sont touchés
remontent pour demander l'inversion
c'est un constat c'est un constat
l'association des meilleurs ruraux au
palacer a été convié aux travaux il n'y
a pas participé et ensuite aller
mécontente de l'accord bon c'est aussi
un constat voilà faut se le dire et
c'est compliqué de faire de fonctionner
comme ça si on peut pas avoir des débats
préliminaires pour essayer de trouver
des solutions
c'est compliqué ça va être compliqué
voilà et rassurez-vous dès l'instant où
on aura pris cette position vous aurez
le retour des maires concernées par ceux
qui avaient intérêt aujourd'hui qui vous
diront mais qu'est-ce que vous avez fait
vous êtes revenu sur un accord où on est
arrivé à peu près à trouver quelque
chose donc rassurez-vous personne sera
gagnant de cette affaire voilà tout ce
que je voulais vous dire et bien entendu
on gardera parce que c'est la position
de la Commission la vie de retrait mais
on ne regardera pas on se retournera pas
pour voir comment à quelle vitesse on
est mis en minorité
merci monsieur le Président alors
Monsieur Richard
madame la miss mes chers collègues
moi j'ai consigné un de ces amendements
donc je vous mettrai à l'aise je le vaut
très et je voterai naturellement les
autres également qui vont dans le même
sens
ce qui m'inquiète un peu c'est la
position
l'exposé des motifs de ces demandes de
retrait notamment monsieur le rapporteur
vous avez justifié cette demande de
retrait madame la ministre l'a fait
aussi par le fait que c'est le CFL qui
qui aurait proposé ce nouveau dispositif
nous permettrait de
ne pas considérer que c'est une bible
donc on a ici le droit de voter
autrement surtout lorsqu'on examine
pourquoi il s'agit semble-t-il ici c'est
ce que j'ai lu
quelque part de mieux je lis de mieux
corriger les situations pour lesquelles
le critère de la longueur de la voirie
crée des distorsions et si j'ai bien
compris moi j'allais poser la question
de savoir c'est quoi ces distorsions et
si j'ai bien compris ce que nous avions
monsieur le rapporteur c'est distorsion
toucherait essentiellement les communes
qui ont transféré leur voirie au
métropole
permettrait de dire que je me pose la
question de savoir si c'est toujours
bien lié à la ruralité tout ça où sont
les communes rurales
pourquoi ne tient-on pas compte plus les
communes rurales enfin clairement la DSR
c'est bien cela
on nous a dit aussi la DSR n'a pas pu
objective de financer l'entretien de la
voirie bien sûr pas seulement mais la
voirie lorsque vous avez
présidé au destiné d'une commune rurale
vous voyez bien à quel point c'est
important on l'a dit ce matin et et ce
matin
malheureusement Stéphane sotarell a
retiré un amendement qu'il avait proposé
que j'aurais d'ailleurs voté visant à
créer un fond spécial sur la voirie
alors madame la ministre j'ai bien
compris que quel que soit le vote ici on
aura derrière 49-3 etc on va pas
discuter sans ces temps mais madame la
ministre si vous m'entendez il faut
réfléchir à la possibilité de prendre en
compte le critère de longueur d'une
voirie d'une façon ou d'une autre un
fond spécial si vous le voulez ou non
mais c'est fondamental c'est essentiel
les communes rurales en ont besoin donc
indépendamment du vote il faut madame la
ministre que vous fassiez droit à cette
demande légitime des communes rurales
dans ce pays merci chers collègues
monsieur sotarel
[Applaudissements]
merci même la présidente madame la
ministre alors j'ai fait grâce de mes
deux minutes de temps de parole puisque
j'avais un amendement que j'ai retiré
avant la séance qui était similaire à
ceux de mes collègues pour renforcer le
poids de ceci mais bien évidemment je
soutiens la démarche et j'espère que le
débat permettra permettra d'avancer
effectivement la voirie est bien un
poste de charge majeur dans les charges
de la ruralité ça a été dit inutile de
le de le rappeler et j'espère que
l'amendement que j'ai retiré
avec difficulté ce matin mais j'espère
qu'il sera dans une démarche
constructive pour que nous puissions au
cours de l'année 2023 bâtir une réelle
réponse sur un for spécifique pour les
communes rurales au terme de la voirie
je veux aussi rappeler que tout ce qui
touche à la spatialité qui est
effectivement peut présenter un intérêt
me semble plus répondre à une
préoccupation de ressources que de
charge c'est à dire que d'examiner à
l'échelle spatiale par exemple la
richesse pour corriger des écarts qui
sont incompatibles avec la question de
la population
pas un rapport avec certaines charges
pourrait présenter un intérêt mais quand
on veut corriger des postes de charges
la voirie et le deuxième le troisième
poste de charge d'une collectivité donc
je défends ces amendements et je pense
que ça opérerait un transfert au
détriment de la ruralité profonde de
l'hyper ruralité de la vraie ruralité et
qui serait dommageable de revenir sur ce
critère je vous remercie merci
collègues j'aimerais vous rafraîchir la
mémoire
août 2018 août 2018 un pont s'écroule en
Italie plusieurs dizaines de morts suite
à cet accident l'Italie la commission
aménagement du territoire la reprise de
fin septembre mais en place une mission
d'enquête sur les ouvrages d'art en
France certaines d'entre nous on faisait
partie et cette mission qu'est-ce
qu'elle a mis les conséquences c'est que
on a mis au pied du mur les mers ruraux
en leur disant attention suite à cette
mission vous avez des ouvrages d'art sur
votre commune vous en avez désormais la
responsabilité et donc nous sommes un
peu responsables de ça donc
indirectement on a mis nos maires en
disant maintenant vous avez la réponse
c'est à vous d'agir et maintenant dans
les critères on va retirer le critère
voirie enfin à un moment donné mes chers
collègues on marche sur la tête
si monsieur corbizet nous passons à
Monsieur Delage
merci madame la Présidente d'abord
madame la ministre une observation de
forme j'ai cru entendre dans vos propos
que vous parliez de décision du Comité
des finances locales excusez moi le
comité du finance locale donne un avis
les décisions esprits ici je crois qu'il
faut le rappeler la deuxième observation
c'est que on parle de ruralité
une des caractéristiques de la ruralité
c'est un rapport particulier entre le
nombre d'habitants et le nombre de
kilomètres de voirie si vous commencez
par supprimer la voirie effectivement va
difficilement parler de la même chose la
troisième observation que que je
voudrais faire c'est que
les finances locales sont quand même
terriblement chamboulés
est-ce que vous croyez vraiment que
c'est le moment même si ça peut vous
paraître finalement à ces secondaires de
faire une réforme que vous nous
présentez comme une réforme technique
mais qui n'est pas une réforme technique
l'un des collègues tout à l'heure a
parlé de réforme symbolique je crois que
le symbole a aussi son importance je
pense donc voilà même un ministre que
c'est pas le moment de venir chambouler
un certain nombre de critères laisser
tranquille les mers en ce moment ils
aspirent à respirer et surtout que vous
vous occupiez un peu moins de réglementé
et un peu plus de les aider
alors
nous avons encore 6 prises de parole et
ça ne s'arrête pas donc je laisse la
parole à Monsieur je n'ai et puis si
vous pouviez vous contraindre dans vos
prises de parole ce serait pas mal merci
Monsieur Jeunet merci madame la
présidente madame la ministre tout
d'abord une confession d'iguane n'est
pas une commune rurale et donc je ne
siège pas dans un conseil municipal de
commune rurale mais j'ai présidé la
communauté de communes du Grand
Charolais et lorsque nous avons réfléchi
au pacte communautaire entre nous nous
avons tenu à intégrer la voirie comme
compétence communautaire parce que c'est
une compétence essentielle pour les
communes et en particulier pour les
communes rurales et c'est vrai qu'à la
fois sur la discussion que nous avons eu
ce matin sur le fond spécial voirie
proposé par notre collègue sottarel avec
son conditionnement aux communes de
moins de 500 habitants et réfléchissant
à ce que nous avions fait localement je
peux comprendre les arguments des
rapporteurs sur cette évolution
qu'effectivement aujourd'hui c'est de
voirie communale aujourd'hui elle n'est
pas forcément gérée tout le temps par
les communes elle peut être par
l'intercommunalité et il est vrai que ça
induit un certain nombre de différences
de traitement d'un territoire à l'autre
et donc je comprends tout à fait ce qui
a pu conduire à la réflexion préalable à
cette proposition de décision en
revanche madame la ministre
après avoir salué votre nouvelle
nomination avec vos nouvelles
compétences permettez-moi de vous dire
que si à la première journée de vos
fonctions ici au Sénat vous commencez à
nous expliquer que s'occuper de la
voirie dans des communes rurales ce
n'est pas moderne je ne suis pas sûr que
vous aurez un grand succès d'estime
auprès de beaucoup des maires ruraux
parce que derrière votre argument qui
était noté sur votre document préparé
par vos services il y a effectivement
cet argument qu'on entend partout et
tout le temps que la voirie ce ne serait
pas moderne lorsque vous allez en
commission DETR et si l'on vous dit on
ne peut pas prendre les travaux de
voirie parce que ce n'est pas moderne
dans beaucoup de départements ou de
région lorsque vous allez demander des
subventions pour la voirie on vous dit
ah ben non c'est pas moderne il y a la
transition écologique il y a tellement
d'autres choses à soutenir et on ne vous
donne pas de subventions pour la voirie
je crois au contraire que la voirie
c'est un outil essentiel pour garder de
la modernité
et donc au-delà du symbole il y a
également la ta grande sensibilité des
élus ruraux et des habitants à ces
sujets il faut absolument revoir votre
copie madame la ministre merci alors
Monsieur Canevet
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre chers collègues comme disait
Fabien Genet à l'instant la voirie c'est
quelque chose d'important dans nos
communes tout simplement parce que c'est
ce qui sert au déplacement à la mobilité
que ce soit individuelle que ce soit
collective que ce soit les déplacements
doux que ce soit tout en fait c'est le
lien entre la population dans les
communes donc c'est quelque chose qui
est extrêmement important et je crois
que pour ce qui concerne la modification
des critères des dotations il faut
l'effectuer avec beaucoup de précautions
et semble-t-il parce que ce qui a été
fait en la circonstance puisqu'on sait
bien nous les élus qui représentent les
territoires ici combien cette question
de la voirie est essentielle dans nos
communes alors moi je veux simplement
dire que au Comité des finances locales
il a notamment été argumenté le fait que
les élus dans nos communes seraient
incapables de connaître la longueur de
voirie moi je trouve cet argument qui a
été évoqué tout à fait anormal en tout
cas je crois qu'il faut faire les
confiance aux élus ils sa de quoi il
parle quand il gère les communes parce
que
ils sont près de de l'argent des
contribuables et donc ils le font avec
parcouronner donc je dis simplement
qu'il est important que l'on garde ce
critère de la voirie dans nos modes de
calcul de nos dotations
madame la présidente madame la ministre
monsieur le rapporteur moi je vais vous
dire je ne retirerai pas mon amendement
je sais pas ce que fera mon collègue
delcro parce que
c'est pas le Comité des finances locales
qui décide ici c'est le Sénat c'est
notre assemblée le Comité des finances
locales peut donner un avis
éventuellement mais il a pas décidé pour
nous
deuxièmement la longueur de varie c'est
factuel c'est-à-dire que
on connaît tous les longueurs de voirie
dans nos communes je suis désolé parce
que ça ça impacte quand même les
finances de notre de notre budget
et puis je pense que finalement il faut
il faut vraiment que cette longueur de
voirie soit reste un critère défini dans
la DSR alors je suis désolé monsieur le
rapporteur mais je pense que au regard
de tout ce qu'on vient de dire il est
important de pouvoir conserver parce que
finalement comment faire simple quand on
peut faire compliqué c'est un peu ça les
on veut changer les critères mais ça va
poser d'autres problèmes où il y aura
des effets de seuil il y aura les
perdants des alors qu'on a un critère
qui est déjà là depuis très longtemps
je pense qu'il faut que vraiment
conserver la longueur de voirie merci à
vous
si monsieur delcro
madame la ministre c'est vraiment à la
ministre en charge de la ruralité que je
voudrais m'adresser au-delà du vote
auquel nous allons auquel nous allons
procéder parce que ce n'est pas par
hasard si des voix si on débat d'abord
longtemps sur sujet et si des voix
s'élève sur tous les bancs surtout les
bancs du Sénat parce que évidemment il y
a le travail du comité des finances
locales je n'y reviens pas mais ce que
vous entendez là c'est la voix des
territoires on est dans la chambre des
territoires ce qu'on vous fait remonter
c'est le vécu sur le terrain des
sénateurs au quotidien tout au long de
l'année dans leur territoire et
notamment dans les territoires ruraux et
aujourd'hui le critère voirie c'est pas
le critère principal de répartition de
la DSR c'est un critère parmi d'autres
même pas majoritaire qui compte à 30%.
les autres critères prennent en compte
la population il y a quatre critères si
demain on remplace le critère de la
longueur de voirie par un critère qui
fait encore entrer en ligne de compte la
population ça veut dire qu'on aura
quatre critères fondés sur sur un sur la
population
la population et le potentiel financier
la population et les forces fiscales la
population avec le critère qu'on fait
rentrer même si il y en a d'autres il y
a la population qui intervient et le
nombre d'enfants entre 0 et 500 mais
c'est directement lié à la population
donc on a un seul critère sur un sujet
qui est majeur dans les communes rurales
qui est la principale préoccupation des
maires ruraux on peut vous le dire on le
vit au quotidien tout au long de l'année
donc s'il vous plaît au-delà du vote
d'aujourd'hui entendez-nous essayer de
prendre en compte cette demande qui vous
est faite je pense à peu près à
l'unanimité par le Sénat pour maintenir
le critère de longueur Loiry tel qu'il
est aujourd'hui merci
si Monsieur delcro monsieur lourd
[Applaudissements]
oui madame la ministre de la ruralité
j'ai connu la DETR au départ voté par
enfin décidé par Pasqua
c'était essentiellement des communes
rurales aujourd'hui dans mon département
272 communes
267 ont droit à la deetr la dotation de
solidarité rurale par ses nouveaux
critères reviendra une dotation
essentiellement pour les villes parce
que c'est là où il y a le plus
d'habitants c'est là où il y a plus de
jeunes on fait des lois pour les
territoires ruraux et on s'empresse dans
le temps de les détruire c'est
inacceptable
si Monsieur loup madame espanyac
oui madame la ministre moi je voudrais
déjà vous féliciter pour votre
nomination je connais votre capacité des
coupes et donc j'en appelle à vous parce
que on parle de ruralité on parle de
montagne aussi je donne un exemple quand
on est une petite commune en montagne
avec 70 km de voirie comment fait-on
quand en effet on ne peut plus abonder
sur la detrs même sur la réserve
parlementaire il fut un temps où on
pouvait aider les communes sur la
réserve parlementaire ce n'est plus le
cas voilà donc moi j'en appelle à votre
bon sens je le connais et donc c'est
pour ça que je me permets de vous saisir
parce que il n'est pas possible
aujourd'hui de soustraire ce critère qui
est essentiel voilà donc certains de mes
collègues on va parler de critères de
modernité moi je vais vous dire c'est un
vraiment c'est un critère de sécurité
pour les habitants au quotidien je
rappelle que la montagne il y a de la
neige il y a plein de choses nous avons
besoin de de voirie qui sont en état et
donc j'en appelle à votre bon sens merci
la parole est à Madame Cu Kerman oui
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre
simplement pour dire et peut-être sans
surprise mais avec quelques explications
que nous allons voter ces amendements
tout d'abord parce que comme je l'ai dit
ce matin la question de la voirie est
intracitement liée au développement y
compris des plus petites communes et
alors on peut continuer de disserter sur
ce qui est du fait d'être moderne ou de
ne pas être moderne je vais le dire très
tranquillement ici parce que je pense
que l'on peut me taxer de beaucoup de
choses sauf être de sel qui ne
défendraient pas les services publics
demain mais il y a une réalité
c'est que le service public du transport
collectif madame la ministre je m'excuse
je le fais rarement mais juste si je
vous dérange vous me le dites c'est que
à un moment donné on ne fera pas du
service public collectif de transport de
partout et dans toutes les communes et
donc nous aurons besoin
de toutes les façons de partout d'avoir
des voiries de qualité pour assurer le
déplacement et la mobilité pourquoi
parce que nous avons collectivement un
impératif qui est de tenter non pas
d'empêcher ce serait certainement trop
orgueilleux de dire ça mais en tout cas
de limiter demain l'aggravation de la
fracture territoriale dans notre pays et
j'oserais vous dire Madame la Ministre
ça ne va peut-être pas plaire à certains
ici mais vous savez je me souviens il y
a quelques années
tous ceux qui ont voulu remettre en
cause les critères territoriaux pour ne
garder que les critères de population ça
n'a jamais été une réussite
et ça n'a jamais été une réussite parce
que ça ne répond pas à l'enjeu premier
qui est d'accompagner la vie des femmes
et des hommes qui vivent et qui
travaillent sur nos territoires et je
crois que c'est de cela que nous avons
besoin comme light motif comme
finalement phare pour nous guider et
sincèrement oui nouveau transfertment
parce que la proposition que vous faites
n'est pas adéquate aux besoins des
populations merci Madame Gatel vous avez
la parole
si madame la présidente madame la
ministre monsieur le Président de la
Commission je suis désolé qu'on rallonge
le temps mais nous on n'avait rien
demandé donc on aurait pu gagner du
temps si on n'est pas ouvert ce débat
qui est quand même un vrai sujet madame
la ministre pardonnez-moi avec l'amitié
que j'ai pour vous on va pas vous
décrire ce qu'est la ruralité
vous en êtes encore si je filais si vous
êtes encore ministre bon on a un sujet
très simple est-ce qu'on peut se parler
en français
y compris au Comité des finances locales
une dotation de solidarité rurale c'est
une dotation de solidarité rurale la
ruralité se caractérise par un habitat
dispersé très étendu parce qu'il y a des
fermes et donc pour rejoindre la ferme
au bourg il y a des routes et que les
routes sont extrêmement modernes puisque
maintenant on met des unités de
méthanisation dans les exploitations
agricoles et il y a des camions qui
doivent circuler il y a un seul critère
sur la dotation de a été rural qui est
vraiment rural c'est la longueur de
voirie plus vous êtes petit plus vous
avez de la longueur de voirie il n'y a
aucune subvention sur la voirie alors
qu'on vienne bricoler un truc pour y
remettre des habitants et de la densité
c'est venir introduire ce que j'appelle
un vice caché dans une dotation qui est
clairement ciblée et claire et que mes
collègues l'ont dit aujourd'hui la
voirie elle dépend de la déclaration des
élus ruraux mais madame la ministre ils
sont allés à l'école les mers euros ils
savent mesurer une longueur de voirie et
si l'administration n'a pas confiance
elle envoie un contrôleur
alors en plus vous avez inventé un
critère extrêmement compliqué ça ne va
pas quant aux communes qui aurait confié
la voirie aux métropole je répète plus
désagréable que je ne l'était mais les
métropoles ont des dotations largement
supérieures aux communautés de communes
et qu'il convienne conviendrait de
rééquilibrer donc moi je pense que c'est
tellement flou qu'il y a plusieurs loups
dans cette affaire et qu'on gagnerait à
rester là où on en était merci merci
chers collègues madame douanot
merci madame la Présidente je voudrais
tout d'abord saluer votre nomination
madame la ministre et vous dire tout
simplement alors je sais pas si vous
m'écoutez
je voulais saluer votre nomination
madame la ministre et vous dire tout
simplement que il y a la France des RER
mais il y a aussi la France des
territoires ruraux et que pour faire du
lien nous avons besoin de bien et que au
détour de de cette question il faut
vraiment changer les choses et revenir
sur cette décision parce que ça ne peut
pas convenir au tout début j'ai été
maire d'une commune rurale et je sais
combien ça pèse sur nos budgets et donc
n'enlevez pas ce critère ce serait une
aberration merci merci alors nous avons
fini cette longue liste de prise de
parole nous alors si certains souhaitent
retirer leurs amendements qu'ils le
signal personne ne retire son amendement
et donc je vais je vais mettre aux voix
tout d'abord les quatre amendements
identiques
39472 475 724 qui ont reçu de deux avis
défavorables qui est pour
qui est contre
qui s'abstient ils sont adoptés et les
autres tombes
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
deux amendements faisons l'objet d'une
discussion commune le 209 rectifié
monsieur Delcros
il est défendu
oui pardon cet amendement concerne les
ligibilité à la DETR les communes sont
depuis qu'elle a été créée d'ailleurs il
y a un certain nombre de critères des
disciplinités à la DETR parmi les
critères d'éligibilité il y en a un qui
concerne le potentiel financier pour
être éligible pour une commune de plus
de 2000 habitants pour pouvoir être
éligible à la dot elle doit avoir un
potentiel financier par habitant
inférieur à 1,3 fois le potentiel
financier moyen de l'astre et puis les
intercommunalités surmontées en
puissance ont été éligibles à la DETR
sauf qu'au passage
on a oublié quelque chose en route si je
peux dire parce qu'aujourd'hui vous avez
des intercommunalités des grandes
communautés d'agglomération de plus de
75000 habitants et l'egibles à la DETR
pour lesquels on applique pas le critère
du potentiel financier alors qu'on va
l'appliquer à une commune de 2200
habitants ça veut dire qu'on exclut des
petites communes d'un peu plus de 2000
habitants de la DETR au motif du
potentiel financier alors qu'on explique
on applique pas ce critère pour des
grandes interco de plus 75000 habitants
donc cet amendement il vise simplement à
corriger cette injustice et appliquer le
même critère pour les grandes intercos
que pour les communes de plus de 2000
habitants merci Monsieur Delcros
le oui nous venons d'avoir une très
longue discussion qui est aboutit un
vote quasi unanime de notre assemblée
pour préserver les moyens des communes
rurales et bien l'amendement qui est
défendu là par mon collègue delcro et
moi-même va tout à fait dans le même
sens et vise à restreindre éligibilité
des EPCI à la dotation d'équipement des
territoires ruraux on introduisant un
nouveau critère d'éligibilité
le présente amendement propose d'exclure
les EPCI dont le potentiel fiscal par
habitant est supérieur à 1,3 fois le
potentiel fiscal moyen par habitant des
EPCI de leur catégorie il s'agit ainsi
d'appliquer
assez établissements publics et
coopération intercommunale un critère de
ressources qui serait proche de celui
qui est déjà prévu pour déterminer les
gibitier des communes tout en prenant en
compte les différences de potentiels
fiscales entre catégories de PC voilà
c'est un moyen de resserrer ce que
bloqué tout à l'heure l'éligibilité à la
DETR des communes et des EPCI qui en ont
le plus besoin on y reviendra d'ailleurs
dans le prochain amendements tout à
l'heure merci Monsieur Marie alors nous
passons à la vie de la Commission et
peut-être avant que monsieur le
rapporteur nous donne son avis quand
même vous dire que si nous continuons à
ce rythme donc la discussion s'arrêtera
à 20h avant l'article 45
bis pardon et les amendements qui
suivent et bien seront réservés pour
examiner samedi voilà
donc moi comme ça tout le monde est
informé donc maintenant monsieur le
rapporteur
nous poursuivons sur un nouveau débat
alors
l'introduction d'un critère de potentiel
financier pour le bénéfice de la DETR
donc
ces deux c'est de faire en sorte que les
ligibilité des EPCI
par un critère de potentiel financier
comme c'est déjà le cas pour les
communes alors
pour la Commission et nous paraît pas
opportun de durcir l'éligibilité là de
terre à plus forte raison s'appuyant sur
des critères de richesse fiscale car si
les indicateurs financiers sont
évidemment indispensables faute de mieux
comme modalités de calcul de répartition
des dotations de fonctionnement mais
compte tenu de leur caractère très
largement périmés nous sommes plutôt
opposés à un accroissement de leur
influence sur les dotations
d'investissement qui ne sont d'ailleurs
pas ce sont des dotations
d'investissement et il faut pas leur
faire jouer le rôle de dotation de
péréquation c'est à dire qu'il y a un
risque de mélange entre finalement la
possibilité d'obtenir des dotations
d'investissement et d'autre part le
système de péréquation je vous rappelle
enfin que le préfet dispose toujours de
la possibilité et je crois qu'il le fait
de la possibilité de tenir compte de la
situation financière des communes entre
autres et donc des EPCI dans ces choix
d'attribution donc finalement ce que je
veux dire que c'est que très souvent
dans notre assemblée on est pour la
simplification
pour trouver des solutions là encore
proposer avec le rapporteur général
permettant de trouver avec peu de
critères des solutions et là on vient
encore une fois rajouter de nous-mêmes
un élément supplémentaire de complexité
alors que aujourd'hui le préfet et les
commissions d'attributions ont tout
moyen de
d'allouer sur les communes sur les EPCI
dans le cas précis canon le plus besoin
et pour ceux qui concerne la mienne j'ai
vérifié c'est toujours le cas
c'est-à-dire que on tient compte
évidemment de la capacité de l'EP ou la
capacité évidemment de la commune à
financer ses investissements et on vient
de voir donc venir rajouter des critères
supplémentaires je crois que c'est
contraire à notre philosophie depuis
toujours
merci monsieur le rapporteur oui dans la
décision commune il y en a il y en a un
deuxième et comme il est pas écrit de la
même façon mais il revient au même
principe donc même réponse et demande de
retrait madame la ministre avis du
gouvernement
madame la Présidente vous remercie donc
sur ces deux amendements et en
complément de ce que vient de dire
monsieur le président et rapporteur en
fait c'est un moment pour y conduire
notamment à exclure près de 150 EPCI du
bénéfice de la DETR donc là
l'opinion du gouvernement et de
recommander le retrait sinon avis
défavorable merci
alors Monsieur Delcros
oui juste un petit mot pour dire qu'il
s'agit pas de créer un système
supplémentaire il s'agit d'appliquer aux
grandes communautés d'agglomération de
plus en 15000 habitants les mêmes règles
qu'aux petites communes qui ont un peu
plus de 2000 habitants c'est tout on
invent en inventent rien et
effectivement ça ferait sortir un
certain nombre de PCI des éligibilité du
coup du coup ça reste ça renforcerait
l'enveloppe pour les autres mais c'est
ce qui se passe aujourd'hui pour les
communes c'est ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui pour les communes
donc vous le maintenez monsieur dELCON
on est d'accord donc je mets
il y a une explication de vote
monsieur rénal
à force de bloquer les choses et de trop
les contraintes le risque c'est qu'on
est moins de gens éligible que dans vos
loop
et je m'excuse mais quand vous sortez
autant de PCI de la possibilité de la
possibilité de l'éligibilité vous avez
tout simplement un risque à ce que
l'enveloppe soit pas consommé
évidemment que ça existe tu peux dire
non Bernard mais c'est la réalité
alors s'il n'y a plus de demandes
d'explication de votre je vais mettre
aux voix l'amendement
209 rectifié qui a reçu un avis
défavorable de la commission et du
gouvernement qui est pour
qui est contre
qui s'abstient il est adopté
on va recompter mais il faut bien lever
la main parce que là très honnêtement
tout le monde n'a pas levé le bras donc
on recommence si vous voulez qui est
pour
levez bien les bras
qui est contre
qui s'abstient
il est adopté
et l'autre tombe
trois amendements identiques faisant
l'objet d'une discussion commune et nous
avons le 229 rectifié pour commencer
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre monsieur le rapporteur c'est
amendement vise à rendre plus réel les
délibérations de répartition
dérogatoires des prélèvements et
attributions du SPIC il vise à favoriser
le développement des modalités
alternatives de répartition interne du
SPIC au sein du territoire et en cela
cet amendement s'inscrit n'est-ce pas
dans le droit fil des analyses
développées notamment dans l'excellent
rapport sénatorial du gainé rénale
d'octobre 2021 et intitulé pour un fond
de péréquation des ressources
intercommunales et communales plus
proches des réalités locales il existe
trois freins à une plus grande mise en
oeuvre de répartition dérogatoire mais
je vais vous passer le détail en tout
cas cet amendement propose donc aux
exécutifs locaux d'avoir la possibilité
de faire en sorte que les délibérations
puissent par tacite reconduction
demeurer valable tant qu’une
délibération contraire souhaiter
localement ne rendent pas caduc il
conduit à ce que les délibérations ne
soient plus fondées sur les répartitions
en valeur absolue mais sur des côtes
parts de répartition je précise que cet
abonnement étaient déposé par Madame
micolo merci Monsieur hangler le 318
colo était parfaitement défendu par
Jean-Claude merci Monsieur Brisson le
468 qui est aussi un identique c'est
Monsieur benaroche qu'il présente
à la défense qui a été présenté
merci
monsieur le rapporteur avis de la
commission
bon dans la réalité comme cela était
cité il y a un excellent rapport de mon
collègue Guinée de moi-même donc je vous
y renvoie et dans les préconisations
nous préconisions cela donc on peut pas
être hostile ça ça va de soi on y est
même on aura donc un avis de sagesse
comme je l'ai indiqué tout à l'heure sur
cette position une sagesse assez
favorable cela étant dit nous avons dit
ça dans les objectifs il n'en demeure
pas moins vrai que nous avons un petit
souci constitutionnel sur possible en
tout cas sur cette affaire dans la
mesure où il y a le principe de libre
administration des collectivités
territoriales est appréciée de manière
assez raide par par le Conseil
constitutionnel et il considère que il
faudrait renouveler assez régulièrement
le cet accord et non pas avoir une
vision plus réelle
de l'accord bon donc il faut le savoir
c'est pour cela que nous donnons à
[Musique]
merci madame la Présidente
donc nous traitons des trois amendements
318 et 468 vous proposez de rendre plus
réel les délibérations de répartition
dérogatoires des prélèvements et des
reversements au titre du pic afin de
favoriser le développement des modalités
alternatives de répartition interne du
pic au sein du territoire si votre
amendement peut permettre de concourir à
une meilleure appropriation de la
répartition interne du pic par les
ensembles intercommunaux et de
simplifier les procédures de répartition
alternatives du fait qu'il pourrait en
revanche poser des difficultés dans des
situations spécifiques en effet d'un
exercice à l'autre en fonction de
l'évolution des indicateurs financiers
et des territoires ou des mouvements du
périmètre intercommunal les montants des
contributions et des attributions au
titre du pic d'un ensemble intercommunal
peuvent évoluer à la hausse ou à la
baisse de même le contexte politique
ayant prévalu à l'adoption d'une
répartition alternative du pic et la
situation individuelle
collectivités locales et d'un
établissement intercommunal peuvent
profondément changer nécessitant de
revoir les modalités de répartition
interne du pic dans ces conditions il
est préférable que les ensembles
intercommunaux possèdent en amont tous
les éléments nécessaires y compris les
résultats de la répartition du droit
commun pour prendre une décision
dérogatoire éclairée haut de mes rang au
demeurant la procédure d'adoption relève
du niveau réglementaire je partage
néanmoins l'objectif que vous recherchez
demeure ouverte à approfondir la
réflexion sur ce sujet pouvant aboutir
sur une évolution des dispositions
réglementaires régissant l'adoption des
répartitions dérogatoires comme la
suggéré monsieur le président et
rapporteur
donc c'est retraits ou défavorable pour
vous Madame la Ministre
et pour la commission une sagesse
sagesse favorable de la commission alors
je mets aux voix les trois amendements
identiques 229-318 468 qui ont reçu une
sagesse favorable de la commission un
avis défavorable du gouvernement qui est
pour
qui contre qui s'abstient ils sont
adoptés le 586 madame ku Kerman merci
madame la présidente madame la ministre
je j'oserais vous dire que je suis un
peu embêté avec la présentation de cet
amendement sans faire ici de la
légistique et revenir sur l'organisation
de nos travaux mais de fait dès lors que
les amendements précédents ont été
adoptés
celui-ci pourrait devenir caduc mais
comme il n'a pas été crantée
initialement sur les mêmes alinéasques
les précédents et que pour autant il
parlait de l'âme du même objectif qui
est aujourd'hui de la question de
l'évolution du SPIC et finalement de ça
nécessaire refonte pour pas dire de sa
création absurde en son origine et de
comme toute création de départ qui porte
en elle un péché originel peut toujours
être corrigé mais jamais finalement
répondre et solutionner à la difficulté
j'ai pressé précédemment déjà dit que
j'en avais perdu mon latin j'oserais
dire maintenant qu'on pourra en perdre
son grec mais plus sérieusement parce
que je crois que depuis ce matin nous
sommes confrontés à une vraie difficulté
c'est à dire que nous avons un débat
il fait que les parlementaires que nous
sommes somme saisie dans nos territoires
sur un certain nombre de problématiques
que nous rédigeons et que nous déposons
parfois y compris en lien avec les
associations d'élus un certain nombre
d'amendements que chacun va positionner
là où le cela lui semble pertinent et
que nous aurions besoin pour le coup et
je vais aussi interpeller monsieur le
président de la commission des finances
parfois à des vrais discussions avec les
auteurs des amendements pour voir
comment est-ce qu'on peut les recrenter
ensemble et avoir une discussion
intelligente intelligible collectivement
sur un sujet commun tout comme à
l'inverse parfois on pourrait avoir une
discussion intelligente intelligible
pour nous inviter à repositionner des
amendements pour s'empêcher que un
amendement soit retiré parce que de fait
il pourrait faire tomber d'autres
amendements qui ne sont pas sans rapport
donc puisque j'ai utilisé mon temps de
parole et je m'en excuse auprès de mes
collègues que personne n'a envie de
revenir samedi matin j'économiser le
temps du président comme de la ministre
en retirant mon amendement après vouloir
présenter je vous remercie si chers
collègues le 586 est retiré le 1046
monsieur le rapporteur c'est un
rédactionnel
le 1046 il est défendu c'est un
rédactionnel madame la ministre avis du
gouvernement favorable merci je mets
donc aux voix la maman rédactionnelle du
rapporteur le 1046 avec un avis
favorable du gouvernement qui est pour
qui est contre qui s'appe c'est adopté
le 689 monsieur Rambaud merci madame la
Présidente alors après avoir longuement
et justement parler de DSR on va parler
un petit peu de dotation politique de la
ville je rappelle que la dotation
politique de la ville c'est une dotation
d'investissement qui est qui est versée
aux communes qui remplissent
simultanément trois conditions avoir
fait partie au moins une fois au cours
des trois dernières années des communes
les mieux classées au titre de la DSU
présenter une forte proportion de
population résident quartier prioritaire
de la politique de la ville et faire
partie du périmètre de la politique de
la ville ce dernier critère est apprécié
au travers de l'existence le territoire
communal d'une convention plus réelle
avec l'enru au 1er janvier de l'année
précédente précédant la répartition
chaque année plusieurs communes perdent
leur éligibilité à la DPV en raison de
la fin de validité de la convention
qu'elles ont conclu avec la rue et ce
alors même que perdu sur leur territoire
des dysfonctionnements urbains que la
DPV pour vocation de contribuer à
corriger aussi se présente amendement ce
gel donc l'appréciation de l'existence
d'une convention en rue active sur le
territoire communal au 1er janvier 2021
de sorte que les les communes qui
auraient dû perdre leur le bénéfice de
cette dotation politique de la ville en
2023 en raison de la fin de leur
convention en rue demeureront éligible
si elle remplissent les deux autres
critères merci
merci Monsieur Rombeau monsieur le
rapporteur vous avez la parole
merci donc le présentement de mon visa
suspendre l'appréciation de l'existence
d'une convention en rue active sur le
territoire communal au 1er janvier 2021
pour déterminer les éligibilité à DPV
alors
de manière générale on aurait sans doute
pas fait droit mais pour pour la période
que nous connaissons un tel moratoire
peut sembler au porteur alors qu'une
réflexion d'ensemble sur le zonage des
politiques de la ville est à l'étude
pour l'année 2023 mais on va évidemment
interroger madame la ministre pour nous
confirmer que c'est bien le cas et que
ça permettrait à ce moment-là
effectivement d'attendre d'avoir les
nouveaux hommages afin de relancer avant
de relancer ceci et d'éviter que des
pertes des communes perdent la DPV en
attendant
donc on est un peu dans un quelque chose
d'un peu particulier pour un moment
particulier
[Musique]
c'est bien le cas à vie favorable du
Gouvernement
donc avis favorable du Gouvernement
favorable de la commission je mets au
voile le 689 avec ses deux avis
favorables qui est pour
qui contre qui s'abstient il est adopté
le 20 il est défendu par monsieur le
rapporteur
un moment de coordination
avis du gouvernement
avis du gouvernement sur l'amendement de
la commission favorable
retrait sinon rejet s'il vous plaît
demande de retrait sinon des favorable
je mets aux voix la maman de la
commission qui a reçu un avis
défavorable du gouvernement qui est pour
qui contre qui s'abstient il est je
refais voter qui est pour l'amendement
de la commission
qui est contre il est adopté trois
amendements identiques faisant l'objet
d'une discussion commune 46 rectifié bis
merci la Présidente je défends un
amendement proposé par notre collègue
bourquieux fonds
financiers fiscaux utilisés pour le
calcul de la dotation d'intercommunalité
des EPCI à fiscalité propre ont été
bouleversées par la suppression de la
taxe d'habitation évidemment mais aussi
d'une partie significative des
impositions économiques la plausible
suppression de la CVAE annoncé par le
gouvernement vient perturber à nouveau
les modalités de calcul de cette
dotation pourtant ni les lois de
finances pour 2021 et 2022 ni le PLF
pour 2023 ne comporte de mesures de
correction des critères financiers et
fiscaux des intercommunalités aucune
mesure spécifique sur le sujet n'est
énoncé cet amendement propose donc de
sécuriser les impacts des dernières
réformes fiscales sur l'ensemble des
intercommunalités en leur garantissant
de percevoir au moins 100% de la
dotation par habitant perçut l'année
presse précédente pardon en 2023 et 2024
ce qui leur permettra d'avoir un peu de
visibilité et je vous rends une minute
madame la président merci chers
collègues alors nous passons au 428
identiques madame Gatel
merci madame la Présidente donc les
réformes récentes de fiscalité taxe
d'habitation
CFE et TFB et demain la CVAE ont des
conséquences sur les critères financiers
et fiscaux pour le calcul de la dotation
d'intercommunalité des EPCI pour
neutraliser ces réformes fiscales sur
les indicateurs financiers notamment des
piscines il y a eu un groupe de travail
qui s'est mis en place pour permettre
que la DGF et là enfin l'équivalent pour
les autres piscines ne soient pas
impactés or il y a un élément qui un
élément qui n'a été pas qui n'a pas été
prise en compte c'est tout ce qui est
très aussi fait au potentiel fiscal et
donc on a un certain nombre de PCI à
fiscalité propre il y en a 421 qui sont
concernés par une garantie de dotation
d'intercommunalité en 2022 dont 299 qui
ont vu cette garantie
enfin diminuer sérieusement ce qui fait
une perte de plus de 6 millions 560000
euros donc ce que nous demandons par cet
amendement et dans l'attente d'une étude
d'impact approfondie c'est de sécuriser
les impacts des dernières réformes
fiscales en garantissant de percevoir au
moins 100% de la dotation par habitant
perçue l'année précédente en 2023 et
2024 ça donne de la visibilité madame la
ministre ça ne coûte pas un centime je
vous remercie collègue monsieur Marie
pour le 625 toujours identique oui c'est
exactement le même il a été élaboré avec
l'AMF et donc il est défendu merci
Monsieur Marie je passe maintenant à
l'avis de la commission sur ces trois
amendements
la vie de la commission c'est une
demande de retrait sur ces trois
amendements
alors quand je vois le nombre de
signataires je commence à m'inquiéter
pas sur je suis pas sûr d'être
totalement suivi mais quand même mais
quand même alors
donc le présentement situé une garantie
de non baisse de la dotation
d'intercommunalité en 2023 et 2024
alors il est d'abord à noter que la
dotation d'intercommunalité fait déjà
l'objet d'une garantie qui n'est certes
pas à 100% son montant ne peut baisser
de plus de 100% par rapport à l'année
précédente ce dispositif joue en
pratique le même rôle que la fraction de
correction pondérée par un coefficient
dégressif mis en place s'agissant des
intercommunes des indicateurs communaux
en fait
c'est si on a adopté cet amendement
c'est fait pour les intercommunalités un
système une garantie à 100% qui
n'existerait que pour les
intercommunalités premier sujet
c’est-à-dire que lorsqu'on est sur les
communes ben on est dans un tunnel on
n'est pas dans on est en plus simple
moins 5 là on aurait un espèce de
comment dire quelque chose qui serait
extraordinaire du droit commun deuxième
sujet ça coûte pas 1 euro à 10 Françoise
Gatel alors à l'état c'est vrai mais aux
autres PCI bien sûr ça coûte c'est à
dire que ceux qui gagnent évidemment
gagnerait moins voilà puisqu'il faudrait
garantir les autres voilà c'est toujours
des jeux à son menu voilà pour quelques
gagnants il y a beaucoup de perdants je
le rappelle donc maintenant
vous voudrez bien passer au vote merci
monsieur le rapporteur je vais mettre
aux voix à pardon à vue du gouvernement
je suis trop pressée
ou bien défavorable si alors
je mets au voir pas d'explication de
vote je mets aux voix les trois
amendements identiques qui ont reçu un
avis
défavorable de la commission et du
gouvernement ou retrait sur certains
souhaitent les retirer et donc
qui est pour
qui est contre qui s'abstient ils sont
adoptés
trois amendements identiques qui font
l'objet d'une discussion
mais s'ils sont adopter
bien sûr
il y a pas
[Musique]
et oui
moi je veux bien aller faire voter comme
tout à l'heure mais je vous garantis que
ici on voit clairement les choses il y
avait massivement plus de voix pour que
contre
alors je recommence le 131 rectifié bis
alors c'est Monsieur viole qu'il défend
oui merci madame la Présidente mes chers
collègues cet amendement concerne la
dotation de la terre communalité et
revient sur le débat que nous avons eu
suite à l'amendement de Madame Loisier
tout à l'heure c'est en fait la question
de la différence entre potentiellement
et concrètement on a un certain nombre
de communautés de communes qui
potentiellement devrait toucher une
certaine dotation d'intercommunalité en
fonction de critères qui ont été fixés
et concrètement qui ne la touche pas
potentiellement certaines devraient
toucher le double de ce qu'elle touche
réellement concrètement elle touche la
moitié de ce à quoi elles auraient droit
c'est donc une question de justice que
d'essayer de pallier à cela tout à
l'heure madame Loisier proposait un
déplafonnement en tout cas un
plafonnement à 120 à 120% puisque c'est
cette limite de 110% qui empêche ses
communes de progresser dans cet
amendement nous proposons par sagesse
j'allais dire de pouvoir déplafonner ce
rattrapage pour les comités de communes
rurales les plus fragiles et donc nous
mettons des critères pour des
communautés de communes de moins de 20
000 habitants qui ont un potentiel
fiscal par habitant inférieur au
potentiel fiscal moyen
et en faisant cela nous permettons à ces
comité de communes les plus fragiles de
pouvoir rattraper dès l'année prochaine
la dotation auquel elles ont normalement
le droit mais qu'elle n'aurait
concrètement pas si nous n'arrivions pas
à mettre en place ce système de
rattrapage ça concerne un peu plus de
d'une cinquantaine de communauté de
communes donc c'est un effort qui est
somme toute modeste mais qui est fait
c'est un amendement de justice pour
permettre à ces communautés de communes
de toucher plus rapidement la somme
auquel elles auraient le droit
merci Monsieur Vial le 429 rectifié
madame Gatel
ma solidarité à Cédric Vial qui a
brillamment défendu les choses mais je
voudrais juste rappeler un principe
c'est qu'à un moment on a évoqué avec
justice et justesse la nécessité de
faire converger les dotations selon les
catégories d'intercaux l'écart étant
très important entre les métropoles et
les communautés de communes l'intention
était bonne mais à un moment le chemin
est pavé d'un certain nombre de prises
de conscience qui a fait que pour
maintenir et ne pas pénaliser les
métropoles dans leur dotation en quelque
sorte on est venu pénaliser les plus
petits et les plus faibles donc nous en
fait c'est un effort de justice que nous
demandons encore une fois un rééquilibre
au sein de l'enveloppe je vous remercie
merci chers collègues le 626 monsieur
Marie merci Madame Présidente
je souscris l'argumentation qui a été
développée par mes deux collègues
précédemment
je n'ajouterai que deux éléments tout
d'abord quand on prend en compte les
hypothèses qui ont été évoquées à
l'instant avec les données de DGF 2021
ce serait 62 communautés de communes qui
auraient été concernées pour un montant
total de 8 millions 200000 euros en 2022
et cette mesure c'est le deuxième
élément ne représente pas de dépenses
supplémentaires pour le budget de l'État
car elle sera financée en une année par
l'accroissement annuel de la dotation
d'intercommunalité et de boulevard Sarah
donc pas l'enveloppe de la dotation
intercommunalité en 2023 et c'est donc
une mesure qui va effectivement dans le
sens de plus d'égalité de justice entre
nos intercommunalités en particulier à
l'égard des communautés de communes
merci Monsieur Marie avis de la
commission monsieur le rapporteur
oui enfin je sais pas trop si ça vaut le
coup maintenant de donner des avis bon
je le dis en toute tranquillité mais
non mais à un moment donné je vous le
dis il faudra regarder ce qu'on vote et
en fonction de ce qu'on vote faire la
liste des intercommunalités concernés de
part et d'autre vous allez avoir des
surprises donc
non non ça marche pas mais c'est comme
ça voilà mais quand même je le dis
donc la garantie à 100% c'est ahurissant
mais cela étant dit celui-là en était
par contre sur un avis favorable le coup
le et oui non mais voilà il faut savoir
attendre les trucs là effectivement
c'est une mesure d'égalité là c'est une
mesure en faveur des EPCI les plus les
plus faibles dotés et le coup pour
l'ensemble du système c'est 7 à 8
millions d'euros voilà nous on est
plutôt sur 7
nos collègues a dit 8 on est plutôt sur
7 millions c'est-à-dire moins de 1% de
la dotation à répartir voilà là on est
dans quelque chose de raisonnable c'est
dommage madame Gatel que vous ayez
présenté le premier
merci
merci monsieur le rapporteur madame la
ministre a vie du gouvernement
merci madame la Présidente donc sur les
trois
sur les trois
la position du gouvernement est donc
sagesse
voilà avec quelques petits un petit
rapidement
le dispositif est ciblé sur près d'une
cinquantaine de communauté de communes
un coup estimé comme ça vient d'être dit
à 7,5 millions d'euros serait
directement imputé au sein de
l'enveloppe de la dotation
d'intercommunalité avec un effet
d'éviction sur les autres EPCI et donc
il faut nécessairement mesurer les
conséquences comme ça vient d'être dit
ce dispositif bénéficierez à des EPCI
dans la dotation augmentera déjà de 10%
2023 ce qui n'est pas négligeable merci
mais on vient de voir des chiffres et
des chiants quand même on nous a
expliqué durant des années et on
continue à nous expliquer qu'il faut se
regrouper parce que plus j'en regroupe
plus on fait des économies d'échelle et
plus les finances peuvent être gérées à
des rigueur et qu'est-ce qu'on constate
que ce comme beaucoup regroupé ce comme
beaucoup de population il reçoivent plus
de dotations de l'État que ceux qui sont
plus modestes en taille alors là
pardonnez-moi je suis un sénateur rural
qui a pas fait de grandes études et j'ai
de la difficulté à comprendre
alors merci Monsieur Billac la parole
est à Monsieur Richard
ministre mes chers collègues j'ai
consigné cet amendement et je
m'apprêtais j'ai préparé un long travail
à les défendre puisqu'on a un avis
favorable du
rapporteur et puis une sagesse du
gouvernement très franchement je
m'absiendrai pour faire plaisir
précisément monsieur le Président de la
Commission rapporteur
merci Monsieur Richard je mets donc aux
voix les trois amendements
identiques 131
419 et 626 qui ont reçu la vie favorable
de la commission une sagesse du
gouvernement qui est pour
qui est contre qui s'abstient ils sont
adoptés alors le 627 madame jasmin le
défend merci madame la Présidente
l'article 250 de la loi de finance pour
2019 à réformé la dotation des terres
communales
avait notamment pour objectif de
supprimer les inégalités liées à la
répartition des enveloppes distinctes
par catégorie de PCI ces derniers ayant
désormais des degrés d'intégration
fiscale proche propre
il existe cependant un frein à se
rattrapage qui ralentit considérablement
l'évolution de la dotation de certains
EPCI notamment en outre-mer cela est dû
au système de plafonnement de la
dotation des terres communales un ECI ne
peut bénéficier d'une attribution par
habitant supérieur à 110% du montant
perçu au titre de l'année précédente ce
plafond permet ainsi d'appliquer
progressivement le montant de la
dotation des terres communalité ciblée
par la réforme à chaque PC afin de ne
pas déséquilibrer l'enveloppe globale de
la dotation des terres communalité dans
ce territoire d'outre-mer 11
intercommunalités sont concernés par ce
plafond en 2022 on constate que le
montant cible de la réforme de la
dotation intercommunalité et parfois
très éloignée du montant réellement
perçu par les communautés contenu de
cette règle de plafonnement afin de
permettre aux intercommunalités d'autres
mères de Guadeloupe Martinique Mayotte
Guy et de la réunion de bénéficier
justement de ce des plafonnement je
souhaite ses collègues que vous puissiez
voter cet amendement pour un montant
de 13 millions 421 763 euros merci
Madame jasmin monsieur le rapporteur
oui ma chère collègue
donc il y a plusieurs aspects mais
effectivement il faut
votre amendement évidemment a été déposé
avant l'acceptation de l'amendement
précédent
l'amendement précédent
répond pour partie à votre souhait et
comme nous sommes dans une vision sur
ces sujets là une vision nationale
l'amendement que nous avons pris propose
de déplafonniers pour 2023 pour les
communautés de communes de moins de
20000 habitants pour le montant qui a
été indiqué y compris y compris
outre-mer y compris donc je pense que
l'amendement en question correspond
largement à à vos demandes et donc je
vous demanderai
le retrait pour votre amendement merci
merci monsieur le rapporteur madame la
ministre même avis même avis merci
madame la Présidente merci Madame jasmin
merci madame la Présidente donc je tiens
compte des avis à la fois
le chanteur et de même la ministre et je
crois que ce sera suivi des faits
effectivement merci vous le retirez je
retiens merci Madame le 627 est retiré
deux amendements faisant l'objet d'une
discussion commune le 492 rectifié
madame loisir
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre donc la lignée à 42 du présent
article prévoit une neutralisation de
l'effort fiscal uniquement cet
amendement vise donc en fait à
parachever la démarche du gouvernement
et à étendre le chant pour neutraliser
l'ensemble des indicateurs financiers et
ainsi éviter de pénaliser notamment les
communes qui ont investi en effet nous
l'avons dit les réformes fiscales
successives génèrent des effets de bord
périphériques des effets de bord
exogènes qui sont largement liés à la
réforme de la taxe d'habitation et qui
de manière synthétique amène les
communes situées dans un département
impliquant un taux de TFPB plus faible
d'être pénalisé en fait sur leur
potentiel fiscal et des effets également
contre péréquateurs liés eux plutôt à la
DMTO et qui peut conduire à
l'augmentation du potentiel fiscal d'une
commune et donc la rendre ainsi
inéligible à la fraction cible DSR dont
nous avons beaucoup parlé du fait d'un
effort d'investissement important en
2022 on utilise donc les communes qui
investissent afin d'apporter de la
lisibilité de la stabilité au bloc
communal dans un contexte financier que
l'on sait incertain c'est amendement
propose donc d'élager d'élargir la
neutralisation des 2023 à l'ensemble des
indicateurs financiers je souligne que
les départements de France ont procédé
au même dispositif en sollicitant la
neutralisation intégrale et pérenne des
conséquences de la réforme fiscale sur
leur propre potentiels financiers et
j'ajoute que je me ravie que monsieur le
rapporteur est déposé un amendement
identique pendant la pause méridienne
j'espère que cela l'amènera à donner un
avis favorable à mon amendement merci
chers collègues et nous passons au 1047
présenté par Monsieur Guénet au nom de
la commission monsieur le rapporteur
oui donc c'est un amendement
donc de coordination mais il n'est il
n'est pas identique
si monsieur le rapporteur
nous alors il y en a plus en discussion
commune donc nous passons à la vie de la
commission donc sur cet amendement il
est effectivement
relativement sympathique puisque
il vise à une neutralisation complète de
la réforme des indicateurs financiers
bon il faut convenir qu'il faudra bien
passer à un moment à l'intégration de
ces nouveaux indicateurs sur pour les
ressources des communes et n'est pas
sain de prolonger éternellement les
choses et
c'est une façon d'envisager un jour
quand même de modifier la fiscalité
locale si mais si on ne tient jamais
compte de ce qui est fait on y arrivera
pas et ce que je voulais dire c'est
qu'on ne peut pas mettre sur le même
plan
la réforme du potentiel financier simulé
et adopté notamment par le CFL avec
celle de la réforme des forts fiscales
qui est inscrite dans la loi avant même
d'être similé malgré le bien évident de
la nouvelle formule qui exclut les
produits intercommunaux alors je
voudrais attirer votre attention c'est
que votre amendement est incompatible
avec l'amendement rédactionnel que je
propose madame loisir
ensuite et qui lui propose la
neutralisation de l'effort fiscal qui
est donc très importante parce que ça
sous-tend l'ensemble du système c'est la
deuxième raison pour laquelle je vous
demanderai de retirer cet amendement
compte tenu de l'importance de celui que
présente par commission merci merci
monsieur le rapporteur madame la
ministre avis du gouvernement sur ces
deux amendements sur le premier donc
[Musique]
492 madame Loisier de la même façon que
la Commission que je vous invite à le
retirer parce que nous porterons un avis
effectivement favorable sur l'amendement
suivant qui va être présenté par
Monsieur Guénet 47
merci Madame la Ministre
madame Loisy
merci Madame la miss monsieur une petite
explication donc en fait mon abonnement
propose la neutralisation de l'ensemble
des indicateurs financiers que propose
exactement le vote monsieur le
rapporteur
monsieur canevé peut-être avant en
explication de votre puis comme ça
monsieur le rapporteur pour un répondre
globalement c'est peut-être mieux merci
madame la Présidente de Madame la
Ministre chers collègues effectivement
on voit bien que cette réforme des de la
fiscalité locale est extrêmement
difficile en particulier lorsqu'il faut
intégrer les critères de pondération
mais la manifestement il y a une erreur
dans l'appréhension de l'ensemble des
critères tout simplement parce que on a
pris le nouveau critères tenant compte
de la suppression notamment de la taxe
d'habitation bien entendu on a intrigué
les DMTO mais on n'a pas intégré dans la
réforme les effets du coefficient
correcteur or il paraît légitime puisque
le coefficient correcteur a pour
ambition de pouvoir corriger les
inégalités il paraît anormal que
celui-ci ne soit pas intégré dans le
calcul des dotations et donc il est
absolument nécessaire que celui-ci soit
intégré et que donc
on remette à plat l'ensemble du
dispositif
merci Monsieur Calvé monsieur le
rapporteur oui simplement en réponse à
votre demande de précision
le problème c'est que votre amendement
neutralise tout alors que celui de la
Commission fait neutralise simplement le
seulement l'effort fiscal et fait
tourner le système et c'est pour ça que
bon je n'aurais pas toujours le même
caractère d'injonction dans mes demandes
de retrait mais celui-là sera vraiment
extrêmement gênant si jamais vous ne me
retiriez pas
et très honnêtement mais bon
alors je pense que chacun s'est exprimé
madame Loisy vous le maintenez nous le
mettons vote
vous le maintenez oui
il n'a pas été discriminant pour les
départements je vois pas pourquoi il le
serait pour le calcul du bloc communal
donc je le maintiens merci donc je vais
mettre aux voix l'amendement
492 rectifiées qui a reçu donc un avis
défavorable de la commission et du
gouvernement qui est pour
qui est contre
qui s'abstient il n'est pas adopté je me
vois l'amendement 1047 de la commission
présentée par Monsieur Guénet qui est
pour
qui contreception il est adopté le 491
rectifié madame loisir
merci madame la Présidente alors nous
sommes toujours sur le sujet de la quête
d'une meilleure justice fiscale entre
nos collectivités
selon nos projections donc 2000 communes
seraient de moins de 500 habitants
serait sa déjà été évoqué serait impacté
par une baisse de leur DGF et donc cette
amendement vise en fait à créer un filet
de sécurité DGF pour les communes de
moins de 500 habitants en leur
garantissant un montant de DGF 2023 au
minimum égal à celui perçu en 2022
merci monsieur le rapporteur
oui merci madame le Président alors donc
votre amendement en fait vise à
introduire une garantie de non baisse de
la DGF pour les communes de moins de 500
habitants
qu'on vient en premier lieu de noter
qu'une telle baisse devrait être rare
compte tenu de la hausse de la DGF
devant d'ailleurs bénéficier en premier
lieu comme une rurale en second lieu
l'application du critère unique de
population sans aucun critère de
ressources ou de charge de nous paraît
difficilement justifiable
bon la Commission a privilégier d'autres
dispositifs pour soutenir les cabines
face à la crise énergétique avec un
filet de sécurité élargi et simplifié
bon voilà
donc on demande plutôt un retrait mais
reconnaissons que l'amendement est très
sympathique pour les communes de moins
de 500 habitants
merci Monsieur Guénet avis du
gouvernement madame la ministre
défavorable madame la Présidente
on considère que la Commission anavit de
sagesse si j'ai bien compris ou
favorable retrait demande de retrait
alors je mets aux voiles 491 rectifié
qui a reçu une demande de retrait donc
défavorable de la commission et
défavorable du gouvernement qui est pour
je vous laisse compter
qui contre
qui s'obtient il n'est pas adopté je
mets aux voiles article 45 qui est pour
qui est contre qui il est adopté après
l'article 45 monsieur Moret l'amendement
150 de rectifier
merci Madame présidente madame la
ministre mes chers collègues cet
amendement vise à corriger partiellement
tout du moins une inégalité en termes de
dotation forfaitaire dans le cadre de la
DGF vous le savez le montant de la
dotation forfaitaire varie du simple eau
double selon la taille de la commune on
est à 60 tours de 60 euros pour les
communes de moins de 500 habitants alors
qu'on est à plus de 120 euros pour des
communes de plus de 200000 habitants et
cette situation n'est pas justifiée il y
a eu un rapport du gouvernement en 2019
qui le reconnaissait en disant je cite
le poids des charges des communes de
moins de 500 habitants semblent
sous-estimer et donc si jusqu'à présent
le gouvernement a reconnu que cette
situation n'était pas satisfaisante il
n'a pas pour autant pris les mesures
pour le corriger c'est même opposé à des
amendements qui ont été adoptés en ce
sens précédemment dans dans cette
assemblée renvoyant toujours à des
travaux ultérieurs qui jamais eu lieu et
donc je dépose cet amendement qui a pour
objet de réduire l'écart qui comme je le
disais est aujourd'hui de 1 à 2 de le
réduire de 1,5 à deux c'est à dire que
la dotation minimale passerait de 64,46
€ à 96 euros 69 j'ajoute que c'est une
année tout à fait propice pour le faire
puisqu'il y a une augmentation de la DGF
donc ça permet de de
dégager des sommes pour donner un peu
plus aux communes rurales sans pour
autant retirer aux autres communes je le
dis parce que les autres années on nous
opposait le fait qu'on allait dépouiller
les uns pour améliorer le sort des
autres j'ajoute enfin que cet amendement
était répond à une demande très forte et
récurrente de l'Association des maires
ruraux
t-shirt collègues avis de la commission
monsieur le rapporteur
modifier l'application du coefficient
logarithmique la population c'est
effectivement pas la première fois que
nous le retrouvons lors de cette mission
c'est vrai que des plus mesuré puisque
donc il dirait il proposerait de réduire
à un 5
pendant s'il n'est pas parfait ce
coefficient est encore le moins mauvais
des systèmes trouver ce jour dans la
mesure où il est corrigé par bon nombre
d'autres systèmes et à ce moment-là nous
retrouverions d'autres collectivités
autour de la table qui viendrait
demander d'application d'autres critères
bon très homme très objectivement il ne
paraît pas opportun de bouleverser
à ce moment les équilibres de cette
dotation forfaitaire qui est
reconnaissons-le
assez précaire et menacé d'obsolescence
et il faudrait vraiment remettre à plat
globalement la DGF sinon on sort pas et
en attendant il faut reconnaître que la
solution d'un renforcement de la DSR de
200 millions d'euros nous paraît
constitué quand même un instrument plus
favorable plus direct et mieux ciblées
pour le soutien à la ruralité que que ce
que vous demandez
merci Madame la Ministre demande de
retrait pour les mêmes raisons que la
Commission a vite défavorable madame la
Présidente la ministre donc monsieur
Morez vous ne retirez pas votre
amendement
très bien je me suis Moret explication
de vote
oui juste pour regretter évidemment la
position du du rapporteur c'est jamais
opportun chaque année on nous dit ça et
chaque année on nous dit on verra plus
tard le gouvernement là il fait pas
beaucoup d'efforts il justifie même pas
eu du défavorable bon d'habitude on a au
moins des engagements de mise en place
de commission de travaux qui n'aboutit
jamais mais au moins on enrobe un petit
peu le refus là c'est c'est sec et net
ne me paraissent pas bonne et je ne vous
conseille pas ma mamie si je peux me
permettre de vous donner un conseil
d'aller porter ce message à l'assemblée
générale des mères ruraux
merci Monsieur Moret je vais donc passer
aux explications de vote en commençant
par Madame cuerman oui merci madame la
présidente madame la ministre
excusez-moi messieurs mais c'est un peu
la résine donc je ne sais pas si
l'arlésienne est belle mais à force d'en
parler tout le monde se l'imagine mais
personne ne l'a jamais vu même pas
touché et donc finalement nous sommes là
c'est le principe de la légende
messieurs mesdames
on est exactement dans la même situation
ici c'est à dire que chaque année on
parle de cette véritable réforme et du
besoin de revoir la répartition de la
répartition de la dotation globale de
fonctionnement truc comme une rural et
les communes urbaines c'est pas le
moment parce que bien évidemment bah oui
c'est pas à 17h alors qu'il faut qu'on
ait fini la mission à 20h parce que
sinon on doit tous revenir samedi matin
qu'on va poser ici le débat et donc
c'est pas le moment aujourd'hui c'est
pas le moment au projet au prochain
projet de loi de finance rectificative
c'est pas le prochain et puis dans un an
on va se retrouver comme on s'est
retrouvé l'année dernière comme ça fait
des années qu'on se retrouve en disant
que c'est pas le bon et pour autant les
inégalités paradoxalement elle elle
continue de se creuser et sans faire un
fil conducteur de notre journée madame
la ministre mais vous voyez très
simplement si on reprend le pourquoi
finalement de la différence entre les
communes rurales et les communes
urbaines
urbaines remontons aux années 50-60 de
ces inégalités oui nous avions des
routes communales qui n'étaient pas
forcément entretenu goudronné etc nous
avons des problématiques d’eau
d'assainissement qui n'étaient pas les
mêmes mais aujourd'hui on en est plus là
et depuis ce matin on en parle par
exemple la question du kilomètre voirie
bah dans les communes rurales elle se
pose de façon bien plus forte et bien
plus indispensable qu'elle ne se posait
précédemment et donc l'enjeu de la
dotation elle est indispensable puisque
depuis ce matin on nous dit que c'est un
vrai sujet mais que ça ne peut pas être
pris en compte sur la création d'un
nouveau fond la création l'augmentation
de la 2tr la prise en compte dans la
descente donc ça peut jamais être pris
en compte et là il est 17h ça peut
toujours pas être pris en compte nous
personnellement nous voterons cet
abonnement parce qu'à force que ce ne
soit jamais pris en compte c'est une
réalité réelle au quotidien pour les
élus merci Madame cuerman madame Gatel
le sénateur est endurant
persévérant et conséquent je voudrais
quand même rappeler qu'en 2021 le Sénat
avait adopté cette disposition qui avait
échappé à l'intelligence qu'on reconnaît
tous aux député et que de la même
manière en 2019 madame la ministre le
gouvernement avait dit ah mais c'est
bien sûr fréquence s'occupe d'une chose
c'est la distorsion de dotation entre la
entre les communes selon leur taille
alors je suis d'accord on va pas faire
ça autour d'un amendement mais il
faudrait quand même qu'on se demande
pourquoi il y a autant d'amendements qui
portent tout le temps sur le même sujet
qu'en même temps on nous dit la ruralité
c'est très important et nous on dit
donne-nous l'heure un peu d'argent et
tout à l'heure il y a eu dans le texte
une proposition de revoir le critère de
voirie en l'affectant davantage aux
communes plus denses est-ce que
sincèrement on peut se poser entre deux
PLF et prendre l'engagement de regarder
avec courage au CFL comme au Sénat ce
sujet parce que ça devient fou parce
qu'on répare au rustine on sait plus ce
qu'on fait et on invente des
usines à gaz donc soyons sérieux madame
la ministre si vous voulez pas d'un
amendement à 17h mais que nous on a déjà
voté il va peut-être être voté quand
vous reviendrez nous voir l'année
prochaine pour le même exercice il y
aura moins d'amendements mais on va pas
le samedi et ce sera peut-être plus
pertinent merci
monsieur Duplomb vous avez la parole
madame la présidente madame la ministre
toute l'amitié que je porte à Charles je
peux pas accepter le l'argument qui
consisterait à dire nous sommes
conscients de la situation
nous trouvons qu'elle n'est pas normale
mais repoussant la plus tard parce qu'il
est urgent d'attendre ça moi pour moi
c'est absolument pas un argument je
pense qu'au contraire
c'est amendement un véritablement deux
grands avantages le premier c'est qu'il
n'a jamais été autant d'actualité
qu'est-ce qui fait qu'une commune puisse
par son budget gérer convenablement
l'amélioration du cadre de vie de ses
concitoyens c'est qu'elle est
suffisamment de ressources je m'excuse
mais ce gouvernement a supprimé une part
importante des ressources qui pouvaient
être faites sur nos communes avec la
suppression de la taxe d'habitation
alors vous allez me dire elle est
compensée certes certes sur la base de
2017 à chaque fois qu'on a une
augmentation de la population on a plus
l'augmentation de cette base et
l'augmentation de cette taxe donc par
définition si on veut revenir à quelque
chose où on est sur un système où on
donne pareil à tout le monde sur 2017
par exemple pour la taxe d'habitation et
bien il s'en est normal de faire la même
chose sur la dotation globale de
fonctionnement et le deuxième argument
c'est que je trouve que cette année il
faut absolument le mettre dans la loi à
la sortie du Sénat parce qu'au moins le
gouvernement en appliquant le 49-3 le
49-3 portera à lui seul la
responsabilité de ne pas avoir pris cet
engagement là vis-à-vis des maires et il
s'en expliquea puisque dans le 49-3 vous
avez la chance de pouvoir décider seul
de ce que vous gardez de ce que vous
enlevez ou de ce que vous pouvez
reprendre et bien enlevant on vous
permettra de vous décider et on jugera
derrière
la parole est à Monsieur Billac
merci madame la Présidente
effectivement
à 17h c'est pas peut-être le moment par
un amendement de modifier mais il y a
des années que nous dénonçons cette
différence de traitement financier au
niveau de la DGF avec un rural qui vaut
la moitié d'un urbain c'est quand même
surprenant alors que surnommery nous
avons gravé les mots de liberté
d'égalité et de fraternité mais bon
c'est ainsi le rural il vaut la moitié
d'une bain alors qu'elle a déjà fait au
début des années 70 ça se comprenait ça
je comprenait parce que c'était quoi la
commune rurale un peu de charbon pour le
poil boucher les trous dans la rue et ma
foi à quelque chose près quelques cris
pour le tableau et quelques papiers
c'était ça
aujourd'hui les besoins des habitants
des communes rurales ils ont rejoint les
habitants des communes de la ville moi
j'ai été élu en 1983 si j'avais dit à
mon conseil municipal vous voyez dans
quelques années on va faire une cantine
scolaire il m'aurait rayonné si je leur
avais dit dans quelques années on va
ouvrir une crèche ils auraient appelé
aussitôt l'hôpital psychiatrique pour me
faire interdire et pourtant c'est ce qui
s'est passé le rural évolue le rural
n'est plus une communauté où on vivait
ou les enfants allaient manger chez la
grand-mère à midi parce que le rural a
pris des habitudes du monde urbain et il
faut en prendre en compte parce que les
communes rurales ont quasiment
aujourd'hui les mêmes besoins que les
communes urbaines madame la ministre
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre la succession d'amendements que
nous discutons depuis
ce matin
vise à réduire les inégalités à corriger
les effets négatifs et les dommages
collatéraux des réformes successives qui
ont lieu et montre une chose c'est que
le système est à bout de souffle le
système ne fonctionne plus et c'est la
raison pour laquelle
les uns et les autres nous déposons un
certain nombre d'amendements pour en
corriger tel ou tel effet négatif c'est
ce qui est fait au travers de cet
amendement que nous allons voter
mais de grâce madame Amélie vous venez
d'arriver il faut vous laisser un peu de
temps mais prenez l'engagement de mettre
à plat l'ensemble du dispositif
repartons d'une feuille blanche et
essayons de construire quelque chose
prenons le temps de le faire
rassemblons l'ensemble des forces
politiques et
l'ensemble des associations d'élus il y
aura nécessairement des heureux et des
mécontents assumons-le mais en tout état
de cause il faut aller vers plus de
lisibilité vers plus d'équilibre vers
plus d'égalité il faut aussi au regard
de ce que nous avons connu ces dernières
années prendre en considération la
situation de la vie de nos concitoyens
dans les communes rurales et c'est comme
une rurale aujourd'hui souffre plus que
les autres il faut donc effectivement
mettre sur la table et disposition et
les dispositifs qui permettent de les
aider et d'assurer à nos concitoyens
ruraux des qualités de vie qui soit à la
hauteur de ce qu'ils attendent
merci Monsieur Marie la parole est à
monsieur le rapporteur
oui merci madame la Présidente
simplement pour dire à certains de mes
collègues que depuis presque un quart de
siècle que je me préoccupe de fiscalité
locale certaines réalités ne m'échappent
pas
cependant je voudrais dire que
ce n'est pas en essayant de modifier au
coût par coup les choses comme ça que
que nous séparviendrons parce que sous
d'autres dans d'autres enceintes j'ai
défendu aussi
l'obsolescence de ce critère de
qui multiplie par deux les ressources
pour les collectivités les plus peuplées
et puis bon au fil du temps on s'aperçut
que cette fiscalité qui était assise sur
des réalités il y a environ admission
ce sont plus forcément les mêmes et
lorsque tout à l'heure vous discutiez du
de la longueur de voirie
je partageais aussi de ce que vous
disiez parce que je suis un rural aussi
et je connais bien les choses simplement
dans la la charge agrégée du territoire
où j'étais il y a 40 ans quand j'ai
commencé à m'occuper des choses la
voirie c'est 50% de la dépense
aujourd'hui c'est 15 quand tout va bien
donc les choses ont évolué et on ne peut
pas garder des symboles asseoir les
choses de cette manière là
sans arrêt simplement est-ce que je
voudrais vous dire c'est qu'à dans le
temps qui s'est écoulé j'ai moi aussi
participé à des tentatives de réforme je
me souviens d'une il y a deux ou trois
ans combien c'était oui
et on a vu dans
dans ce même hémicycle des gens s'élevés
partout parce que chacun a regardé sa
dotation historique
et tous ces fixé sur la base de la
dotation historique qu'on possède et non
pas sur
la dotation qu'il faudrait je suis pour
une remise à plat complète de la
fiscalité locale et sur d'autres
critères notamment sur celle de
critères de charges synthétique pour les
territoires afin qu'ils soient dotés sur
ces bases là au titre d'une péréquation
généralisée et que par ailleurs on
puisse satisfaire les dynamiques dans
les autres territoires et c'est à cela
qu'il faut qu'on arrive mais il
êtes-vous prêts
j'ai pas le sentiment on y est prêt
intellectuellement mais dès que les
résultats sortent on en veut plus alors
il y a un problème même si on a dit
qu'on prendrait un tunnel de
un lissage sur cinq ou dix ans mais
c'est ce qu'il faut faire et il faudra
le faire alors voilà bon à partir de là
c'est la réponse que je voulais apporter
sur
ma mes considérations personnelles ceci
étant je suis au moment de la commission
des finances et j'essaie de de faire
modestement de remplir en mode est ce
moment mon rôle et c'est pour ça que je
vous ai demandé un retrait en l'état
actuel des choses voilà
merci
monsieur le rapporteur je vais donc
mettre aux voix la maman 152 rectifier
qui a reçu un avis défavorable de la
commission et du gouvernement qui est
pour
qui est contre
ça tient il est adopté après l'article
16 amendements qui font l'objet d'une
discussion commune et nous commençons
avec le 140 ah pardon une parole
de monsieur le Président rénal
merci madame le Président alors nous
rentrons sur un nouveau sujet
nous allons maintenant examiner
plusieurs amendements et sous
amendements relatifs à la DGF des
communes nouvelles
notre sujet mais qui concerne beaucoup
moins de communes en réalité
donc nous partageons tous la volonté des
auteurs de soutenir le développement des
communes nouvelles en mobilisant pour ce
faire les leviers juridiques et
financiers adéquat
la loi prévoit déjà un certain nombre de
dispositifs d'incitations financières
avec notamment la dotation d'amorçage ou
encore le pacte de stabilité pour les
trois premières années suivant la
création
on peut également citer les dispositifs
d'éligibilité dérogatoires à la DSR ou à
la DPE l introduire respectivement un
défi 2022 et dans le texte du présent
PLF
faut-il aller plus loin comme le pense
pour encourager davantage le mouvement
et peut-on faire mieux
alors comme toujours politique et truc
on peut toujours faire mieux néanmoins
les pistes proposées par les différents
amendements ne nous paraissent pas
encore abouti et se heurtent notamment à
des obstacles d'autres techniques ou
juridiques
ces amendements en commun de prévoir que
certaines dotations versées à la commune
nouvelle qu'il s'agisse de la dotation
forfaitaire ou de la DSR soit au moins
égal à la somme de ces mêmes dotations
qui auraient dû être versées aux
anciennes communes
la ministre nous confirmera mais il
semble techniquement impossible de
reconstituer ainsi de tels dotations
fictives puis pour des communes qui ont
cessé d'exister juridiquement
de telle sorte que ces amendements
apparaissent en réalité une
mais je laisserai la ministre développer
sur ce point puisque c'est la une partie
administrative là-dessus ça me paraît
assez clair si les communes n'existent
plus il n'y a plus de documents il y a
plus de documents
on peut plus retrouver la somme de des
communes qui n'existent plus
ces amendements prévoient en outre un
nouveau mécanisme de garantie
d'évolution de leur DSR qui serait
indexée sur celle du montant national de
la dotation une telle mesure poserait de
très sérieux problèmes d'équité
vis-à-vis des autres communes et
pourrait même s'exposer selon nous à une
censure du Conseil constitutionnel sur
ce fondement les communes nouvelles
deviendra en effet les seules communes
pour qu'il évolution de leur dotation de
péréquation serait complètement
décorrélée de celle de leurs indicateurs
financiers
alors après très sincèrement cette
assemblée nous apprend
à modifier nos points de vue
bon puisqu'elle vient de voter une
garantie de nombreuses de la dotation
d'Inter comme unité
à ma grande surprise mais c'est pas
grave donc si elle vient de le faire
c'est à dire d'avoir une vision
totalement décorée de tout après tout on
peut continuer pour les communes
nouvelles voilà on peut poursuivre c'est
cette même voix mais on doit vous dire à
la commission des finances que nous
sommes évidemment défavorables non pas à
l'idée c'est à dire non pas l'idée qu'il
faille continuer à trouver des systèmes
pour créer des communes nouvelles c'est
sûr qu'il y a un enjeu autour de autour
de ça même s'il est pas toujours très
partagé la commune nouvelle quelquefois
ne rassure pas on va dire mais pour ma
part pour la part de la Commission n'y
est plutôt ouvert simplement il faut
trouver le système qui va bien et donc
peut-être le préparer je le dis à ceux
qui ont écrit ces amendements et je
parmi les gens qui ont écrit à Françoise
Gatel c'est à dire la présidente de la
de la commission
donc de la délégation collectivité
donc qui sait je pense se rapprocher
quand il le faut des cabinets et d'un
DGCL pour trouver les termes exactes qui
permettront de faire passer tel que ces
amendements sont rédigés en tout cas ils
sont d'une part inopérant de notre part
dangereux par rapport à une sanction de
conseil constitutionnel et donc très
naturellement j'appellerai à leur
retrait mais j'ai bien compris que la
tendance au retrait est assez peu
développée aujourd'hui
vous avez la parole
merci madame la Présidente oui je vous
ai demandé la parole parce que plusieurs
amendements proposent d'inciter au
développement des communes nouvelles et
je voulais vous dire à quel point le
gouvernement est pour
pas les 16 amendements mais nous avons
16 amendements et je voulais vous dire
parmi lesquels et pour être en total
cohérence et je le redis pour Monsieur
malheureusement monsieur le sénateur est
parti quand je me permets de dire
défavorable en cohérence avec la
commission des finances et pour ne pas
vous infliger exactement les mêmes
arguments donc c'est pour ça que je me
permets de temps en temps et pour aller
vite de aller à la conclusion quand le
gouvernement est en phase avec les
recommandations de la commission donc
un dispositif de maintien parmi ces 16
amendements de maintien de la dotation
globale de fonctionnement des communes
nouvelles à hauteur des montants perçus
en 2022 et au niveau de la somme des DGF
des communes délégués dont elles sont
issues sur le plan technique comme ça
vient d'être dit je le confirme cette
mesure n'est pas applicable car vous
l’appuyez sur des communes disparues car
fusionner or les nombreux indicateurs
utilisés pour répartir la DGF de façon
juste et objective n'existe plus sur le
périmètre des communes fusionnées qui
n'existe plus juridiquement
géographiquement
institutionnellement et fiscalement donc
le dispositif serait donc totalement et
irrémédiablement une applicable le
calcul des dotations ne pourrait tout
simplement pas être effectué sur le
principe je ne suis pas favorable à tous
ces dispositifs car ils viendraient
modifier en profondeur le pacte de
stabilisé dont bénéficie des communes
nouvelles ce dispositif complet est très
incitatif a été réformé récemment
en 2020 et se traduit concrètement par
les mesures suivantes pour les communes
nouvelles je me permets d'être longue je
ne parle de l'aurai qu'une seule fois
pour les 16 amendements elle perçoivent
une garantie spécifique visant en
neutraliser une baisse de leur dotation
forfaitaire et de leur dotation de
péréquation suite à leur fusion
deuxièmement elle perçoivent une
dotation d'amorçage de 6 euros par
habitant perçus pendant trois ans
pouvant atteindre 10 euros par habitant
pour les petites communes troisièmement
elles pourront bénéficier en 2023 d'une
éligibilité dérogatoire à la DSR
lorsqu'elle dépasse les 10000 habitants
mais peuvent être qualifiés de rural les
communes nouvelles issues de la fusion
de toutes les communes d'un ou plusieurs
EPCI bénéficient en outre des anciennes
dotations de l'EPCI en conséquence les
787 communes disposant du statut de
communes nouvelles bénéficiée en 2022
d'une attribution moyenne de DGF c'est
le vent à
219,65 euros par habitant contre 165
euros habitants pour l'ensemble des
communes soit 32% de plus vous proposez
notamment de remettre en cause le
principe d'éligibilité dérogatoire à la
DSR introduit par la loi de finances
2022 ce dispositif permet de soutenir
les communes nouvelles gardant des
caractéristiques rurales
enfin votre amendement court un fort
risque de censure par le Conseil
constitutionnel en estorant de manière
pérenne une différence de traitement
entre les communes nouvelles et
l'ensemble des autres communes il en va
de même entre les communes nouvelles
votre amendement favorisant celle ayant
maintenu des communes déléguées au
détriment de communes plus intégrées les
pistes comme cela était dit ne nous
semble pas à ces aboutis assez aboutis
pardon pour les mêmes raisons que
monsieur le rapporteur l'indiqué je veux
souligner l'importance que je porte que
le gouvernement porte et dont je
comprends de façon évidente
l'importance que revêt pour vous
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs et
d'ailleurs je l'ai dit en introduction
je le redis le gouvernement soutient le
développement des communes nouvelles ce
que je veux tout simplement vous
proposer c'est dès la semaine prochaine
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs qui
avaient proposé ces 16 amendements c'est
vous recevoir au ministère pour monter
un groupe de travail pour en discuter et
pouvoir comment nous allons pouvoir
ensemble développer nos communes
nouvelles je vous remercie
merci Madame la Ministre alors nous
allons pouvoir procéder à la
présentation des amendements à commencer
par Monsieur VIAL
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre mes chers collègues c'est un
peu original de présenter les
amendements après qu'ils aient après la
vie du gouvernement et de la commission
mais je vais essayer
[Musique]
il y a une perte de vitesse du nombre de
communes nouvelles et c'est bien et
c'est bien naturel aujourd'hui il ne
reste plus que des inconvénients donc ce
qu'on propose par ces amendements et je
vais essayer de répondre apparemment ça
vous propositions madame madame la
ministre c'est quelque chose qui se base
sur des choses qui existent donc je vais
répondre un peu à votre proposition on
propose trois choses notamment
premièrement de stabiliser la DGF afin
de garantir aux communes nouvelles
qu'elle n'est pas perte de DGF c'est la
moindre des choses si on veut que des
communes nouvelles se créent et on
s'appuie sur les communes nouvelles qui
ont des communes déléguées ça existe
juridiquement une communauté et donc on
peut geler sur cette base là
deuxièmement pour les communes qui qui
se sont déjà qui ont déjà fusionnés on
s'appuie sur le montant 2022 c'est un
chiffre qui existe la DGF 2022 on la Gel
c'est une garantie simple et le il y a
un troisième point dans cet amendement
qui permet de garantir la le versement
de la dotation de compensation de l'EPCI
pour les communes communautés voilà je
vous remercie mais vous voyez on
s'appuie sur des choses qui existent
pour favoriser ces communes nouvelles
comme vous le souhaitez madame la
ministre et nous aussi merci chers
collègues le 400 est rectifié
monsieur corbizet oui pardon madame la
Présidente la cause sera tellement bien
défendu par la présidente Gatel que mon
amendement est défendu
mon collègue pour la pression je
voudrais remercier le collecté de rivial
qui a bien défendu le principe alors
madame la ministre vous m'épater
totalement parce que vous êtes
totalement pauvre mais au final vous
êtes gravement contre mais vous nous
proposez gentiment d'aller prendre le
thé discuter comme une nouvelle chez
vous alors c'est sympa mais excusez-moi
on fait pas une loi de finance avec ça
quand au président rénal moi je suis
très touchée de l'attention qu'ils
prennent mais sérieusement cher Claude
mais à la fin à force de nous dire bah
oui mais votre truc il est pas opérant
moi je regrette c'est très opérant parce
qu'il a déjà opéré et je veux dire
pourquoi
à l'Assemblée nationale ils ont adopté
un amendement maintenant la dotation
élue locale pour les communes nouvelles
à partir de celle perçues par les
communes déléguées
alors moi il faut qu'on m'explique
pourquoi ce qui a été opérant à
l'Assemblée nationale ne l'est pas au
Sénat et puis je dirais quand il y a une
volonté il y a un chemin et soyons
sérieux
non mais tout le monde est d'accord avec
moi voilà formidable ça m'arrivera
rarement et je termine et je termine non
mais madame la ministre est-ce qu'on
peut être grave et sérieux et en même
temps je crois qu'on l'a tous été là en
2014 80 communes françaises n'ont pas eu
de candidats aux élections municipales
en 2020 c'est 110 et bien continuons à
emprunter ce chemin et on verra on
n'aura plus à parler d'argent parce
qu'il y aura plus d'élus il y aura plus
de communes et ce sera le désert et on
aura une grave misère sociale et moi je
souhaite vraiment que les communes
nouvelles restent une liberté
d'initiative donnée aux élus il ne
s'agit pas de l'imposer mais quand il y
a des élus courage et audacieux qui se
payent des moments très difficiles pour
garantir l'avenir de leur collectivité
est-ce qu'on les aide ou est-ce qu'on
les enfonce
madame Gatel rester au micro pour
défendre de 434 rectifiés de terre
alors le
434 terre c'est un peu une évolution
enfin moi je dis qu'il y a toujours ce
vice caché dans Cédric vient la parler
dont on n'a pas qui n'avait pas été vu
et pas été dit à propos de la DSR du
fait d'évolution législative et
sincèrement chers amis est-ce qu'on peut
comparer une commune de 2000 habitants
historiquement de 2000 habitants avec
six communes qui se sont regroupées pour
faire 2000 habitants donc ce que nous ce
que nous proposons aujourd'hui c'est que
les communes nouvelles rentes dans des
dispositions de droits communs sans les
sanctionner il s'agit là pour les
communes nouvelles qui seraient à partir
de 2023 de bénéficier d'un mécanisme de
sortie sur quatre ans de la dotation de
solidarité rurale et le sifflet ainsi
proposé est extrêmement responsable et
on retrouve de l'incitation
si le 517 monsieur VIAL
oui c'est un amendement
identique alors madame la ministre
madame présente il y a peu de suspense
puisque nous sommes un certain nombre de
groupes avoir déposé un amendement
identique et si on compte bien la somme
des cosignataires et supérieure à la
majorité dont le Sénat a besoin pour
adopter cette amendement donc le
suspense est relativement limité si par
contre j'aimerais bien quand même
monsieur le Président parce que vous
avez tout à l'heure pris la pris la
parole pour donner votre avis sur les
amendements avant qu'il ne soit défendus
et vous avez donné un avis défavorable à
l'ensemble des amendements il me
semblait avoir vu un avis de sagesse
d'accord donc on aimerait quand même
avoir votre avis sur les différents
amendements qui qui pourraient peut-être
être différenciés et notamment sur
celui-ci qui qui permet de régler là
aussi un vice caché comme l'a dit Madame
Gatel sur un nombre relativement
restreint de commune nouvelle mais on ne
pourra pas on ne pourra pas continuer à
avoir des communes nouvelles on ne
pourra pas inciter à la création de
communes nouvelles si on n'est pas
capable de corriger ce genre de règle et
en plus c'est une peine qui vient qui
tombe sur ses communes par des
modifications législatives qui sont
intervenus après qu'elles aient pris la
décision de de se créer en commun une
nouvelle donc nous nous devons en tant
que représentation nationale de régler
ce type de problème pour
redonner confiance finalement aux élus
locaux dans la politique du gouvernement
dans le et dans la présentation
nationale quand il s'engage dans un
dispositif on doit au minimum tenir les
engagements qu'on leur a donné quand on
les a incités à y rentrer merci Monsieur
Vial le 578 monsieur Capu
merci madame la Présidente
l'amendement a été défendu par la
présidente Gatel et par notre collègue
Vial et je défends celui que j'ai déposé
effectivement avec mon école mon
collègue Franck mélonville et l'ensemble
des indépendants
il s'agit pas pour répondre à la
critique qui a déjà été fait par le
président rénal d'inciter à la fusion ou
de donner un cadeau aux communes
nouvelles il s'agit de réparer une
injustice ou pour reprendre l'image que
je ne connaissais pas du sac de réparer
un truc qu'on n'avait pas vu il se
trouve qu'il y a des communes nouvelles
qui se voient non seulement pas incité
mais puni en fait et qui ont des qui
touche une DSR inférieur à ce qu'il
touchait quand il était les communes
déléguées enfin les unes à côté des
autres donc je crois qu'on peut tous
quand même considérer ici que on va pas
donner une DSC inférieur à des communes
nouvelles simplement parce qu'elles ont
fusionné alors même que c'était quand
même pas l'objectif et que c'est plutôt
à mon sens si elle le souhaite positif
de travailler ensemble donc il s'agit de
réparer modestement une injustice un
truc qui n'avait pas été vu et là
l'amendement est très modeste prévoit
non pas de la réparer définitivement non
pas de façon pérenne mais de sortir de
façon lisser sur quatre ans enfin en
sifflet
de cette injustice donc c'est très
modéré quand même un moment
le 64
identique monsieur Ruquier il est
défendu monsieur très bien il est
défendu le 646
[Musique]
allez-y monsieur Bigot oui merci la
présidente monsieur
la dynamique des communes nouvelles à
l'heure actuelle est en pause
qu'on vient de réfléchir aux raisons
pour lesquelles de nouvelles communes ne
souhaitent pas s'y engager le mécanisme
des communes nouvelles a été initié déjà
quelques temps une dizaine d'années
j'appartiens à un département qui est
pilote en la
circonstance il s'agit du département de
Maine-et-Loire et beaucoup de fusion de
communes on était ont été opérés sur la
base du volontariat avec un projet de
territoire ce sont celles qui
fonctionnent le mien le mieux à l'heure
actuelle un certain nombre de communes
envisagent parfois de défusionner mais
c'est l'ordre c'est dès lors qu'il n'y
avait pas de projet de territoire et
donc votre proposition de commission
tombe à pic je crois que c'est le moment
de faire un arrêt sur image de regarder
un petit peu ce qu'il en est sur cette
question du commune nouvelle parce qu'il
y a un il y en a un certain nombre qui
qui fonctionne correctement d'autres qui
ont des difficultés c'est le sens de cet
amendement merci Monsieur Bigot le 694
madame ku Karman oui merci
dans Madame la ministre mes chers
collègues
je crois que les arguments qui ont été
exposés tout d'abord sont importants
parce que au moment de voter ses
dispositions il nous appartient
effectivement tout d'abord avec humilité
parfois de pouvoir se dire qu'il y a eu
quelques erreurs et que nous avons comme
seul objectif de continuer de garantir
l'égalité entre les différents
dispositifs et donc de gommer comme ça
te dit par Madame Gatel par Monsieur
viam une nouvelle nous l'avons eu et
dans le temps imparti je ne pourrai en
faire de résumer pour notre groupe
l'enjeu n'est pas d'inciter ou de
désinciter l'enjeu est tout simplement
de partir d'un conseil d'une réalité
aujourd'hui les communes nouvelles
existent et parfois et on va se le dire
tranquillement parce que ici ce n'est
pas le paradis sur terre elles existent
parce que on les a incité fortement
conseillé fortement encouragés on leur a
fait découvrir que tous ensemble c'était
mieux pour garder tel ou tel service
public et que comme par la magie
soudainement tous les élus étaient tous
d'accord pour créer ensemble une
communion nouvelle et qu'ils l'ont créé
tout va très bien mais à part ça madame
la marquise il faut quand même que je
vous dise que cela pose encore des
soucis aujourd'hui et que donc venir
fragiliser ce qui s'est constitué
volontairement à volontairement et je ne
réouvre vraiment pas le débat ici nous
l'avons eu de longues heures
précédemment serait en tout cas remettre
en cause le rapport et la confiance que
peuvent avoir les élus y compris dans
l'accompagnement que l'État leur fait au
quotidien pour le déploiement de la mise
en place de ces communes nouvelles dans
notre dans mon département où il en
existe un certain nombre je crois
qu'aujourd'hui la question est de
sécuriser cette existant plutôt que le
fragilisant le fragiliser d'où le sens
de notre et Madame la miss comme j'ai
débordé j'en profite pour dire que le
prochain amendement sera également
défendu et au lieu de 4 minutes j'aurais
fait deux minutes 10 pour les deux je
vous remercie chers collègues monsieur
Capu le 580
je vais défendre le 580 et le suivant
c'est-à-dire
le 300 de rectifier en même temps et
ceux d'autant plus qu'en fait le 580 et
le repli du 302 donc je pense que la
séance les amis dans dans le désordre en
pensant sans doute que le premier était
le repli de celui d'avant mais en fait
c'est le repli du dernier on est sur la
même logique et ce ce cet amendement
vous le verrez a été déposé par les
quatre sénateurs du Maine-et-Loire parce
qu'il démarre par une problématique du
Maine-et-Loire de la commune de Douai en
Anjou doué en Anjou c'est une c'est une
commune qui à l'origine était composée
de Doué-la-Fontaine 7000 habitants et
des communes environnantes qui sont
toutes de moins de 2000
elle fusionne elles arrivent à une
commune de 11000 habitants comme toutes
les autres communes elle pense qu'elles
vont garder une DSR du même niveau et là
elle découvre cette année qu'elles vont
perdre 800.000 euros de DSR parce que du
jour au lendemain pour une raison très
simple parce qu'on leur dit que la
densité de leur population de la commune
centre parce qu'elle fait 7000 habitants
et trop dense
on est à doué en anjouffe je vous invite
à y aller on est vraiment dans la
ruralité du Saumurois donc on est on a
des critères de densité qui sont
vraiment à apprécier de façon très
particulière c'est la raison pour
laquelle le premier amendement
c'est-à-dire le
302 qui est le deuxième en fait là
propose et qui a été déposée par mes
collègues bigots et pieds-noirs et de
roches proposent simplement de rajouter
aux critères de pour le maintien de la
DSR de très peu dense et en rajoutant ou
de densité intermédiaire puisqu'il
semble on semble considérer que ce type
de commune a une densité qui est
intermédiaire et non pas très peu dense
et le deuxième est un amendement de
repli qui si jamais on maintenait une
sortie progressive en cinq ans
nous passons à l'amendement présenté par
Monsieur c'est monsieur piennoir qui le
dépose qu'il défend pardon le 335
absolument madame la Présidente vous
êtes nouvellement chargé de la ruralité
vous n'ignorez pas néanmoins que le fait
pour certaines communes de se regrouper
en commune en commune nouvelle ne leur a
pas fait perdre leur caractère rural et
c'est le cas dans un certain nombre de
communes du Maine-et-Loire vous voyez
que ce département est particulièrement
mis à l'honneur dans les discussions de
ce jour comme à chaque fois que nous
évoquons les communes nouvelles
et donc lorsque nous avons voté lors du
précédent loi de la précédente loi de
finances de 2022 de permettre à
certaines communes qui dépassent les dix
mille habitants de continuer à
bénéficier de la DSR nous avions bordé
ça accompagner ça d'un certain seuil sur
la densité de population cette densité
devait être dense ou très peu dense très
peu dense nous vous proposons un
aménagement pour prolonger en fait ce le
bon sens qui a conduit nos débats de
l'époque en disant il reste certaines
communes il y a des effets de bord en
fait sur cette sur cette mesure et nous
vous proposons d'étendre ça à une
densité un tout petit peu plus forte
c'est à dire très peu dense ou de
densité intermédiaire ce qui permettrait
d'intégrer certaines communes la commune
de douane Anjou bien sûr dans le
Maine-et-Loire mais probablement
d'autres communes en France qui seraient
concernées je vous remercie merci chers
collègues et maintenant le 400 4
monsieur Bigot oui c'est le troisième
sénateur du Maine-et-Loire intervenir
pour le sujet pour
les mêmes motifs et comme ça a été
brillamment défendu avant je ne
m'éterniserai pas sur le sujet en
reprenant ce qu'ils ont dit et que je
partage complètement merci le 142 rect
ifier le suivi
merci madame la Présidente
là aussi il s'agit d'un amendement pour
essayer de
répondre à des effets de bord qui ont
été créés par cette réforme toujours sur
les communes nouvelles en effet un
certain nombre de communes nouvelles qui
dépassent le seuil de 10 000 habitants
deviennent inéligibles à la DSR ça
représentait environ 32 communes
nouvelles
le gouvernement dans un dans un
amendement à essayer de trouver une
solution à cela en permettant de je vais
citer l'amendement il dit que les
communes peuvent rester éligibles à la
DSR ceux qui ont porterait alors
l'inéligibilité à la dotation de
solidarité urbaine donc elle a DSU
lorsque ceci a été fait il y a pas eu de
simulation qui ont été faites elles ont
été faites depuis notamment par
l'Association des maires de France et on
s'aperçoit en fait que voulant aider
certains nombre de communes on les
enfonce encore un petit peu plus parce
qu'on leur fait perdre la DSU qui était
souvent bien plus importante que la DSR
qu'on leur accorde en contrepartie donc
là encore c'est une peine supplémentaire
qu'on met sur le dos de ces communes sur
les 32 qui étaient concernés jusqu'à
présent ça concerne à peu près 13
communes nouvelle donc vous allez dire
c'est pas énorme mais là encore c'est la
promesse qu'on fait assez commune on
leur met encore une charge
supplémentaire sur le dos donc il
semblerait nécessaire de revenir sur de
cette situation et de permettre à ces
communes notamment de continuer à
percevoir la déesse pendant un temps
limité si vous voulez et si vous
maintenez votre invitation au ministère
madame la ministre vous nous direz
d'abord ce qu'on mange mais ensuite on
pourra mettre au menu ce genre de
disposition pour discuter précisément de
la manière dont on pourra faire sortir
ces communes dignement de ce dispositif
je vous remercie
433 bis identique madame Gatel
madame la Présidente je vais te très
rapide de on a donc un problème de
glissement parfois pour certaines
interco qui sont plus éligibles en DSR
qui pourrait être éligible en dsumés on
n'est pas sûr de tout ça donc il y a 13
comme une nouvelle qui redeviendrait
éligible à la DSR en 2023 mais perdront
leur éligibilité à la DSU voilà cette
nouvelle disposition que vous proposez
aggrave leur situation compte tenu du
risque cette proposition fait prendre
nos communes nouvelle concernées nous
proposons par cet amendement de
conserver la perception de la DSU pour
ses communes nouvelles dans l'attente
des premiers résultats sur la DSR de ces
communes nouvelles en 2023 c'est la mise
en application de l'histoire du chat
dans le sac
merci et enfin le
585 non mais comme déjà dit Monsieur
Vial et Madame Gatel ont tout dit et
donc je me range à leurs explications
que je partage y compris jusqu'au menu
madame la ministre merci Madame cuerman
alors bah maintenant nous pouvons passer
aux avis sur l'ensemble de ses
amendements alors je vais pas donner un
avis par amendement puisque on a fait
une une présentation commune au départ
et cette
présentation commune je pensais que
c'était compris dans mon propos
vaut demande de retrait pour tous les
amendements et j'ai même fini d'ailleurs
en disant que je vais je considérer que
ma comment dire ma capacité à vous y
amener me paraissait limiter donc je
reste vous voyez très serein par rapport
à ce point-là évidemment
ça ne rien à vous interventions ne
répond au fait que ces amendements et ne
peuvent pas être mis en oeuvre bon
petit souci au problème constitutionnels
évident
pas de souci non plus c'est pas relevé
on fait comme si on n'avait pas vu il y
a pas de souci mais
en même temps je vous dis que
malheureusement ça va s'appliquer comme
ça donc le sujet important c'est comment
effectivement on est capable un jour
ensemble de rédiger un texte qui
fonctionne est-ce qu'on en est capable
voilà c'est ça notre sujet tout le reste
sera voté il y a pas de souci il y a pas
d'inquiétude mais sera une opérant donc
après après avoir fait notre débat ce
qui reste important c'est que nous
sommes tous attachés à trouver des
solutions pour les communes nouvelles ça
ça reste vrai et ça doit être resté
l'aspect positif et utile de notre débat
quel que soit le vote par ailleurs bon
j'ai beaucoup aimé Cédric Vial
l'argument le gouvernement nous nous a
pas fourni de simulation j'attends les
vôtres surtout les amendements là qu'on
vote je suis pas tout à fait certain que
tous nos amendements fassent l'objet de
simulation mais bon mais je trouve
amusant pour une fois de l'utiliser dans
l'autre sens je l'avais jamais tenté
mais vous c'est bien c'est ça m'ouvre ça
m'ouvre des des perspectives enfin je
crois qu'il faut il faut pas trop
madame ku Karman chers collègues à mon
avis alors vous allez me dire que c'est
parce que vous avez dit je vous connais
mais quand même vous l'avez dit tu
aurais des mères qui n'auraient pas bien
compris mais qu'aurait fait que si vous
avez dit ça et qu'aurait été amené
contraint etc d'abord ma chère
intéressant pour les marques en question
d'apprendre que ils ont été menés par le
bout du nez je
je ne crois pas qu'on puisse se dire ça
et
madame cuckermann on va on va rester
calme et on va repartir sur le débat
monsieur le Président Monsieur
je ne crois pas qu'on puisse dire les
choses ainsi en tout cas faut le dire
avec prudence sur ces aspects de manière
générale moi je connais ce débat
des communes nouvelles dans mon
département
j'en ai été figurez-vous vous en doutez
sans doute un peu promoteur comme ici
d'ailleurs j'ai un succès limité voilà
c'est à dire que vous voyez par exemple
5 communes au hasard de 10 15 20
habitants etc où tous les maires m'ont
dit qu'ils étaient intéressés mais après
avoir interrogé les 15 habitants ils ont
dit ben on garde notre mairie notre
cimetière notre truc on fait rien
voilà on ne fait rien et bien chez moi
il n'y a pas une je crois que pas une
commune nouvelle voilà pourtant j'ai
essayé de les amener
et bien je n'y suis pas arrivé voyez et
ils ont tous compris les avantages
inconvénients parce que rien de ce que
certains découvrent n'étaient inconnus
au départ rien donc il y a des il y a
des avantages et des inconvénients comme
dans tout tout groupement tout truc il y
a des avantages il y a des inconvénients
c'est la même chose et donc en toute
état de cause ces amendements
vous allez les voter et le point
important c'est qu'on va se retrouver
après pour trouver des amendements qui
tournent et on essaiera de le faire
merci
madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs vous dire bon je
n'ai pas été compris par Françoise Gatel
ce n'est pas grave
on se retrouve à malgré tout pour
travailler j'ai beaucoup apprécié les
prises de parole qui visaient accepter
de travailler ensemble ce que je veux
dire en résumé très court
anticonstitutionnalités vous pouvez ne
pas être d'accord moi j'arrive et on
reçoit vos amendements vendredi 11h moi
j'arrive dans ce ministère lundi je
travaille hier pour préparer cette
séance les services me disent c'est
anticonstitutionnel bien sûr que ils
peuvent se tromper mais en attendant moi
je vous dis que je fais confiance et que
quand on me dit anticonstitutionnalités
ou quand on me dit madame la sénatrice
inopérant et quand on me dit aussi du
pack de the stabilité aussi auquel on
est attaché certains de ses amendements
ne sont pas opportun moi je viens vous
dire en introduction et en motivant la
position du gouvernement pour lequel
voilà c'est trois points trois raisons
qui font que je pensais que l'on pouvait
travailler ensemble mais je continue en
conclusion à vous dire et là je n'ai pas
été compris donc je le redire à quel
point le gouvernement soutient les
communes nouvelles mais écoutez madame
la sénatrice est-ce que ça peut passer
par des amendements de soutenir
soutenir ne veut pas dire que on est
d'accord pour les raisons que je viens
d'invoquer j'ai pas les reciter qu'on
est d'accord avec ces 16 amendements
donc ce que je vous propose c'est de
mettre en oeuvre ce soutien efficacement
par un travail comme ça a été dit par
monsieur le rapporteur ensemble et dès
la semaine prochaine et ça pourrait être
poursuivi si on travaille bien pendant
deux heures par un déjeuner merci
beaucoup alors madame cuckermann vous
avez la parole
[Musique]
madame cuckermann pour explication de
vote
merci madame la présidente Madame la
mise bon juste un très sincèrement
d'abord bon effectivement je m'en excuse
on a pas à se prendre à parti comme je
l'ai fait tout à l'heure peut-être
monsieur le président de la commission
des finances simplement chacun son
caractère chacun a son mot donc on peut
tous se jouer des choses sur ce qu'il
faudrait dire et dans quel terme je
crois que par contre nous pourrons nous
pourrions nous retrouver l'un et l'autre
sur le fait que par exemple une fois que
les communes nouvelles ont été créées
par la législation nous pourrions
constater l'un et l'autre que
l'accompagnement indispensable qu'aurait
dû être celui par exemple des services
de l'État qu'aurait dû être celui de la
DG fit aux côtés de ces différents élus
y compris pour les accompagner en
matière de prospective financière et de
projection de ce à quoi ils ont élu
étant parfois lacunaire je n'oserais
dire absente madame la ministre parce
que là encore on me dirait que je suis
dans l'excès donc en tout cas lacunaire
a fait parfois que aujourd'hui un
certain nombre début ont pris des
décisions en lien ou pas avec leur
population certaines parfois en lien
avec leur population qui font que nous
sommes dans des difficultés qui amènent
effectivement les différents amendements
être déposés parce que infinie dans la
réalité dans la vraie vie je m'excuse de
cette expression qui n'est peut-être pas
très érudit pour cette émission mais en
tout cas dans la vraie vie tout n'a pas
été maîtrisé tout n'a pas été mesuré
qu'aujourd'hui nous avons des élus qui
sont constatés à ces choix madame la
ministre très simplement
on vous a entendu je crois que
j'aimerais pas être personnellement à
votre place effectivement en deux jours
reprendre un la mission collectivité
territoriale c'est un défi j'oserais
vous dire mais vous avez tous meilleur
que ça avec beaucoup d'excès vous savez
la constitutionnalisation le rapport à
la caution était de tel amendement du
pacte de stabilité sachez des fois vous
en démarquez nous sommes ici pour faire
de la politique et les soins à d'autres
le soin d'arbitrer en tout cas sachant
travailler plus de deux heures s'il le
faut et nous sans chantage nous
passerons tous un bon moment dans
l'intérêt de nos collectivités
nous avons une demande de parole de
d'abord madame Goulet ensuite monsieur
Capu et Monsieur delège
oui mais madame la présidente madame la
ministre vous avez vous nous avez dit
tout l'intérêt que vous portiez au
travail collectif alors c'est peut-être
un détail pour vous mais pour nous ça
veut dire beaucoup est-ce que vous
pourriez travailler à voir avec vos
services le nombre de grands électeurs
des communes nouvelles en France parce
que nos préfets ont beaucoup de
difficultés à connaître d'ores et déjà
le nombre de grands électeurs et
voyez-vous c'est un sujet qui nous
intéresse donc ça fait pas partie d'un
amendement et comme je vous l'ai dit
c'est peut-être un détail pour vous mais
pour nous ça veut dire beaucoup merci
chers collègues
alors Monsieur Capu
merci madame la Présidente non juste
trois mots la première évidemment pour
remercier la ministre pour son
invitation à travailler ensemble et nous
serons bien évidemment présents le
deuxième
le deuxième mot effectivement alors il
faut faire attention quand on a des
amendements comme ça qui viennent de
tous les bancs c'est quand même qu'il y
a un bon sens du Sénat qui représente ce
bon sens des élus locaux et la troisième
observation parce que je n'ai pas
répondu à ce point-là par avance tout à
l'heure au rapporteur pas d'un pardon au
président en rapportant spécial sur le
problème de la constitutionnalisation on
n'est pas tous des constitutionnalités
ici et je ne sais pas si tous les
amendements sont conformes à la
Constitution je l'espère je le pense il
y en a un sur lequel je peux on peut
tous vous mettre d'accord c'est le 380
que j'ai déposé et celui qui a été
déposé par mes deux collègues il s'agit
juste de rajouter à peu danse à la
densité peu dense très peu dense ou de
densité intermédiaire donc qui conserve
toutes les communes de France il y a
aucune différenciation pérenne entre les
communes nouvelles et les autres donc
celui-ci sans être constitutionnaliste
je peux vous affirmer de façon certaine
qu'il est parfaitement conforme à la
Constitution donc celui-là mes chers il
y aura pas de problème il y a pas de
problème sur les autres mais celui-là
encore moins
la présidente
madame la ministre monsieur les
rapporteurs moi je voudrais vous faire
part de ma perplexité sur ce débat
depuis deux heures parce que tout à
l'heure on a eu un débat très
intéressant sur la DGF on est tous
d'accord pour dire que ça fonctionne pas
mais quand par hasard on fait bouger un
curseur l'année d'après on revient en se
disant voilà mon dieu il y en a qui ont
perdu on entend jamais ceux qui ont
gagné mais comment peut-on faire une
réforme où tout le monde serait gagnant
alors que l'enveloppe est constante je
crois qu'il faut avoir l'honnêteté de de
le reconnaître et là je suis frappé sur
sur ce débat que que nous avons où on
veut corriger les effets que nous
n'avions pas vu d'un vol sans doute un
peu précipité sur les communes nouvelles
c'était génial les communes nouvelles on
allait ensemble on allait être plus fort
c'est comme les OPCI sauf qu'à la sortie
quand il y a pas plus de sous il y a
toujours le même nombre de kilomètres
d'euros tu as toujours le même nombre
d'élèves donc je ne sais pas comment une
réforme de structure peut multiplier les
sous alors je voudrais former un vœu
madame la ministre vous nous invitez
tous à déjeuner moi ce que je souhaite
c'est que l'année prochaine on ne se
dise pas la même chose que l'année
dernière parce que l'année dernière on
s'est quitté sur ce débat en disant
promis juré on va travailler pendant
l'année et qui vient et l'année
prochaine lors du vote du budget nous
trouverons une voie de passage je
constate que nous ne l'avons pas cette
fois-ci pour ma part je l'ai signé aucun
amendement et je n'en vauterai aucun
donc nous n'aurons pas été capables
ensemble de se dire que faire une
réforme c'est accepter de tout mettre
sur la table accepter que des perdants
acceptés qui étaient des gagnants mais
la réforme où il y a que des gagnants je
n'y crois pas
très rapidement madame la présidente
madame la ministre nous on prendra les
deux c'est comme le fromage et le
dessert c'est-à-dire on prend les
amendements et l'invitation à travailler
je vous en remercie mais le fait que sur
tous les membres de cela ça a du sens
monsieur le Président de la Commission
évident avec amitié respect je partage
tout ce que vous dites et je suis
sensible à votre proposition pourra même
se rapprocher de vous pour travailler
l'anticonstitutionnalité alors moi j'ai
une confiance éperdues dans le dgcel qui
est là et ça me donne l'occasion de lui
rendre hommage moi j'ai beaucoup
travaillé avec lui non non mais sur 3DS
et sur engagement et proximité à chaque
fois il nous a trouvé des solutions donc
monsieur le DGCL et le roi des opérants
donc encore quelques jours à la
direction des collectivités il va nous
inventer la solution très sincèrement
donc je vous remercie et je veux juste
te dire que ce ne sont pas les élus des
communes nouvelles qu'ont
les lois de finances successives et les
réformes sont venus impacter les
prévisions qui étaient faites donc c'est
pas eux qui sont aveugles c'est
qu'encore une fois on a changé le monde
alors même qu'on leur a dit que cette
réforme et se déroulait dans un cadre
merci beaucoup et à très bientôt à tous
parce que
alors il n'y a plus monsieur
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre je voulais aussi souscrire aux
propos de Madame Gatel et de beaucoup
d'autres collègues en effet lorsque la
loi a été présentée c'était une
proposition de loi sur les communes
nouvelles
moi je me souviens tout à fait être
avoir parlé à cette tribune et avoir
appelé à la prudence et avoir dit dans
mon département je ne ferai aucune
propagande je dirais que c'est un outil
qui existe mais qu'il faut faire
attention je sais que dans certains
départements les préfets se sont fait
militants en essayant de multiplier les
communes nouvelles comme si c'était
nécessairement mieux
je crois que la solution des communautés
de communes
qui sait développer au fil du temps qui
maintenant est généralisée présente le
grand avantage de respecter l'identité
de la commune on peut faire tout ce
qu'on veut les Français ont la commune
dans le cœur quel que soit la taille de
la commune et ça permet de travailler
ensemble tout en respectant cette entité
et si naturellement des élus veulent
faire une commune nouvelle ils peuvent
le faire
cela dit je prends la suite de Madame
Gatel pour dire que je pense qu'il est
possible de trouver des solutions il
n'est pas vrai qu'il y a aucune
possibilité
de prendre en compte les évolutions qui
sont intervenues et de sorte
d'aberration par rapport à la DSR qui
ferait qu'on serait moins rural du fait
qu'il y aurait eu une communauté de
communes donc j'appelle de mes vœux avec
un gap ou sans agape le fait que
vraiment on y arrive parce que je crois
que ce serait justice par rapport à des
élus qui n'ont pas pu mesurer parce que
les lois de finances futures n'étaient
pas encore votées ce qui se passerait
exactement
si monsieur Sueur merci Monsieur le
testeur monsieur VIAL
oui merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre mes chers collègues
par ses amendements on a essayé de faire
des propositions pour régler un certain
nombre de problèmes on a on est tous
conscients ici ça a été dit je veux pas
y revenir que le problème perdu et
perdurera qu'on vote ou pas ses
amendements et donc on est tous très
favorable à trouver une solution comme
nous y invite d'ailleurs la Cour des
comptes et elle est pas la seule si on
souhaite maintenir un dispositif de
commune nouvelle préenseur l'a dit aussi
il va falloir présenter la dot et la
barrière un peu différemment sinon il
faut arrêter le dispositif par contre je
pense qu'on a un engagement et
désengagement à tenir auprès de ceux qui
ont déjà fait le choix soit convaincu
par le militantisme de certains préfets
c'est vrai ou du gouvernement en tous
les cas ou des dispositifs qu'on leur
avait proposé à l'époque et qui au final
par des modifications législatives
ultérieures ne sont plus la réalité
qu'elles vivent aujourd'hui donc je
pense qu'on avait on a ce devoir
moi monsieur le monsieur le Président
rénal j'avais j'ai soutenu trois
amendements ici dont celui de ma
collègue Agnès canaille
j'aurais j'envisageais en fait de me
rallier à la sagesse de la commission si
vous avez eu des avis un peu plus
nuancés j'étais prêt à retirer un
certain nombre d'amendements si on avait
obtenu d'autres on a un avis qui qui
tombe de cette manière et sans aucune
nuance je ne me vois donc pas dans la
possibilité de nuancer moi-même et donc
je maintiendrai tous ces amendements
merci chers collègues alors je pense que
là tout le monde s'est exprimé et que
nous allons pas pouvoir passer au vote
sur ces amendements alors tout d'abord
nous avons une série de trois
identiques 141 400 à 432 qui ont reçu
évidemment deux avis des favorables de
la Commission et du gouvernement qui
pour
ces trois identiques qui pour
qui contre
ils sont adoptés
et ils font
tomber tous les autres
nous passons à l'amendement 253 il est
présenté par Monsieur Ferro
merci madame la Présidente
sont perturbés par le nombre
d'amendements qui sont tombés donc je
présente l'amendement 253
la loi de 1999 qui crée la couverture
maladie universelle à supprimer la
participation obligatoire des communes
aux dépenses d'aide sociale des
départements et parallèlement à la
minoré la dotation forfaitaire de chaque
commune et augmenter celle des
départements la loi de finances pour
2022 à elle supprimé la mention de la
ville de Paris dans la rédaction de
l'article 23 34 du Code Général des
Collectivités Territoriales mention qui
permettait de traiter équitablement
l'ensemble des communes et la ville de
Paris dans le calcul de leur potentiel
financier du fait de son statut
particulier cumulant compétences
communales et départementale la ville
n'a ainsi pas vu sa DGF communale
minorée ni sa DGF départemental
augmenter en conséquence son potentiel
financier communal n'a pas été minorée
comme c'est le cas pour les autres
communes et le niveau de recettes pris
en compte a été minorée pour les autres
communes sauf pour la ville de Paris cet
amendement vise donc à revenir sur cette
suppression intervenue en 2022 sans
aucune concertation avec la ville et
aboutissant un traitement défavorable
pour que la Ville de Paris est le même
traitement que l'ensemble des autres
communes françaises je vous remercie
merci Monsieur Ferro avis de la
commission
la présidente madame la ministre mes
chers collègues monsieur Ferro vous
entendez par votre avanttement revenir
sur la suppression de la minoration du
potentiel financier de la ville de Paris
de la participation obligatoire de la de
la commune aux dépenses d'aide santé au
Département de Paris constaté donc en
2007 ce retraitement se justifiait par
le fait que désormais cette collectivité
exerce les compétences départementales
et lorsqu'on considère que par ailleurs
la réforme de la TH a une incidence très
favorable au potentiel de financier de
la ville de Paris est-il
utile d'aller plus loin semble-t-il donc
c'est plutôt une demande de retraite
mais en plus vous allez avoir le
bénéfice d'un avis ministre neutre
merci monsieur le rapporteur donc madame
la ministre je vous donne un avis
défavorable de la part du gouvernement
et je retiens les arguments présentés
par le rapporteur merci alors
je mets on voit monsieur Ferro pour
explication de vote
merci madame la Présidente une nouvelle
fois
la ville de Paris n'est pas traitée
équitablement avec l'ensemble des autres
communes de France il faut le dire je
suis content d'entendre dire que vous
considérez madame la ministre parce que
j'aurais aimé vous entendre sur le sujet
considéré que le potentiel financier de
la ville de Paris est suffisant mais moi
je veux le dire peut paraître un détail
pour vous mais pour nous c'est essentiel
pour reprendre ce que disait Nathalie
Goulet et la chanson tout à l'heure je
pense que l'ensemble des communes des
collectivités des territoires ont le
droit d'être traité en équité Paris et
les Parisiens également
merci Monsieur
frérot il n'y a pas d'explication de
vote
je vais mettre aux voix donc
l'amendement 253 qui a reçu deux avis
défavorables qui pour
qui contre
il n'est pas adopté un manque quatre
631 et c'est Monsieur
il est retiré
le alors trois amendements faisant
l'objet d'une discussion commune le 57
madame Noël merci madame la présidente
madame la ministre il s'agit d'un
amendement que j'avais déjà déposé en
2020 qui avait été adopté grâce aux voix
de nombreux collègues sur tous les bancs
de cette hémicycle et j'espère
renouveler l'exploit à l'image de
l'amendement adopté tout à l'heure par
notre collègue Hervé Morel c'est un
moment a pour but de revoir le calcul de
la répartition de de la part de dotation
forfaitaire pour diminuer les inégalités
entre
urbain et rural aujourd'hui compris
entre 1 et 2 les quarts entre les
montants alloués au plus petites
communes et au plus grandes seraient
ainsi réduit à 1,6 grâce à cet
amendement ceci étant justifié par le
fait que la plupart des charges de
centralité sont aujourd'hui assumées par
les intercommunalités je vous remercie
merci le 113 qu'il défend monsieur
delcroz monsieur Lamini qu'il est
défendu
il est défendu le 169 rectifiés monsieur
sotarel oui merci oui merci madame la
présidente madame la ministre mes chers
collègues mon amendement est similaire à
celui de ma collègue Sylvian de Noël
sauf qu'il propose un coefficient de
1,5 au lieu de 1,6 mais j'ai du mal à
comprendre qu'il n'est pas été mis en
discussion commune avec l'amendement
tout à l'heure de notre collègue Hervé
Moret qui a été adopté et donc je
m'interroge sur la compatibilité de ces
amendements du coup je vais retirer mon
amendement comme j'ai apporté ma voix à
celui de mon collègue avait mourrait
tout à l'heure mais j'en profite de
quelques secondes de parole qui me sont
accordés madame la ministre pour
solliciter la même invitation que mes
collègues intéressés par les communes
nouvelles parce que les communes
anciennes ou toutes les communes sont
toutes intéressées par la question de la
voirie dont on a beaucoup parlé et donc
je compte bien qu'on est aussi une
réunion de travail sur la voirie comme
vous le proposez sur la question des
communes nouvelles merci beaucoup merci
Monsieur sotarel et donc le 169 est
retiré à vie de la commission monsieur
le rapporteur madame la Présidente oui
effectivement en écho ce que vient de
dire monsieur sotarel c'est 3 amendement
qui sont très proches de
celui de qui était adopté de Monsieur
Moret son virtuellement satisfaits donc
je vous propose
de les de les retirer ou de considérer
qu'ils sont satisfaits quoi parce que
effectivement on aurait pu effectivement
les discuter ensemble donc sinon je vous
demanderai de retrait et un avis
défavorable mais comme vous avez voté le
Moret
alors madame la ministre
même avec le rapporteur merci alors pour
le 57 madame Noël vous le maintenez vous
le retirez
donc il est retiré et le 113 monsieur la
mini les retiré il est retiré
le 99 madame
si Madame vermillier
merci madame la Présidente c'est un
rendement a pour objet de protéger les
communes de moins de 1000 habitants les
empêchant d'être frappés par une DGF
négative le mécanisme prévoit de
supprimer pour ses communes la ponction
sur la fiscalité opérée lorsque le
montant de la DGF n'est pas suffisant
pour acquitter la contribution au
redressement des finances publiques il
doit ainsi permettre de protéger les
collectivités qui bien souvent rurales
se voient en plus de ce prélèvement
sommet de contribuer à la péréquation
par la contribution au pic c'est
notamment le cas des territoires
touristiques de montagne dont plus de
50% des hausses de fiscalité sont
attribuées à ces deux prélèvements donc
cet amendement évite les DGF négatifs
merci chers collègues monsieur le
rapporteur
oui
je rappelle qu'en fait
438 communes sont concernées par une DGF
négatif dont 236 de moins de 1000
habitants
simplement
le fait d'avoir une DGF négative n'a
rien d'un congru c'est quelque chose qui
résulte d'un phénomène mécanique et le
problème c'est que c'est pas parce
qu'une commune est petite qu'elle est
pauvre et quelque part ça veut dire que
on va peut-être avantager des des
communes qui ont une DGF négative parce
qu'elles ont des ressources phénoménales
par ailleurs sous prétexte qu'elles sont
petites elles vont être dispensées d'un
effort que l'ensemble des collectivités
supportent donc je ne peux que vous
demander un retrait sinon être
défavorable
si ma vie madame la ministre mais ma vie
alors madame vermilly explication de
vote elle va être très courte j'entends
sur le rapporteur mais symboliquement
une DGF négative c'est pas possible
voilà donc je maintiens cet amendement
alors je mets aux voiles l'amendement 99
qui a reçu par non explication de vote
madame prima
quelques instants je veux dire au
rapporteur je suis désolé mais je vais
voter c'est amendement prendre de la DGF
à des communes qui ne collecte plus cet
argent face à quelque chose de
complètement délirant et je suis désolé
mais il y a aujourd'hui madame la
ministre des communes dans mon
département qui ont des DGF négatives et
qui sont pas riches voilà et qui sont
pas riches alors il y en a plein qui
sont à zéro depuis quelques années
maintenant et qui sont pas riches non
plus alors peut-être elles ont un
potentiel fiscal élevé mais il faut
regarder aussi la qualité de leur
population donc on sait bien que sur la
DGF il y a un gros travail mais des dsgf
négatives là je trouve que c'est le
pompon donc moi je voterai cet
amendement
alors je mets au voile amendement de
Madame Vermeillet qui a reçu un avis
défavorable de la commission et du
gouvernement qui est pour
qui contre
il est adopté
le
633 monsieur ah non pardon
ministre le présente amendement vise à
intégrer un critère de taux logements
sociaux dans le calcul de la première
fraction de la dotation de solidarité
rurale dite bourse centre alors que
notre pays connaît un important déficit
de logements sociaux et considérant que
la crise économique et sociale induite
par l'épidémie covid-19 va entraîner un
besoin croissant de logements abordable
pour nos concitoyens il apparaît
pertinent de récompenser les communes
rurales qui prennent leur part de
solidarité nationale en produisant de
tels logements alors que le gouvernement
souhaite par ailleurs que les
collectivités locales jouent un rôle
central dans la relance de notre
économie une telle mesure peut être de
nature à inciter les maires de ces
communes à produire logement social ne
serait-ce que pour maintenir leur
taureau
merci Monsieur stanzion
là on passe à la ville de la Commission
la présidente mes chers collègues il
s'agit là donc d'intégrer un critère de
taux de logements sociaux dans le calcul
de la fraction boursante de la DSR
c'est vrai que c'est pas véritablement
incohérent avec la vocation d'un
boursintre mais bon quand on sait que la
notion de Boursin est très variable dans
notre
dans l'Hexagone il serait sans doute
nécessaire de faire des des évaluations
et une concertation plus large mais
enfin bon étant donné qu'on a rajouté
d'autres critères alors qu'on en
rejetait d'autres je fais une demande de
retrait mais bon
je voulais
madame la ministre mais ma vie retrait
même avis
vous le maintenez donc je mets au voile
le 633 qui a reçu un avis des favorable
de la commission et du gouvernement qui
est pour
qui contre
qui n'est pas adopté
le nous passons à deux amendements qui
font l'objet d'une discussion commune le
648 monsieur patient
mon amendement pour créer le SPIC il
propose que le principe du droit commun
appliqué aux collectivités des
départements région d'outre-mer
or Mayotte déjà en vigueur pour ce qui
concerne le dispositif de prélèvement
soit étendu Audi positifs de reversement
du SMIC ce qui permettrait d’accorder la
même valeur aux critères de répartition
du public sur l'ensemble du territoire
national
par ailleurs pour éviter que des EPCI de
l'Hexagone éligible jusque là ne se
retrouvent exclus par l'augmentation du
nombre de PCI
ultramarins éligibles il est proposé de
faire passer la part de les EPCI
éligibles aux versement du flics de 60%
à 60,6%
le second demande que soit modifié les
modalités de reversement du flicdom en
rendant l'ensemble des EPCI de
Guadeloupe Guyane Martin Martinique et
de la Réunion éligible et non plus les
seuls 60% des plus pauvres
merci et le second le 649 défendu très
bien avis de la commission monsieur le
rapporteur
m'en demande donc vise à aligner sur le
droit commun les modalités de
reversement au titre du SMIC
nous semble que un tel dispositif serait
inéquitable pour les ensembles
intercommunaux de l'Hexagone dans la
mesure où ceux d'outre-mer ne voient pas
leurs ressources d'octroi de mer prise
en compte donc le poids de mer est quand
même un gros différentiel et je vous le
savez chers collègues passant est depuis
longtemps
pour le deuxième le 649 qui vise à
augmenter de 33 à 60% le taux de
majoration de la population prise en
compte là aussi on n'a pas évidemment
de
d'estimation précise de enfin il s'agit
d'une enveloppe fermée d'un milliard
donc comme d'habitude ce qui est donné
aux heures en plus étant levé aux autres
donc je crois que ce sont des
discussions qu'il faut avoir
préalablement avec le gouvernement qui
éventuellement après un chiffrage peut
revenir vers l'Assemblée pour faire
voter cela et peut-être pas par un
amendement donc plutôt des demandes de
retraite sur les deux amendements
merci monsieur le rapporteur mais ma vie
madame la ministre absolument madame la
Présidente
vous maintenez vos amendements vous les
retirez
mais je voudrais simplement préciser
monsieur le Président du conseil
d'administration que l'octroi de mer est
une recette de fiscalité indirecte et
dans l'Hexagone les recettes de
fiscalité indirecte ne sont pas prises
en considération quand il s'agit de
calculer le SPIC merci les 648 et 649
sont donc retirés merci Monsieur patient
alors le 702 rectifié
qu'il défend Monsieur Hervé merci madame
la présidente madame la ministre chers
collègues c'est un amendement qui avait
déjà été déposé il y a quelques années
et qui se propose d'organiser leur
ruissellement des métropoles vers ce
qu'on peut appeler leur arrière-pays en
mettant en place le 1 % métropole vous
savez que dans nos territoires les
métropoles concentrent la richesse
intellectuelle la richesse financière
les investissements et qu'il est
nécessaire parfois que la solidarité qui
n'est pas si naturelle que ça qu'on
renvoie souvent des contrats de
réciprocité certaines collectivités je
pense notamment à
des grandes villes françaises ont
commencé ce travail mais il m'est bien
du temps à rentrer dans la réalité et
donc ce que l'association des petites
villes de France à proposer déjà à
plusieurs reprises c'est de créer une
occasion
de d'organiser cette solidarité du de la
métropole vers l'arrière-pays
collègues oui je te demande que l'on a
vu quelquefois
il vise à situer un fond régional de
solidarité inter territoriale alors dans
le détail 1% des recettes tirées de la
fiscalité professionnelle par la
métropole serait prélevée sur cette
dernière chaque année à disposition de
la conférence territoriale d'action
publique afin de financer des projets
structurants alors bon c'est un
dispositif supplémentaire parce qu'il y
en a déjà beaucoup un tel dispositif
semble donc redondant par rapport au pic
auquel les métropoles contribuent très
largement
ensuite
on peut dire que la métropole et
l'activité métropolitaine contribue
beaucoup aux sources départementales qui
ont justement vocation à revenir vers
les projets territoriaux
et puis on peut indiquer également que
la suppression probable de la CVAE
limiterait d'ailleurs fortement la
portée d'un tel fond parce que là on
sait plus
exactement ce que l'on donnerait si
c'est une part de TVA après enfin c'est
plutôt
donc défavorable
madame la ministre
merci madame la Présidente donc notre
position sera défavorable même si nous
sommes très en faveur de l'Inter
territorialité de la solidarité des
territoires ruraux des territoires
urbains mais pour les raisons invoquées
particulièrement le fait que c'était à P
n'est pas une instance décisionnelle la
position du Gouvernement est défavorable
merci Madame la Ministre
pas d'explication de votre SI me
surveille
la maman malgré la demande de retrait de
la part de monsieur le rapporteur
on peut pas seulement invoquer la
solidarité dire qu'il faut que les élus
organisent entre eux alors que nous
voyons très bien que il y a des
territoires dans laquelle elle est en
passe de devenir réalité que dans
d'autres ça n'est pas absolument pas le
cas les démographes les économistes
montrent aujourd'hui que dans notre pays
la métropolisation c'est la
concentration de la croissance de la
richesse de et y compris sur un plan
sociologique j'entendais tout à l'heure
que les métropoles concentrent les
pauvres mais enfin faut regarder aussi
la réalité non les territoires
périurbains les territoires ruraux en
proximité sont aussi des territoires qui
sont des territoires parfois
sociologiquement en souffrance c'est pas
la gentrification elle se fait
essentiellement aujourd'hui dans les
centres villes des métropoles bien plus
que dans la ruralité proche de ces de
ces métropoles et vous avez des risques
de rupture donc je maintiens cet
amendement je pense madame la ministre
si vous avez encore un peu de temps
parce qu'on a voulu vous voulez bosser
c'est comme une nouvelle mais je pense
que sur ce thème là il y aurait de quoi
organiser un groupe de travail sous
votre régime pour réfléchir à ça
alors la parole est à Monsieur Marie
merci Marie présidente
l'amendement de mon collègue Loïc Hervé
un grand mérite c'est qu'il pose la
question de la coopération entre les
métropoles et leur environnement
immédiat
la solution du 1%
est une solution parmi d'autres n'est
peut-être pas la meilleure comme la
rappeler le rapporteur spécial puisque
d'autres moyens de concourir à la
solidarité financière existe mais il est
impératif de revisiter les dispositifs
existants aujourd'hui les pôles
métropolitain n'existe pas ou ne
fonctionne pas et quand ils existent ils
concerne quelques compétences partagées
qui ne sont pas financées or il y a des
exemples qui fonctionnent si vous prenez
la métropole de Rennes qui a mis en
place un dispositif de collaboration
avec l'ensemble des communauté de
communes de son environnement si vous
prenez y compris celle dans laquelle je
suis à Rouen il y a des possibilités le
seul problème c'est qu'aujourd'hui il
faudra arriver à structurer cela et à le
rendre obligatoire car autrement les
métropoles restent campés pour certaines
d'entre elles sur leur territoire sur
leur compétences et ne discutent pas
avec l'ensemble des communautés de
communes environnantes ce qui pose un
véritable problème on pourrait citer
différents sujets le premier d'entre eux
étant celui des transports par exemple
alors madame la ministre souhaite
prendre la parole mais je voudrais dire
que si vous souhaitez encore une
possibilité de finir la mission avant
20h enfin pour 20h à condition de faire
du 30 amendement à l'heure donc ça veut
dire ramasser vous avez le choix
merci madame la Présidente je voulais
juste répondre favorablement à l'appel à
réflexion et groupe de travail par
contre pas la semaine prochaine mais en
janvier sur deux sujets le sujet de la
coopération
territoriale entre les métropoles et les
territoires ruraux cette réconciliation
des territoires donc on posera tout en
janvier une réunion de travail et il est
parti monsieur le sénateur mais on va
aussi en janvier travailler sur la
voirie quand je vois la masse
d'amendement qui a été proposé sur ce
sujet donc voilà je réponds
favorablement à ces deux groupes de
travail complémentaires à celui des
communes nouvelles
donc je mets aux voix cet amendement où
on se retire on le maintient on est bien
d'accord je mets au voie cet amendement
qui a reçu deux avis des favorables qui
est pour
qui contre
n'est pas adoptée
nous avons trois amendements discussion
commune le 515 monsieur yakovic oui
madame la présidente madame Lamy chers
collègues je cet amendement est porté au
nom de plusieurs communes des
Hauts-de-Seine concernant le calcul des
indicateurs de richesse comme le
potentiel fiscal et le potentiel
financier qui ont été modifiés dans la
loi de finances pour 2021 et pour 2022
pour intégrer les effets des réformes
fiscales de 2021 notamment la
suppression de la taxe d'habitation de
la division par deux de la CFE et de la
taxe foncière sur les propriétés bâties
des établissements industriels
la répartition des dotations est de
péréquation horizontale des communes et
intercommunalités de nulle part et des
départements d'autre part imposent de
calculer les indicateurs distincts pour
la ville et le département de Paris qui
forment une collectivité territoriale à
statut unique les lois de finances
prévoient un calcul dérogatoire des
indicateurs de richesse de la ville et
du département de Paris qui conduisent à
ne pas appliquer le même traitement
qu'aux autres collectivités auxquelles
elles sont comparées à l'échelon
communale d'une part et à l'échelon
départementale d'autre part concernant
la répartition des dotations et des
péréquations horizontales la ville de
Paris à certes bénéficie d'un traitement
spécifique pour la compensation de la
suppression de la taxe d'habitation
laquelle a été intégralement compensée
par une part de la TVA
ceci étant cette particularité
n'interdit en rien de calculer le
potentiel financier de la ville et du
département selon les règles similaires
aux autres communes et aux autres
départements garantissant ainsi
l'égalité de traitement entre les
collectivités de chaque échelon dans les
dispositifs de péréquation de la
couronne parisienne c'est notamment un
enjeu important s'agissant de la
répartition des contributions au fond de
solidarité des communes de la région
Île-de-France dont Paris représente 61%
en 2022 par certains amendement je vous
propose donc mes chers collègues de
modifier le calcul du potentiel fiscal
et financier de Paris ainsi que ses
indicateurs pour qu'ils soient calculé
de la même dans les mêmes conditions que
les autres villes et les autres
départements et à garantir ainsi
l'égalité de traitement de la
répartition des dotations et des fonds
de péréquation je vous remercie merci le
693 monsieur zulien identique merci
madame la Présidente merci Madame la
Ministre très rapidement parce que mon
collègue sénatoriacovelli a déjà dit
l'essentiel il faut de l'équité dans
dans le calcul aujourd'hui il y a un
déséquilibre entre Paris et les communes
de leurs proches couronnes qui est qui
est dû à la situation ancienne de Paris
qui était à la fois ville et
départements ça n'est plus le cas
aujourd'hui donc ce que nous souhaitons
c'est que il y ait un calcul des
nouvelles bases pour que toutes les
communes soient traitées avec équité et
surtout pour éviter que les villes
périphériques de Paris contribue à
proportion de façon plus importante afin
de compenser la contribution réduite
dont bénéficie encore Paris voilà c'est
l'essentiel de notre amendement merci
Madame Présidente
nous passons
à Madame Lavarde oui merci madame la
Présidente donc effectivement comme l'on
dit mes collègues
cet amendement concerne l'ensemble des
communes d'Île-de-France et pas
uniquement les communes des
Hauts-de-Seine donc ça serait pour dire
que d'autres personnes ici peuvent être
concernées parce que indirectement le
calcul du potentiel financier de la
ville de Paris à des répercussions sur
la répartition du street et comme le dit
très justement la page 6 du document qui
a été présenté au comité des élus du
street en raison de la diminution de son
potentiel financier la contribution de
la ville de Paris est en légère baisse
alors une légère baisse pour Paris se
traduit mécaniquement par une hausse qui
peut être très importante pour les
autres communes contributrice et ça
notamment qui arrive juste derrière la
ville de Paris alors en l'état en fait
ces trois amendements font la même chose
sur la première partie à savoir revenir
reventiler la disparition de la TH au
niveau de la ville de Paris comme cela a
été fait pour les autres communes de
France par contre quand on fait ça il un
effet incident sur le calcul du
potentiel fiscal du département de Paris
qu'il convient de corriger parce que si
on ne le fait pas ça a des conséquences
sur un autre fond de péréquation qui est
le fond départemental alors c'est ce que
fait aussi mon amendement il le fait
d'une manière qu'on peut juger un peu
imparfaite mais j'avoue que pour avoir
cherché pendant plusieurs semaines j'ai
pas trouvé de solution parfaite mais il
me semble important de souligner et là
en tout cas ça peut permettre de
travailler pendant un an cette question
on avançant et pour les communes et pour
les départements merci Madame Lavarde
monsieur le rapporteur monsieur gainé
madame la Présidente dans la ministre
mes chers collègues oui ces trois
amendements une vocation commune
c'est vrai que certains indicateurs
financiers ont avantagé la ville de
Paris comme on l'évoquait tout à l'heure
et l'avantement revient donc à créer une
sorte de coefficient correcteur fictif
bon le sollicitons la vie du
gouvernement pour savoir si il va pas
mieux faire des travaux complémentaires
pour aboutir à un accord
négocié sur ces bases là plutôt que de
faire ça ici mais peut-être avez-vous
renseigner du gouvernement madame la
ministre merci madame la Présidente et
messieurs les sénateurs dans la
prolongement de ce qui vient vous êtes
dit par le rapporteur les modifications
que vous proposez nous semblent pas
aboutir aux résultats souhaités le
potentiel financier de Paris pourrait en
réalité être minorée par rapport à son
niveau actuel ce qui augmente très la
contribution des autres communes au FS
Rif sur ce type de sujet et afin de bien
évaluer l'ensemble des impacts comme
cela vient de vous être dit il nous
semble indispensable de prendre le temps
d'échanger afin d'aboutir à une solution
partagée j'ajoute que la Ville de Paris
pourrait
utilement être associée à ces réflexions
donc je rejoins la demande de retrait
merci
donc demande de retrait de la part de la
Commission comme du gouvernement
oui alors
explication de votre qui commence
monsieur Julia allez
merci
je suis très impressionné par le soutien
politique que vous accordez à mon
collègue yakovéli à quelques mois des
sénatoriales je pense que ça va lui
rendre un grand service je pense qu'il
va être il va être très heureux en
revanche
et oui oui c'est bientôt les
sénatoriales madame la ministre c'est
pour ça d'ailleurs que nous intervenons
un peu vous voyez il y a il y a un petit
rapport non je pense que ce qui est
vraiment essentiel c'est que aujourd'hui
il y a une disparité de fait entre la
contribution parisienne et la
contribution des communes comme le
disait très justement ma collègue
l'avare qui est le résultat de du statut
particulier de Paris aujourd'hui il faut
absolument aplanir tout ça et revenir à
une règle commune c'est à dire que la
contribution parisienne soit calculée
comme toutes les compositions des
communes franchement c'est pas compliqué
et les élus trouveraient que ça serait
une à mesure tout à fait légitime merci
même le Président si Monsieur Julia
alors
d'abord monsieur Ferro qui avait demandé
la parole depuis un moment et Madame
Lavarde
la présidente cette ces deux ou trois
amendements sont pas sans rapport avec
l'amendement que j'ai présenté tout à
l'heure et qui a été rejeté puisque si
on modifie les critères dans l'article
l234 du Code général ça ne peut pas être
à la tête du client donc ça doit être
quand cela est avantageux Paris comme
quand cela le désavantage alors ça peut
paraître peut-être un peu baroque que le
débat se débat qu'il a est entre les
Hauts-de-Seine et Paris qui n'ont pas la
réputation d'être dans les départements
les plus pauvres de France je tiens
quand même à rappeler une chose c'est
que Paris et c'est 2 millions 100.000
habitants si je vous dérange pas
perçoit 40000 euros de DGF en tout et
pour tout et verse plus de 700 millions
d'euros de péréquation nationale et
régionales donc il faut rétablir aussi
la réalité des chiffres par rapport au
potentiel fiscal et financier mais aussi
par rapport à la solidarité et au fait
que Paris participe à la solidarité
nationale entre les collectivités
alors moi c'est juste pour préciser que
ces questions sur les le modalité de
répartition du street c'est pas la
première fois que j'en parle dans cette
hémicycle je pense que j'en parle à
chaque PLF l'année dernière j'avais déjà
eu des discussions avec le la DGCL parce
que j'avais porté antérieurement un
calcul un amendement qui visait le
double compte de la CPS dans le calcul
du street la DGCL enfin les services
avaient reconnu que j'avais raison mais
qu'il était il fallait pas remettre ce
sujet sur la table puisqu'on doit avoir
une réforme bon la réforme ne venant pas
là on vient sur des montants qui sont
substantiellement plus élevés que ce
double compte de la CPS qui est qui
concernait certaines communes celle qui
avait une ancienne taxe professionnelle
très élevée là je vous parle de
l'ensemble des communes contributrices
au Street ce n'est pas que dans les
Hauts-de-Seine il y en a dans le 91 il y
en a dans le 94 il y en a dans chacune
des départements d'Île-de-France donc
déjà pour l'année dernière je me
souviens que quand nous avions parlé des
indicateurs et que vous étiez venu
ajouter certains critères comme les
droits de mutation pour venir rehausser
le potentiel financier de la ville de
Paris qui se trouve et sinon en
appliquant le droit antérieur on m'avait
répondu que ça n'aurait une incidence
que sur la ville de Paris au regard du
poids de la ville de Paris dans le poids
des DMTO nationaux c'était certainement
vrai si on raisonnait en oubliant que
dans ville de Paris il y a ville les
départements sur les dmteo donc si on
reprendra-t-il la part que de la ville
de Paris et qu'on la compare à la part
des DMTO des autres villes la
comparaison n'est peut-être plus tout à
fait vrai et c'est peut-être ça qui
explique que quand on a calculé le strif
en 2022 devant le comité des élus on a
cette phrase le potentiel de la ville de
Paris financier de la ville de Paris et
en diminué les autres communes sont
appelées à contribuer et ce que je
voudrais dire ici c'est qu'on a quand
même un vrai problème démocratique dans
la répartition de ce fond le comité des
élus du street ou un tableau qui ne dit
rien du calcul du calcul de l'indicateur
synthétique alors je vais pas le répéter
ici la formule compliquée mais donc on
ne sait pas comment les variations se
font d'une année sur l'autre entre les
différentes communes contributrices et
c'est la même chose pour celles qui
perçoivent donc si cette boîte on peut
pas l'ouvrir devant le Parlement qu'elle
est pas plus ouvert devant le comité des
élus qu'est-ce qu'on fait et vous allez
nous dire on va se revoir dans un an
sauf que dans un an les communes
contributrices elles auront continué à
payer en 2022 et en 2022 merci
alors je vais mettre
monsieur
[Musique]
ah pardon excusez-moi chers collègues
je voudrais surtout pas rallonger
excessivement les débats mais
il faut quand même puisqu'on a on a des
éléments très très précis et on est
désolé de monopoliser un petit peu le
débat concernant les communes
d'Île-de-France néanmoins pour que les
collègues étaient un petit peu ça en
tête l'ensemble du fond dont nous
parlons aujourd'hui c'est 350 millions
la ville de Paris contribue à hauteur de
183 donc non mais je voudrais juste que
vous n'ayez pas l'esprit l'idée que
voilà que Paris c'est terrible c'est
vrai que ce ne sont que des sénateurs
des Hauts-de-Seine qui se sont exprimés
donc du coup on a un effet loop sur la
situation des Hauts-de-Seine donc je
pense que dans un mécanisme qui était
extraordinairement complexe d'ailleurs
on vous écoutant chers Christine lavard
tu penses que vous nous aviez perdu à la
8e phrase je pense qu'il faut y
travailler de manière très sérieuse mais
qu'on ne peut pas me semble-t-il
remettre à plat l'ensemble du dispositif
du sriff et les modalités de répartition
entre telle ou telle commune comme ça
mais voilà je tenais quand même à ce que
vous sachiez quel est le montant des
contributions de la ville de Paris par
rapport à l'ensemble du fond
alors merci madame de La Gontrie
maintenant
monsieur je suis désolé je suis désolé
de répondre à mes collègues sénateurs
parisiens mais en fait on ne peut pas
demander du temps quand ça nous arrange
et faire voter quand ça nous arrange
rapidement et donc en l'occurrence moi
je pense que aujourd'hui on est dans une
situation Christine lavard de la très
bien argumenté ça ne concerne pas
d'ailleurs que les Hauts-de-Seine et
d'ailleurs je rappelle que dans les
Hauts-de-Seine il n'y a pas que des
communes riches il y a aussi des
situations difficiles dans un certain
nombre de nos communes et ça concerne
toute l'Île-de-France les 8 départements
d'Île-de-France et donc on a besoin
effectivement aujourd'hui d'avoir une
équité entre les différentes communes
qui composent l'Île-de-France et c'est
pour ça que je pense que en tout cas
pour ma part je maintiendrai
l'amendement
merci Monsieur yakovelli alors je vais
mettre aux voix les amendements
identiques 515
et 693 qui ont reçu un avis un avis
défavorable de la commission et du
gouvernement qui est pour
qui est contre
bient ne sont pas adoptés je me vois le
37 rectifier bis qui a reçu deux avis
des favorables qui est pour
qui contre
il est adopté
alors
je vous propose de faire une suspension
de séance de 5 minutes à la demande du
gouvernement
allez la séance est reprise
le 696
monsieur Julia merci madame la
présidente madame lamis mes chers
collègues c'est toujours le fond de
solidarité des communes de la région
Île-de-France mais vous allez voir c'est
beaucoup plus simple les communes qui
sont contributrices elles elles ont un
prélèvement qui est mensuel donc l'état
prélève tous les mois mais en revanche
les communes bénéficiaires elles elles
ont un versement par moitié le 31
juillet et le 31 décembre donc elles
font l'avance de trésorerie pour le
compte de l'État ce qu'on souhaite par
cet amendement c'est que bien évidemment
prélèvement et versement se fasse
mensuellement ce qui serait une réforme
très simple merci Madame présente j'ai
fait cours c'est très gentil merci
monsieur le rapporteur
avis du gouvernement favorable
favorable donc favorable pour la
commission je mets au voile amendement
696 qui a reçu deux avis favorables qui
est pour
qui contre qui s'abstient il est adopté
le 126
monsieur panousee merci madame la
Présidente
la dotation de continuité territoriale
est un concours individualisé de l'État
versé à la collectivité de Corse pour
lui permettre de mettre en oeuvre le
principe de continuité territoriale
telle que définie en 1976 en organisant
et finançant les desserts maritimes
aériennes liant la Corse continent
les modalités de versement de ladite
dotation sont précisées à l'article
l4425-26 du Code Général des
Collectivités Territoriales
depuis le statut jokes de 1991 les
reliquats de l'enveloppe de la
continuité territoriale peuvent être
affectés aux infrastructures portuaires
et europactuaires
l'article 142 de la loi
2016-1917 du 29 décembre 2016 de
finances pour 2017 a étendu cette
possibilité aux infrastructures
routières et ferroviaires jusque là je
dirais que tout cela reste cohérent or
la dernière évolution intervenue en 2017
constituant en revanche une dérive qui
met à la fois en péril le bien fondé de
cette dotation ainsi que le financement
des infrastructures de transport
fruit d'un accord politique entre le
ministre de l'époque et la nouvelle
majorité territoriale la des
spécialisation totale de l'enveloppe
fait courir un risque au versement de la
dotation
par conséquent à travers cette
amendement il est impératif de préserver
l'affectation de la dotation de
continuité territoriale aux
infrastructures de transport et de
lactée dans la loi l'objet du
présentement et de respecter l'enveloppe
et la parviendra à la collectivité de
financiers directement les autres
programmes sans avoir à opérer des
financements prévus pour les transports
ce serait une opération neutre pour la
collectivité de Corse qui fléchirait les
reliquats sur les investissements
concernant les infrastructures de
transport et préserverait le bien fondé
du versement de la dotation de
continuité territoriale d'où la nouvelle
rédaction proposée afin d'encadrer
l'utilisation de ces reliquats pour les
réserver aux infrastructures de
transport chers collègues
avis de la commission oui madame
présidente merci madame le ministre mes
chers collègues monsieur Panouse
de revenir sur la modification
introduite en 2017
et de respecter le reliquat de la DCT
ça aurait l'avantage de d'être beaucoup
plus en cohérence avec l'objectif
initial et en plus ça émane légitimement
du terrain nous ne pouvons que à tout le
moins vous donner une sagesse mais on va
voir ce que nous dit le gouvernement
la présidente donc concernant
l'amendement 126 la dotation de
continuité territoriale la DCT s'établit
à 187 millions d'euros par an c'est une
recette affectée qui vise à compenser
les contraintes liées à la continuité
territoriale le montant du droit
compensation était calculé selon les
modalités classiques en matière de
transfert de compétences c'est-à-dire au
coût historique de sorte que les crédits
transférés par l'État correspondait au
crédit inscrit en 1992 au budget du
ministère en charge des transports les
dépenses de continuité territoriales se
sont fortement réduites entre 2013 et
2019 passant de 189,5 millions d'euros à
161,2 millions d'euros c'est d'ailleurs
pourquoi la loi de finance initiale pour
2017 a ouvert la possibilité d'affecter
les reliquats de la DCT à des opérations
hors continuité territoriales et
notamment la réalisation d'opérations
d'investissement s'inscrivant dans le
cadre d'un projet global de
développement du territoire de la Corse
notamment au titre des politiques
publiques menées en faveur des
territoires de l'Intérieur et de la
montagne la mesure que vous proposez
monsieur le sénateur est en susceptible
de rigidifier les marges de manœuvre
financières de la collectivité de Corse
dans un contexte socio-économique
fragile le gouvernement n'est pas
favorable à cet amendement et vous en
demande si vous le voulez bien le
retrait
monsieur panouzi pour explication de
vote madame la ministre je pense que on
vous a mal informé
et que vous n'avez pas
analysé le principe il y a une dotation
de continuité territoriale qui est
versée à la collectivité de Corse pour
le transport maritime et aérien de 187
millions d'euros par an
cette dotation n'est pas consommée en
totalité tous les ans
et la loi de 91 qui avait compris le
principe
faisait en sorte que les reliquats
puissent être consommés
par des crédits alloués aux routes au
port et aux aéroports aujourd'hui avec
la des spécialisation de l'enveloppe
vous avez 50 millions d'euros depuis
2017 jusqu'à 2021 qui se sont évaporés
dans le budget de fonctionnement de la
collectivité territoriale et qui ne sont
pas utilisés sur les infrastructures
portuaires aéroportuaire et routière
donc je demande en toute logique que ces
crédits soient consacrés aux
infrastructures de transport comme le
souhaite la loi
si monsieur panoushi
alors je vais mettre au bois cet
amendement 126 qui a reçu un avis de
sagesse de la Commission et défavorable
du gouvernement qui est pour
qui est contre
qui s'abstient il est adopté
de 568 il est présenté par Monsieur
Delcros
merci madame la Présidente
cet amendement concerne les dotations de
péréquation DSR et DSU je suis sûr que
l'immense majorité des élus locaux pense
que la DSU comme son nom l'indique est
réservé aux communes urbaines et que la
DSR dotation sur la terre rurale et
réservée aux communes rurales c'est vrai
pour l'immense majorité des
collectivités mais il s'avère qu'il y a
quelques anomalies il y a quelques
communes qui cumulent l'ADSR et la
déesse qui paraît quand même assez
curieux donc mon amendement propose de
ne pas permettre ce cumul tout en
permettant à chaque collectivité qui
cumule de garder la dotation la plus
importante
oui merci monsieur delcro vous savez
chers collègues que je suis par nature
circonspect envers tous les noms
cumulent mais bon on peut quand même
imaginer que dans certains territoires
peut-être ça puisse s'entrecroiser et
qui puisse y avoir les deux
c'est pour ça
nous considérons que le sujet devrait
être un peu plus expertisé parce que ça
n'est pas forcément impossible et en
toute état de cause je vous dis d'y
penser quand même pour les communes
nouvelles au cas où l'amendement serait
accepté parce que dans ce cas il
faudrait vérifier veiller à les mettre
en exception lorsqu'elles ont à la fois
de la DSU
d'accord mais donc plutôt une demande de
retrait
merci madame la ministre
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Sénateur delcro alors il semble que vous
venez de voter il y a pas très très
longtemps le cumul de la DSR et de la
DSU sur les communes nouvelles là il y a
quelques minutes donc c'est un peu
surprenant mais pas de problème donc là
vous nous proposez
d'interdire le cumul de la DSR et de la
DSU et la position du Gouvernement est
défavorable je
pense que c'est un peu long cet
amendement d'après nous et avec les
travaux qui ont été faits par les
services conduirait à de lourdes pertes
pour des communes déjà fragiles je vous
remercie merci
monsieur corbiset vous avez la parole et
puis monsieur Delcros
la Présidente je rappelle que l'addition
des deux existe parce que je prends
l'exemple de ma commune qui était une
ville minière et comme vous le savez la
plupart des communes minières nordent
Pas de Calais ou ailleurs depuis 10.000
habitants faisaient partie des communes
les plus pauvres de France et donc on
avait des sommes au niveau de la déçu ma
commune touchait un million 8 2 millions
d'euros par an au titre de la DSU mais à
partir du moment où je suis passé juste
sous la barre des démêler habitants j'ai
commencé à toucher de la DETR j'ai
interroge le préfet me dit est-ce que
c'est possible oui parce que sous la
barre des villes de moins de 10000
habitants les 30 communes les plus
pauvres sous la barre des 1000 habitants
donc les 30 communes seulement pouvaient
toucher en plus de la DETR donc cela
existe dans les textes
petit monsieur corbizet monsieur delcro
oui je vais retirer mon amendement mais
je voulais quand même attirer
l'attention là-dessus je pense que les
mécanismes devraient être regardés de
près sans enlever de dotation aux
collectivités pour qu'on puisse avoir
finalement deux ensembles 10 juin d'un
côté la DSU d'un côté la DSR sans rien
retirer à ceux qui perçoivent l'idée
c'est pas que les communes perçoivent
moins mais qu'on est quelque chose qui
soit cohérent avec ces dotations donc
l'A
[Musique]
endement 189 Monsieur Hervé
au nom de la commission des lois c'est
un amendement qui sont à supprimer
l'article 45 bis cet article prévoit
l'ajout d'un nouveau critère dans la
détermination par les préfets
départements et de région du taux de
subventionnement des attributions de
DETR et de déciles
en premier lieu l'ajout d'un nouveau
critère fondé sur le caractère
écologique des projets proposés pourrait
être entré en contradiction avec les
critères déjà défini dans la loi pour
l'attribution de ces projets il convient
de ne pas altérer la procédure
d'attribution dans les élus trouve
souvent en particulier par la des cils
qu'il n'est qu'elle n'est pas d'une
parfaite lisibilité
et par ailleurs le critère proposé
particulièrement vague et pourrait
s'avérer inopérant en effet
l'appréciation par le préfet du
caractère écologique du projet pourrait
s'aderter s'avérer malaiser s'agit-il
par là d'évaluer les conditions de
réalisation du projet ou alors son but
final faute de clarification nécessaire
le présente amendement prévoit de
supprimer cet archétypique c'est pas
parce qu'on prend une préfecture en
verre qu'on fait de l'écologie
si chers collègues le 409 Monsieur
Bonhomme
oui madame la Présidente merci
effectivement l'Artic 45 bis introduit
dans les articles L200 23 34 36 et 23 34
42 du code un paramètre écologique qui
pour le moins surprenant pour la
fixation des taux de subvention de DotA
pour les préfets départements de région
or la terminologie caractère écologique
retenue n'est pas satisfaisante à mon
sens le mot écologie a plutôt une
connotation politique
aux scientifiques que juridique
véritablement par conséquent la
définition du caractère écologique
apparaît beaucoup trop imprécise on peut
se demander sur quels critères objectifs
en effet le préfet va-t-il se déterminer
pour qu'un projet soit effectivement
écologique et en plus de cela s'ajoute
des interprétations différentes de
départements à département qui peuvent
avoir lieu par conséquent cet article
vient complexifier inutilement une
procédure attribution qui n'est pas
toujours facile pour les élus locaux de
maîtriser parfaitement et comme l'a dit
mon collègue il ne suffit pas d'ajouter
des épithètes ou de les collectionner
pour être vertueux en matière
d'environnement
madame la Présidente
je voudrais citer quelques opérations
qui sont aujourd'hui dans mon
département financé par l'adetr par
exemple l'opération de câblage d'une
école pour équiper les écoles en tableau
numérique par exemple renforcement de
voirie pour pour que les cars de
ramassage scolaire puisse passer dans
certaines communes ou par exemple encore
la construction d'une maison
d'assistante maternelle comment faire
rentrer ses projets dont je n'ai pas
besoin de développer sur le caractère
essentiel dans le critère nouvellement
institué de caractères écologique par
ailleurs dans les départements nous
sommes en toute intelligence en
situation nous mettent d'accord y
compris avec les services de l'État et
les préfets sur un certain nombre de
problématiques à résoudre je dans mon
département de la Seine-Maritime il y a
eu un gros sujet par exemple autour de
la défense incendie et de manière
intelligente nous avons décidé ensemble
que la dotrs DETR puisse financer un
certain nombre de travaux pour défendre
nos communes contre l'incendie donc je
crois que ce critère est effectivement
tout à fait mal venu et comme l'on dit
nos collègues je crois que l'écologie
mérite mieux que de devenir un critère
qui vise à sélectionner et clairement à
écarter un certain nombre de projets de
nos communes
merci Madame Brulin avis de la
commission sur ces trois amendements
oui mes chers collègues d'abord il faut
regarder les choses comme elles sont
cette cet article 45 bis a été introduit
à la demande des rapporteurs spéciaux à
l'Assemblée nationale ce n'est pas une
proposition du gouvernement
et donc
c'est comme on est on n'est pas on n'est
jamais contre le fait de supprimer un
amendement venant de l'Assemblée
nationale je plaisante je plaisante
parce qu'il y en a qui vont le croire
bon donc
mon premier point deuxième point la
formule c'est les préfets tiennent
compte du caractère écologique des
projets comment dire
c'est pas très normatif c'est le moins
qu'on puisse dire c'est bon c'est
moyennement ambitieux du point de vue
global c'est-à-dire de l'idée que toute
façon sur les projets aujourd'hui
la question
des consommations la question
énergétique la question
environnementale elle est quelque part
prise en compte déjà beaucoup au niveau
des commissions ça existe nous on avait
noté simplement que une telle
disposition relevée davantage de la
circulaire éventuellement c'est à dire
une orientation du gouvernement vers les
préfets orientations je dis bien que en
tout cas d'un texte de loi et donc
écoutez puisque vous vous demandez si
gentiment on va proposer de le retirer
on va être favorable à ces quatre
abonnements
merci monsieur le rapporteur madame la
ministre donc c'est quoi la vie
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs le gouvernement
va être défavorable sur les trois amants
de mon
faut proposer de supprimer l'article 45
bis qui prévoit la joue d'un nouveau
critère dans la détermination par les
préfets de départements et de région du
taux de subventionnement des
attributions de DETR et de décès c'est
cet amendement s'inscrit dans le
mouvement de verdissement des concours
financiers de l'État au concours aux
collectivités locales traduisant ainsi
l'engagement du gouvernement en faveur
de la transition écologique ne vous
moquez pas s'il vous plaît il n'est pas
question de peindre quelconque mairie en
verre mais bien de verdir ni la
préfecture mais bien de faire dire nos
projets tout en maintenant les critères
d'attribution de ces dotations et dans
le respect des dispositions législatives
et réglementaires auxquelles ils sont
soumises ils permettent d'inciter
d'encourager les projets vertueux pour
l'environnement à travers une majoration
du taux de subventions appréciée par les
préfets pour la DETR c'est appréciation
s'effectuera en outre dans le respect
des catégories d'opérations prioritaires
et des taux minimaux et Maximo de
subventions fixées par la Commission des
élus cette démarche existe
par ailleurs déjà dans certains
territoires merci madame la Présidente
telle que l'Ariège qui a instauré un
bonus transition écologique pour la DETR
ou encore la Drôme ou encore la Drôme
qui attribue des bonifications dans le
cadre de la DETR et de la décile pour
des projets vertueux l'enjeu se situe
plutôt dans l'amélioration d'analyse des
projets permettant d'identifier ceux qui
contribuent réellement à la transition
écologique l'instruction ministérielle
pour les programmations 2023 portera à
la connaissance des préfets une grille
d'analyse des projets en ce sens
celles-ci permettra je pense au
préfecture de mieux analyser valoriser
les projets présentés par les
collectivités et contribuant
positivement à la transition écologique
allez merci même la ministre s'il vous
plaît
merci madame la ministre
alors nous allons passer aux
explications de vote alors on nous
commençons par Madame Goulet
à la présidente
vous qui est tellement attaché à la
constitutionnalité
du droit de ce que nous votons ici je
pense que le caractère écologique est
quand même une notion tout à fait vague
tout à fait imprécise et tout à fait
indigne à mettre dans les dans les oui
absolument je pense que je pense que
aujourd'hui il y a des critères ce
critère là est absolument imprécie il
rajoute à la confusion dont on a parlé
ce matin je pense que la commission des
lois est son rapporteur ont très bien
fait de déposer cet amendement de
suppression que je voterai
merci Madame boulet madame Gatel
madame la présidente madame la ministre
il n'y a plus de projets qui ne soit pas
pur d'une manière écologique aujourd'hui
il y a plus la mer qui le fait parce
qu'il y a tellement de normes qui oblige
à des équipements vertueux et c'est très
bien et madame la ministre vous avez
cité des exemples qui naissent du
terrain dans certains départements les
élus aigles préfet ont décidé
d'organiser les choses comme ça c'est
l'esprit même de la terre pourquoi
est-ce qu'on revient tout le temps à
dire du coup on va mettre dans la loi
cette bonne pratique madame la ministre
encore une fois il faut qu'on aille tous
faire un tour en Mayenne avec le
président de la République il dit
liberté responsabilité locale mais les
élus sont vertueux madame la ministre
arrêtons de leur interdire des choses ou
de leur imposer des choses qu'ils font
naturellement comme Monsieur Jourdain
faisait de la
on est la parole merci monsieur sotarel
oui merci madame la Présidente moi je
soutiendrai bien évidemment ces
amendements avec la vie favorable de la
commission parce que comme l'ont appelé
plusieurs collègues la liberté locale et
est importante d'autre part chaque
territoire à ces particularités et une
commission d'élus qui peut fixer un
cadre particulier et je crains qu'avec
ce critère de caractère écologique une
fois de plus ce soit les routes alors
que comme on l'a rappelé par ailleurs
c'est un instrument pour toutes les
mobilités qui soient victimes demain
dans les arbitrages desert de de cette
de ce critère alors même qu'on n'a pas
pour l'instant construit un fond dédié
aux financement de notre voirie
communale donc bien évidemment je
souscris à ces amendements qui me
semblent sage et de liberté locale merci
Monsieur Hervé
oui merci madame la Présidente sous le
couvert du président de la commission
des lois si la commission des finances
est jalouse de la préservation de
l'orthodoxie financière nous nous sommes
jaloux de de l'orthodoxe de la rédaction
de la loi et de la qualité du droit nous
n'aimons pas les adverbes et le verbe
imprécis donc quand les préfets veille
autant dire que ou qu'on est sur des
mots aussi vague en fait on fait pas de
la loi on est en train d'invoquer des
des choses et on n'est pas loin du
greenwashing pardon de le dire mais on
met dans le droit des un alourdissement
et des choses qui ne font rien avancer
et l'autre élément qui me semble être
l'autre argument qui me semble être le
plus important c'est la confiance faite
aux élus locaux et je vais prendre un
exemple tout simple dans mon département
de la Haute-Savoie en Haute-Savoie les
élus locaux ont décidé dans les critères
de la dotr de donner une bonification
pour l'emploi de bois local
10 points de det en plus et ben ça
marche donc allons dans le concret
restons juridiquement précis et
abrogeons cet article qui n'a aucun sens
monsieur benaroche puis Monsieur
Bonhomme
je trouve dommage pendant quoi
gouvernement dont on a vu depuis
longtemps qu'il est profondément
écologiste
c'est pas de l'ordre de la loi enfin
quand même bon on pourrait accepter en
fait c'est du ripolinage vert en fait
quand vous parlez le verdure oui c'est
du riz polinage vert c'est à dire c'est
du verdissement mais du verdissement au
niveau effectivement d'un coup de
cosmétique ou de peinture alors moi ce
que je propose effectivement c'est qu'on
fasse un amendement ou un article madame
la ministre ou il doit avec des vrais
critères avec des vrais critères
écologistes avec des vrais critères qui
permettent d'avancer un vrai article de
loi qui tient de la route et qui puisse
être appliquée
si Monsieur
Bonhomme puis monsieur canner
effectivement je suis bien croire qu'on
doit faire preuve d'inventivité c'est
pas pour autant qu'on doit se rallier à
un amendement une modification de la
nationale qui me paraît complètement
baroque et
naturellement ça affaiblise qu'on croit
vouloir soutenir les exemples qui ont
donné notre collègue d'ailleurs disque
de projet de rentrée pas stricto sensu
dans des questions dites écologiques
encore que il faudrait préciser et c'est
la toute la difficulté ce qu'on entend
par écologique et puis je crois surtout
que ça vient masquer un peu l'essentiel
l'essentiel c'est que ça traduit que
chez le symptomatique c'est que le
gouvernement fait surcroît de
d'inventivité lexicales et de collection
de de d'adjectifs et d'épites pour
compenser une difficulté qui rencontre
comme les autres c'est à dire à verdir
nos programmes de politiques publiques
mais en dernier lieu si on avait un
doute effectivement les sols la
souveraineté à la commission pour avis
de traiter les questions qui doit être
sélectionnées dans les opérations
oui monsieur canner monsieur le
Président oui madame la présidente
madame la ministre le nombre important
d'interventions sur ce sujet
montre que il n'est pas du tout
anecdotique
il y a 41 ans les lois Mauroy de fer
abolissaient le contrôle d'opportunité
sur les décisions des élus locaux
contrôle l'opportunité exercée par les
préfets des préfets désignés vis-à-vis
de de mer de président de départements
de président de conseil régionaux élus
très concrètement par
cette proposition
issue aujourd'hui est validé par par
vous-même vous recréez de fait ce
contrôle d'opportunités sur aucune base
sérieuse et je pense que l'abrogation
que nous portons que nous allons porter
montre que sur l'ensemble de ces bancs
ici présent de droite à gauche nous
voulons préserver l'autonomie des
collectivités locales face à un pouvoir
central qui devient de plus en plus
comment je vais vous dire ça
craignant pour acheter
poli donc madame la ministre nous allons
vous mettre en minorité ce sera pas la
première fois ce soir mais simplement
que ce message puisse remonter là où il
doit remonter à savoir auprès du
président de la République qui derrière
ces engagements réguliers et
systématiques semblent quand même
oublier que les élus aujourd'hui sont le
tissu social le tissu de l'aménagement
du territoire dans notre pays merci
Monsieur canard la parole est à Monsieur
Lamini
oui merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre mes chers collègues très
rapidement simplement je partagerai ces
amendements à l'initiative de nos
brillants collègues de la commission des
lois partagées avec le président de la
commission des finances c'est ses
collègues parce que je dirais la DETR a
été instituée de mémoire en 2011 la
décile en 2016 et je rappellerai aussi
que dans les commissions des terres il y
a deux sénateurs de députés puis aussi
en représentant de des représentants des
associations de mer des EPCI notamment
puis de l'autre côté je rappellerai en
2017 pour celles et ceux qui étaient là
à l'été 2017 le combat notamment de
notre collègue qui était Président
buffet maintenant qui est président de
la commission des lois à l'époque
c'était le président Philippe Bas qui
s'est battu pour défendre la réserve
parlementaire la dotation d'action
parlementaire et ça fait aussi partie
aussi du lien qu'il y avait et puis de
la proximité et là et le soutien aussi à
l'ensemble de nos collectivités locales
voilà mais je soutiendrai ces
amendements
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre je suis vraiment la pression
que vous vous tirez une balle dans les
pieds pour une raison très simple c'est
comment vous allez pouvoir comment le
préfet va pouvoir définir la qualité
écologique dès que vous allez faire une
route et vous allez donner une
subvention vous allez trouver toujours
un particulier une association qui va
faire un recours ça va être exactement
la même chose avec les mers et donc je
ne vois pas comment vous pouvez défendre
cet amendement d'autant plus que au
départ ça faisait pas partie de vos
projets comme ça a été dit excellente
tout à l'heure c'est pas en mettant
écologique à tous les bouts de phrases
que vous faites pour autant une
politique écologique donc je crois
vraiment que dans cette affaire vous
êtes en train d'entraver la capacité
d'action non seulement des maires mais
aussi
d'entraver la capacité d'action du
préfet qui va se retrouver avec une
série de recours pour rien du tout
est-ce que je voulais des demandes
d'explication de vote c'est bon encore
il y en a eu c'est bon
encore des choses à dire
nos territoires
ou la créativité des élus dans le cas
d'un dialogue avec la préfecture peut
cerner comme l'exprimer par exemple des
sujets d'intérêt particulier sur un
territoire c'est le seul aujourd'hui on
est complètement phagocyté dans des
appels à projets des guichets la DETR et
l'ultime endroit où on peut présenter et
il peut y avoir un dialogue local et une
souplesse l'aide l'accompagnement de
l'État s'adapte aussi pour une fois à la
réalité des territoires donc vraiment
garder nous cette soupape de réponse à
l'intelligence de nos territoires et des
élus locaux
donc on va se voir alors madame la
ministre vous avez demandé la parole
pour répondre
madame la Présidente juste vous dire
quelques mots d'abord que je suis très
respectueuse de tout ce que vous
exprimez et je comprends que vous
demandez la suppression de la joue de ce
critère écologique mais je veux juste
vous dire que ce critère
n'y serait pas que vous nous accuseriez
de manque de cohérence moi j'appartiens
aujourd'hui
j'appartiens est-ce que vous me
permettez d'aller au bout j'en ai pour
moins d'une minute donc soyez
respectueux autant que je le suis de
votre pensée
vis-à-vis de ce que je vais vous dire
j'appartiens
ministère de la transition écologique et
de la cohésion des territoires ça fait
juste quatre mois et demi cinq mois que
je suis au gouvernement j'ai chevillé au
corps l'envie d'ancrer dans les
territoires la transition écologique on
a du mal c'est difficile on travaille
ensemble avec Christophe Vichy sur le
zan on travaille sur plein de sujets sur
cette loi climat est résiliente
aujourd'hui
juste vous ne dit pas plus et donc on a
mis un critère écologique oui dans la
dotr moi j'entends tout ce que vous
dites ce que je dis ne s'oppose pas ce
que vous dites je vous dis simplement
que oui le gouvernement affiche une
volonté par la même de voir colorer
l'ensemble des investissements qui sont
faits sur fond d'État dans les
territoires et c'est juste je vous
demande d'entendre et de respecter une
opinion qui n'est pas la vôtre moi je
suis très respectueuse de la vôtre
merci Madame la ministreham alors je
vais mettre aux voix donc ces trois
amendements
identiques de suppression
avis favorable de la commission avis
défavorable du gouvernement qui est pour
qui est contre qui s'abstient sont donc
adoptés donc la demande suivant tombe
l'article est supprimé alors je vous
signale que nous arrêterons vers 20h
20h05
alors nous deux amendements
identiques alors le 75 madame Noël merci
madame la présidente madame la ministre
nous avons tous remarqué une inflexion
ces dernières années
de dispositifs contractuels et
partenariaux par l'État type contrat
ruralité ou CRTA qui est qui sont la
traduction de la volonté de
l'administration d'établir une doctrine
contraignant les collectivités
territoriales à s'inscrire dans de
telles dispositifs pour solliciter
certaines dotations d'investissement à
la sarde de la décile certaines communes
et particulièrement en milieu rurales se
retrouvent parfois exclues du bénéfice
de certaines ressources et ainsi
contraintes de reporter voire d'annuler
leurs projets d'investissement le
présent amendement a donc vocation à
mettre fin à cette doctrine purement
administrative en fixant un principe
législatif selon lequel la collectivité
territoriale ne peut se voir exclue du
bénéfice d'une dotation d'investissement
au seul motif qu'elle ne s'inscrirait
pas dans une démarche contractuelle ou
partenariale
commencer par l'État merci le 635
la présidente madame la ministre mes
chers collègues c'est un amendement
identique c'est à dire que des
modifications législatives et pratiques
et de pratique dans l'état local
fragilisent les communes la mise en
place des dispositifs contractuels
partenariaux par l'État type contrat de
ruralité c'est heu sont la traduction de
la volonté de l'administration d'établir
une doctrine contraignant les
collectivités territoriales à s'inscrire
dans de telles dispositifs pour
solliciter certaines dotations
d'investissement à l'instar de la décile
certaines communes et particulièrement
dans mon département qui est rural se
retrouve parfois exclus du bénéfice de
certaines ressources et ainsi
contraintes à reporter voire annuler
leurs projets cet amendement instaure
donc un principe législatif selon lequel
une collectivité territoriale ne peut se
voir exclue d'une dotation
d'investissement
merci la vie de la Commission sur ces
deux amendements
que nous avons produit avec Charles
Gonnet puisque c'était une de nos
propositions qui est reprise là donc
évidemment un avis extrêmement favorable
merci la vie du gouvernement madame la
ministre
madame la Présidente
s'il vous plaît merci alors je mets aux
voix ces deux amendements identiques à
vie favorables de la commission
défavorable du gouvernement qui est pour
qui est contre qui s'abstient ils sont
donc adoptés
l'amendement 158 monsieur sotarel ou
monsieur angla monsieur Sautarel
porté par notre collègue Jean-Baptiste
blanc et 62 de nos collègues n'est-ce
pas qui concernent la DETR et donc c'est
amendement vise la garantir que les
crédits de la detrent du bas cette
après-midi sont bien destinés à
l'équipement des territoires ruraux
voilà donc puisqu'on sort de la Cour des
comptes à l'Assemblée nationale
en passant par les associations d'élus
le Sénat a comme en témoigne la
discussion du récent rapport
d'information
l'excellent rapport d'information de
Charles Guénet et Claude Raynal sur le
rôle de la dotation d'investissement
pour les collectivités territoriales le
constat est régulièrement adressé de
dérapage de crédits de la DETR qui
bénéficient qui pourrait bénéficier à
des grandes aires urbaines donc il
s'agit ils ont proposé que les aides et
tribuées dans le cadre de la DETR soit
ciblées sur des projets réalisés dans
des communes ou zone rurales au sens
l'Insee puisque l'initial des critères
pour pour savoir ce la ruralité où tout
le moins sur des projets contribuant
significativement au développement rural
merci la vie de la commission sur le
rapporteur
[Musique]
voilà c'est un excellent exemple les
communes ne sont pas absolument pas de
la même taille et en fait ça viendrait
rigidifier un peu le système et
ce serait dommage pour ça on préférerait
en retrait de ce
cet abonnement madame la ministre
position du Gouvernement est défavorable
madame la Présidente merci
ce que vous retirez l'amendement
monsieur Anglin
à suivre les recommandations de du
rapporteur retirer l'amendement
merci
alors trois amendements en discussion
commune le 76 madame Noël merci madame
la Présidente
forcée de constater que de nombreuses
communes rurales sont privées du
bénéfice de laetitr au profit des villes
avec la liste de bénéficiaires fixés par
la loi outrepassant nettement le seul
champ des communes caractérisées comme
telles selon une étude réalisée par
l'association numéro de France pour les
régions provençales-côte d'Azur et
Auvergne Rhône-Alpes se sont ainsi
respectivement 6,2 millions d'euros et
15 millions d'euros de DETR qui en 2022
ont été reversés à des entités autre que
des communes rurales le présente
amendement modifie la liste législative
des bénéficiaires de cette dotation en
prévoyant que seuls ils seront éligibles
les communes caractérisées comme peu
dense ou très peu dense au sens de la
grille communale de densité de l'Insee
merci
les amendements identiques le 210
monsieur Delcros
oui merci madame la Présidente la DETR
comme son nom l'indique et ça a été
rappelé est une dotation d'équipements
des territoires ruraux sauf que fil du
temps on a laissé faire il y a eu des
dérives à tel point et j'ai envie de
dire cette bouquet quand je dis vous
avez des communes urbaines marrant d'une
métropole qui bénéficie de la dotation
d'équipements des territoires ruraux
donc je propose simplement que les
communes urbaines membres d'une
métropole ne soit plus lisible à la
tension des équipements des territoires
ruraux merci le 636 monsieur Marie
défendu non pas totalement c'est le même
effectivement que mon collègue delcro
simplement une précision complémentaire
l'amendement présenté par notre collègue
madame Noël
concentre la DETR sur l'hyper rural au
risque malheureusement de sortir
certaines communes rurales de la DETR
alors que celui présenté par Monsieur
delcro et moi même avec mon groupe
permet de sortir des communes urbaines
membre des métropole qui en bénéficient
alors qu'elle ne devrait pas en
bénéficier
merci alors la vie de la commission sur
le rapporteur
oui merci madame la Présidente oui pour
l'amendement
76 de Madame Noël je reprendrai la même
argumentation que celle que j'évoquais
tout à l'heure puisque ça reprend là la
notion de zone de danse et dense et
qu'il est assez proche donc je
solliciterais un retrait de la même
manière
pour les amendements de Monsieur delcrot
et de Monsieur Marie c'est vrai que vous
utilisez effectivement cet argument
aussi mais avec la volonté de rendre
inéligible les communes membres de
métropole lorsqu'il remplissent ce type
de conditions
je trouve que ce caractère est peut-être
un peu discriminant et mériterait
d'avoir une étude plus plus appropriée
parce que il n'est pas exclu que dans
certaines métropoles on a effectivement
des communes qui qui soient dans des cas
limites et qui serait donc Corinthe un
traitement relativement différent et au
nom de quoi parce qu'ils sont dans une
métropole on les exclureait c'est bon
voilà
la commission préférait de par
rigidifier le système parce que les
préfets sont quand même là pour faire
leur travail aussi et donc c'est plutôt
une demande de retraite
du gouvernement madame la ministre
la présidente donc en effet je vous ai
proposé tout à l'heure de travailler sur
cette inter territorialité je pense
qu'on sera amené à travailler de ce
sujet sur ce sujet à ce jour à 7h sur la
base de ces trois amendements le
gouvernement aimer un avis défavorable
cependant ça mérite d'y travailler je
vous remercie merci le 76
madame Noël vous retirez votre
amendement ou maintenez ok donc je vais
mettre à main
de Bernard delcro je vous ai dit Madame
la Ministre tout à l'heure à la tribune
pendant la discussion générale les
problèmes qu'on avait précisément avec
des investissements qui dépassaient
complètement le cas de la DETR je pense
que en attendant l'année prochaine et
peut-être l'année d'après le bon débat
le bon moment le bon amendement le bon
jour et la bonne heure et le bon texte
puisque manifestement ça ne fonctionne
pas je vous proposerai quand même de de
bien vouloir éventuellement
consulter et donner des instructions au
préfet pour qu'il soit particulièrement
attentif
à ces cas tout à fait limite dans
lesquels il peut y avoir des très gros
investissements qui en fait des plumes
le reste du département à cause de très
gros investissements de DETR sur des
intercommunalités qui seraient tangente
des 50000 habitants prévus par le texte
je pense qu'on peut dans l'attente des
groupes de travail que vous allez former
peut-être avoir une attention
particulière de la part des préfets et
qu'on est plus de latitude pour l'année
qui vient jusqu'à ce qu'on est réglé ce
problème et ajuster en attendant je vais
entrer l'amendement de Bernard delcro
merci alors je me vois à la maman 76 qui
a reçu un avis défavorable de la
commission et du gouvernement qui est
pour
qui est contre
qui s'abstient n'est pas adopté je mets
au voile et amendements 210 et 636 qui
ont reçu un avis défavorable de la
commission du gouvernement qui est pour
qui s'abstient sont adoptés
alors l'amendement 632
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre cette amendement propose de
réserver le bénéfice de la dotation
d'équipement des territoires ruraux
perçu par les EPCI au projet qu'il
réalise sur le territoire de leur
commune membre qui sont elles-mêmes
éligibles à la dotm il modifie donc pas
le champ des EPCI et des communes
éligibles à la DETR mais porte seulement
sur les projets des EPCI susceptibles
d'être subventionnés
merci la vie de la commission monsieur
le rapporteur
en réalité
chers collègues nous avons surtout
regardé qu'est-ce que ça donnait quoi ça
concernait qui etc alors en ressentrant
donc la 2tr allouée aux EPCI sur les
seuls projets réalisés sur des communes
membres elles-même éligibles de terre
outre que l'on continue à rajouter des
éléments
à la fois on se bat pour simplifier et
chaque fois qu'on peut complexifier on
le propose mais au-delà de ça je
rappelle que les établissements les EPCI
peuvent percevoir de terre si et
seulement si la population n'excède pas
sur une quinze mille habitants il
présente un territoire d'un seul tenant
et sans acclave et leur communément
m'ont des populations inférieures à
20000 habitants il en résulte que cet
amendement vise à exclure des dotations
perçues par le PCI les communes de moins
de 20 000 habitants qui auraient un
potentiel financier supérieur pas une
virgule trois fois la moyenne de la
strate puisque celle il y a un potentiel
inférieur sont éligibles en tant que
commune
les communes membres d'un épci ne sont
en réalité pas urbaine puisqu'elles sont
toutes inférieures à 20 000 habitants
donne les PC éligible pardon ne sont en
réalité pas urbaine puisqu'elles sont
tout inférieurs à 20 000 habitants par
définition pour que le PCI soit éligible
à ADR bon alors ailleurs par ailleurs
parmi les 5350 communes comprise entre
20 et 20000 habitants seuls 610 un
potentiel financier supérieur à une
virgule trois fois la moyenne de la
strate et parmi ces 610 certaines sont
membres d'un EPCI dont la population est
supérieure à 75000 habitants bon il en
résulte qu'il existe très peu de cas et
que donc on crée un élément nouveau pour
pas grand chose donc demande de retrait
merci la vie du gouvernement madame la
ministre
ranger la vie du président et rapport
merci beaucoup sustention
l'amendement 78 madame Noël
merci madame la Présidente
cet amendement a simplement pour objet
de déplafonner la participation maximale
de la participation titre de la dutr
généralement il est fixé à 40%, je
propose de le porter à 80%
. et la vie de la commission monsieur le
Président
réglementaire on est certainement pas
dans le domaine de la loi donc retrait
merci madame la ministre avait du
gouvernement de même retrait merci ce
que vous retirez merci
alors
5 amendements
identiques le 31 même guidez
la présidente mes chers collègues vous
l'avez déjà évoqué nous avions l'avant
la réserve parlementaire pour aider les
petites communes qui avaient des petits
projets or aujourd'hui de plus en plus
de préfecture fixe dans leur circulaire
portant attribution de la DR un montant
minimal de dépenses subventionnables en
dessous duquel des communes ne peuvent
solliciter cette dotation certaines
communes se voient ainsi refuser le
bénéfice de la DTR au motif que le coût
de leur projet n'est pas suffisant
suffisamment élevé le président
amendement entend donc interdire cette
pratique je vous remercie merci alors
l'amendement 79 madame Noël défendu
merci un moment 467 monsieur benaroche
oui madame la Présidente effectivement
comme l'a dit ma collègue nous
souhaitons améliorer l'attribution de la
DETR face aux pratiques pénalisantes
pour certaines communes que tu es
constaté par des élus locaux et il
apparaît en fait que de plus en plus de
préfectures fixent dans leur circulaire
pourtant attribution de la DETR en
montant minimum de dépenses
subventionnelle au-dessus duquel les
communes peuvent solliciter cette
dotation c'est la raison pour laquelle
certaines covides se voir refuser le
bénéfice de la DETR au motif que le coût
de leur projet n'est pas suffisamment
élevé cela pénalise directement les plus
petites communes orientant les dotations
vers de plus gros projets en général
portés par des collectivités plus
importantes
le président amendement qui a fait issu
de proposition de la RF de l'Association
des mères ruraux de France
orthodoxe interdire cette pratique
la présidente madame la ministre mes
chers collègues donc effectivement je
comme mes collègues l'ont dit des
préfectures fixes dans leur circulaire
portant attribution de la dutr un
montant minimal de dépens
subventionnables or lorsque vous êtes
une petite commune rurale et que vous
avez un projet modeste et bien vous ne
pouvez pas prétendre à une aide de la
part de l'étain sous forme de DETR ce
qui est évidemment un frein et pour pour
moi qui suis élu d'un département où il
y a énormément de petites communes voire
même de moins de 100 habitants voilà
c'est donc quelque chose qui remonte
beaucoup des territoires merci merci le
584 même brûlant merci madame la
Présidente nous proposons aussi que les
représentants de l'État ne mettent pas
de seuil minimum pour la tribution de la
DETR pour tous les arguments qui
viennent d'être développés et notamment
pour que les plus petites communes
puissent y avoir accès mais je voudrais
insister sur un point qui est peut-être
en tout cas je l'espère un peu plus
conjoncturel c'est que nous allons avoir
dans les prochains mois les prochaines
années un sujet investissement dans les
communes et dans les plus petites en
raison de la situation financière dans
laquelle elle se trouve en raison de
l'inflation et je vais pas développer ça
ici et donc particulièrement dans la
période si on veut parce que la DETR ça
a quand même un impact sur le tissu
économique et je dirais le tissu
économique le plus fin l'artisanat etc
dans nos territoires voilà pourquoi il
est important que les plus petites
communes puissent en bénéficier sans
seuil merci la vie de la commission
monsieur le président
d'abord madame la Présidente je voulais
me féliciter que nos rapports soient si
bien lus et si bien retraduit donc je ne
pensais pas qu'on avait un tel succès et
donc on avait indiqué effectivement qui
avait en cours un mouvement qui allait
dans ce sens d'une fixation minimale par
les préfets pour son inquiéter on
n'avait pas fait d'amendement parce
qu'on considérait qu'il fallait voir
attendre de voir comment ça se mettait
en place mais de fait c'est une réalité
alors pas dans tout dans toutes les
préfectures mais dans quelques-unes on
comprend bien qu'il y a une question une
volonté
d'économie de gestion si je puis dire au
sein des préfectures on comprend on
comprend l'objet si je puis dire bon on
a été maire tous on sait commencer
essayer de gérer au mieux bon sans
mettre des effectifs supplémentaires
mais en même temps c'est contraire à
l'esprit à l'esprit de la DTR c'est
contraire au fait que on est
effectivement notre propre en qui était
parlementaire qui était mise à la 2tr et
qui était pour l'essentiel consacré à
des tout petits projets et donc nous
sommes favorables à ce que on indique
clairement que on ne peut pas mettre de
critères
minimal dans les critères de DETR il y a
des critères qui sont fixés par la loi
on en reste là et on essaie de faire en
sorte que les préfets soient ouverts à
tous les projets que ce soit pas une
barrière
donc favorable monsieur le Président
merci la vie du gouvernement madame la
ministre
merci madame la Présidente
en fait je vous rappelle que la fixation
des catégories prioritaires ainsi que
des taux minimaux et maximum de
subventions sont du ressort de la
commission départementale des élus et
non des préfets si cette pratique est
reprise dans les circulaires de
certaines préfectures c'est qu'elles ont
été décidées et validées par ces
commissions en outre on compte en 2021
plus de
5570 projets ayant bénéficié d'une
subvention inférieure à 5000 euros
5570 projets il y en bénéficié d'une
subvention inférieure 5000 euros il
semble donc cet amendement introduirait
des rigidités au niveau local sans
véritable besoin avéré des projets de
montant limité restent donc bien
soutenus grâce à la DETR
la gestion des dotations
d'investissement aux collectivités
volontairement déconcentrer cela répond
à une demande locale mais aussi un
nécessaire pragmatisme il me semble
vraiment nécessaire de conserver ces
principes la vie
du gouvernement et le retrait sinon des
favorable merci merci Monsieur Richard
merci madame la Présidente mes chers je
sais pas qui a fixé ça toujours est-il
que
ce chiffre existe et clairement il n'est
pas possible de subventionner au titre
de la DETR des petits projets c'est
c'est un fait
je crois qu'il faut d'autant plus
changer ça madame la ministre que en
terme en termes d'image c'est juste
catastrophique pour les mères qui
reçoivent un courrier qui reçoivent un
courrier qui leur dit le sous préfet
leur dit écoutez votre projet n'a pas pu
être retenu parce que tenez-vous bien la
motivation est expliquée le montant qui
qui est demandé par votre commune est
trop faible trop faible pour bénéficier
alors quand vous savez que ce sont des
tout petits projets et ça a été dit tout
à l'heure ça va empirer compte tenu peu
de marge de manœuvre financière dont
vont disposer à l'avenir les
collectivités locales
c'est juste l'incroyable quoi
persuadé qu'ici un certain nombre de
sénateurs ont été saisis par des
communes auxquelles on a donné ce type
de réponse c'est
désastreux donc une commune qui peut pas
faire d'autres projets que ce petit
projet
comprend pas qu'on lui dise non non non
votre projet est trop faible on va pas
vous donner dessous donc moi je voterai
naturellement des deux mains
ses amendements rejoignant la vie de la
de la commission je vous remercie
merci
franchement je pense qu'il faudrait que
vous reveniez sur votre décision tout
simplement parce que c'est même pas des
projets à 7000 euros je crois que vous
ne connaissez pas les communes rurales
des fois ce sont des projets de 2000
euros donc voilà 7000 euros de même pour
eux c'est beaucoup de surface sont des
projets des gros projets pour eux donc
je crois que vous connaissez pas les
communes rurales et franchement ça me
ferait bien plaisir que vous reveniez
sur une telle décision je vous remercie
merci alors ah pardon madame la
Présidente
pour rebondir sur les propos de Madame
la Ministre quand elle dit que la
Commission à la main mais la Commission
ne voit que les projets au dessus de
100000 donc de toute manière c'est somme
là nous ne les voyons pas c'est à dire
qu'elles ont déjà été éliminées et nous
ne voyons pas ces projets les critères
moi j'ai une commission DETR le 5
décembre je vais demander dans les
critères par exemple que les communes
qui ont subi des incendies puissent
avoir des compensations dans la DETR je
sais déjà qu'elle va être la question on
va me dire mais non c'est pas possible
ça pas été visé par le PLF etc donc moi
je crois qu'on n'a pas vraiment beaucoup
de marge de manœuvre en tout cas il est
vrai que si on a ce débat dans
l'hémicycle c'est vrai qu'on souhait
très que des consignes redescendent
auprès des préfets on a déjà essayé mais
là effectivement madame la ministre
qu'on souhaite vous dire c'est qu'il
faut vraiment vous fassiez redescendre
ces consignes là auprès des des préfets
parce que dans les commissions on n'a
pas vraiment la main pour changer les
critères ça se passe pas vraiment comme
ça
merci alors je mets aux voix donc c'est
cinq amendements identiques avis
favorable de la commission avis
défavorable du gouvernement qui est pour
qui est contre qui s'abstient et sont
donc adoptés amendement 80 madame Noël
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre le premier amendement vise à
fixer un délai de réponse maximale de 3
mois de l'administration pour répondre
aux demandes de subventions et le second
vise à fixer un délai minimum de 6 mois
compter de du lancement des appels à
projets départements tout tôt pour
déposer leur dossier
80 madame Noël vous pouvez le défendre
en même temps et défendu merci avis de
la commission
monsieur
ça demande 80
par ailleurs l'article du Code Général
des Collectivités Territoriales
prévoient que ces subventions doivent
être notifiées en totalité c'est ça qui
est important finalement doivent être
notifiés en totalité au cours du premier
trimestre de l'année civile
en fixant un délai minimum donc de 6
mois pour déposer une demande où monter
des dossiers
la notification au cours du premier
trimestre deviendrait impossible or les
élus s'ils ont besoin de temps on le
comprend pour monter leur dossier ont
également besoin de temps enfin de temps
court pour recevoir les crédits le plus
rapidement possible en fait d'engager
les investissements donc on est entre
deux
intérêts finalement mais comme
finalement le Code général nous impose
la notification avant trois mois je vous
propose le retrait de cette amendement
pour le 80 madame Noël est fixe il
demande propose de fixer un délai de
réponse maximum de trois mois
l'administration aux demandes de
subventions de TR alors quand la réponse
est positive ce délai est respecté
puisque l'article
l23436 du CGCT prévoit déjà que les
subventions doivent être notifiées en
totalité au du premier trimestre comme
je voulais rappeler tout à l'heure par
défaut et en creux les collectivités qui
n'ont pas reçu de notifications peuvent
en déduire conditions qui connaissent la
règle évidemment que leur projet n'a pas
été retenu donc cette absence de
notification pour les projets rejetés
peut cependant effectivement poser
certaines difficultés et d'ailleurs
notre demande visant à fournir la liste
à la Commission de TR de tous les
projets recevables mais non retenus
répond à cette difficulté de manière à
ce que ensuite quand vous êtes membre de
la commission vous puissiez revenir
rapidement vers les communes avant même
qu'elle reçoive une lettre de refus de
la préfecture pour déjà leur indiquer
que leur projet n'a pas été retenu donc
demande de retrait également
merci la vie du gouvernement madame la
ministre sur ces deux amendements 80 et
81 avis défavorable pour les deux de la
part du gouvernement pour les raisons
évoqués merci
retirer pour les deux merci
[Musique]
alors donc amendement
identique le 406 même Brésil merci
madame la présidente madame la ministre
mes chers collègues cet amendement vise
à déployer à titre expérimental une
évaluation environnementale des projets
territoriaux qui pourraient être
financés par la dotation de l'équipement
des territoires ruraux la dutr ou la
dotation de soutien à l'investissement
local à des cils voilà ce que je vous
propose c'est à dire un vrai critère et
non pas celui d'écologie comme nous
avions tout à l'heure qui était floue
mais quelque chose d'expérimental une
évaluation ex hantée qui serait réalisée
pour chaque projet et d'abord sollicité
par une métropole et aidé par la mission
régionale d'autorité environnementale
aussi au soutien d'un de ces deux fonds
l'expérimentation ne concerne dans un
premier temps que les projets des
métropoles dans la mesure où elles ont
les capacités d'ingénierie pour réaliser
de telles évaluations dans un second
temps
et une fois la méthodologie posée ces
études pourraient être généralisées à
toutes les collectivités porteuses de
projets améliorer le pilotage des
financements publics dédié aux
collectivités doit aujourd'hui être une
nécessité un tel mécanisme permet de
répondre entre autres au référé de la
Cour des comptes du 23 juillet dernier
critiquant vertement le pilotage par
l'état de ses concours financiers à
l'investissement public local au travers
des deux principales dotations qui sont
là des cils et la DETR et notamment je
mentionne dans ce rapport de la Cour des
comptes le ciblage géographique et
sectorial problématique la soutenabilité
incertaine et la gestion fragile ou
encore une démarche de performance
inaboutie
par cet amendement cela permettrait à
l'état d'avoir les outils et aux
collectivités territoriales de suivre et
d'évaluer l'efficacité et des impacts
supposés des différents investissements
vis-à-vis de l'urgence climatique
l'analyse de l'exemplarité des projets
portés réalisés par les territoires
devra se faire au regard de critères
précis définis en lien avec les péchés
merci
l'amendement 465 monsieur benaroche je
comptais dire défendu mais du coup je
termine la phrase
en disant que les critères précis et
défini le sang en lien avec les pcaet
mais aussi les stradettes et les projets
de territoire a fait s’assurer du réel
bénéfice pour l'environnement ainsi
beaucoup la vie de la commission
monsieur le président
alors on a on a un petit problème
d'écriture de l'article puisque cet
article finalement parle des évaluations
environnementales par les métropoles et
les projets financés par la DETR et la
décision or par principe le métropole
sont par principes exclus du bénéfice de
TR et des cils donc ce n'est pas le cas
évidemment des communes de certaines
communes membres de la métropole mais
tels qui rédigé la mandat il précise
bien qui ne concerne que les projets des
métropoles elles-mêmes et donc c'est
inopérant et donc demande de retrait
merci la vie du gouvernement madame la
ministre
le même avis pour les deux
ah oui non mais ils sont identiques je
donnais la parole juste à madame la
ministre c'est moi pardon merci Madame
la présidence
sur les deux défavorables merci beaucoup
merci alors je me vois donc ces deux
amendements
identiques 406 465 donc avis défavorable
de la commission du gouvernement qui est
pour
qui est contre qui s'abstient ne sont
pas adoptistes alors
j'ai maintenant
14 amendements discussion communes mais
je veux arrêter à 20h15 absolument donc
soit j'engage cette discussion commune
si vous me promettez que on peut arrêter
à 20h15 sinon j'arrête pas ok tout le
monde est d'accord ça va bien bon ça
marche alors le 629 monsieur Marie merci
madame la Présidente c'est un amendement
qui est proposé par notre groupe vise à
donner au préfet de département le rôle
d'attribuer les subventions au titre de
la dotation de soutien à
l'investissement local comme il le fait
pour les crédits de la LEtr en lieu et
place du préfet de région par ailleurs
cet amendement crée une commission
départementale des investissements
locaux chargés de contrôler la
répartition de la dotation d'équipement
des territoires euro et de la part
départementale de la des cils cette
commission est modelée sur l'actuel
commission DETR mais ses compétences
sont renforcées elle serait ainsi
destinataire de la liste des demandes de
subventions au préfet de département et
formuler un avis sur la liste complète
de subventions projetées cela ramasse
l'ensemble des demandes que nous
formulons chaque année
si l'amendement 153 qui le défend
même
la procédure d'octroi de la DTR se
caractérise par son opacité et un
pouvoir très faible de la commission des
élus afin de remédier à cette situation
le présent amendement propose de rendre
obligatoire la communication à la
Commission de l'ensemble des dossiers
déposés d'abaisser à 80000 euros contre
100.000 euros actuellement le seuil du
montant de subventions au-delà duquel la
ville de la commission est requis
contraindre le préfet à respecter les
catégories prioritaires d'opérations à
financer fixé par la commission prévoir
que préférant de compte à la Commission
de ses choix et des critères retenus
pour sélectionner ou rejeter les
demandes de subvention enfin des
critères excluant une commune de
bénéfice de la ddtr autre que se fixer
par la loi ne doivent pas pouvoir être
prévu dans le cadre du règlement
départemental certains départements
mettent déjà en œuvre à l'initiative du
préfet une partie des dispositions en
matière de transparence prévue par le
président amendement toutefois les
bonnes pratiques restent trop rares
c'est pourquoi il convient de les
généraliser par la loi je vous remercie
merci moi je de vous demander quand
c'est pas votre amendement de faire soit
défendu ou franchement très très court
parce que sinon on n'y arrivera pas à
20h15 merci beaucoup madame je pense que
c'est Madame Estrosi ça sonne pour le
378 oui alors je présente cet amendement
au nom de notre collègue Jean-Marc Boyer
et d'un certain nombre de nos collègues
qui ont été signataires l'amendement
permet au parlementaire de demander
l'attribution d'une dotation d'actions
parlementaires et que 20% de l'enveloppe
DETR soit affectée à cette dotation
parlementaire cet amendement prévoit
également que l'ensemble des
parlementaires et quel que soit leur
nombre dans un département soit douce
membres de la commission DETR et enfin
il précise que les parlementaires ne
votent pas lorsque la commission DETR se
réunit sur les projets qui seraient
présentés par ceci en effet cela
reviendrait à leur demander de se
prononcer sur des projets qu'il propose
et il pourrait être à l'origine de
sources de conflits d'intérêt voilà
alors deux amendements identiques le 29
madame guidez
défendue merci Madame Noël pour le 77
il n'est pas soutenu
trois amendements identiques monsieur
gainé pour le 23
ou sur une allée défendue merci beaucoup
le 292 Monsieur Hervé très bien et le
410 Monsieur Bonhomme
présidente donc depuis 2017 tout le
monde sait que on reçoit nos deux
synthèse simplement votre compétition
dispositif pour pour assurer le
caractère opérant du droit à
l'information qui est un droit essentiel
pour les élus en ne faisant en sorte
qu'on soit en transmettre avant la fin
du premier trimestre de chaque année la
liste complète de l'ensemble des
opérations éligibles et recevable et non
plus simplement celle à subventionné
si le 451 monsieur Sautarel
présidente la ministre cet amendement
déposé par notre collègue Jean-Baptiste
blanc et signé par nombre d'entre nous
vise à ce que le préfet expose les
raisons des refus aux communes qui nous
dans les dossiers n'auraient pas été
retenus au titre de la dotr merci
monsieur sotarel vous venez de défendre
quel amendement
le 160 pardon et là je vous demande le
qui lui vise à élargir les pouvoirs de
la Commission de terre dans chaque
département afin qu'elle puisse non
seulement donner un avis sur les projets
importants mais décisionnaires sur les
demandes de subvention au titre de
l'ensemble des dossiers de la DETR
si le 390 madame Goulet alors madame
président de la ministre c'est un
amendement qui est déjà reçu plusieurs
votes favorables du Sénat il s'agit de
la motivation des refus de DETR donc ce
qui semble une logique quand même pour
que les mères sachent pourquoi on leur
refuse la DETR donc il s'agit d'une
demande de motivation que le Sénat déjà
voté plusieurs fois merci de amendements
identiques le 30 de Madame guidez
merci le 82 n'est pas défendu
et le 137 monsieur Vial oui
oui merci la Présidente il s'agit de
créer pour la décile une commission à
l'image de celle qui existe pour la DETR
donc au niveau régional qui intégrerait
aussi un certain nombre d'élus merci
beaucoup la vie de la Commission sur ces
amendements monsieur le président
alors une réponse générale et puis je
donnerai ensuite les
les réponses par amendement donc tous
les amendements ont pour objectif
d'augmenter les pouvoirs de la
Commission de terre et ou d'améliorer
son information il nous semble
indispensable de garder le meilleur
équilibre possible entre l'Association
des élus et les prérogatives du préfet
pour l'octroi de crédit qui reste ceux
de l'État les amendements de la
commission visent d'une part un
renforcement des pouvoirs consultatifs
des élus et d'autre part à une
amélioration de l'information à
destination des élus s'agissant de la
décide d'amélioration pourrait passer
par une saisine pour avis non
contraignant du président du conseil
départemental sur les projets
subventionnés au titre de la décide des
améliorations sont également prévues en
matière d'information des commissions
d'etr en premier lieu nous proposons une
communication à la Commission de TR de
l'ensemble des demandes subventions dès
lors que le dossier
afin de mieux cerner les critères de
sélection appliqués par les services de
l'État et vérifier le respect des
priorités fixées par les commissions en
second lieu nous proposons d'inscrire
dans la loi l'obligation d'une
communication annuelle du préfet de
département à la Commission de terre sur
l'emploi de la décide dans le
département comme c'est déjà le cas pour
la décile cette information permettrait
ainsi de trouver un juste équilibre
entre l'Association des élus et les
prérogatives du préfet pour l'octroi de
crédit d'investissement en provenance de
l'État et permettrait également aux
membres d'un commission de terre d'avoir
une vision exhaustive de l'emploi du
subvention d'investissement dans leur
département il nous paraissent tous ces
amendements de nature présentées par la
Commission de Natura répondre aux
préoccupations dont les élus locaux nous
ont fait part à l'occasion des travaux
de contrôle que nous avons menés sur le
sujet sans alourdir des musulmans les
procédures je tiens d'ailleurs à
souligner que la commission des lois a
déposé des amendements identiques aux
autres ce qui depuis que je suis
rapporteur est une innovation que je
salue
et donc très apprécié nous vous invite
nous vous invitons donc
à vous rallier aux positions clairement
exprimée par nos deux commissions et par
conséquent à retirer vos amendements
avec lesquels ils sont incompatibles
alors ça voudrait dire que
il serait favorable au 23 de la
Commission et
identique
sagesse on vous propose de la sagesse
sur le 378 c'est celui de la
réinstallation de la réserve
parlementaire même si on le proposait
pas ou ce qui serait voté donc si vous
voulez on préfère être populaire comme
disait l'autre on a appris suffisamment
sur la cafetière toute la journée donc
on termine olé en beauté et la demande
de retrait donc sur tous les autres
merci
merci Madame la Ministre la vie du
gouvernement
aussi rapidement on serait parfait
merci madame la Présidente donc
nous le gouvernement va émettre un avis
favorable sur le 22 et défavorable sur
les autres merci il y a 22 le 22
le 23 madame la ministre
mais je n'ai pas de 22
il est après donc il est pas défendu là
pour l'instant ah oui oui
donc sur le 23
allez tout est défavorable pour nous
tout est défavorable et on va attendre
la présentation du 22 on a pensé que
monsieur le Président l'avait présenté
bon alors je vais mettre aux voix donc
les amendements alors 629 avis
défavorables de la Commission et du
gouverne retrait le 153
avis défavorables commission
gouvernement qui est pour contre qui
s'abstient vous avez pas les mains donc
voilà il est retiré non c'est pas retiré
le 378 sagesse de la Commission et
défavorable du gouvernement qui est pour
qui est contre qui s'abstient donc
adopter
le 29
il retiré merci
le 23 donc 292 et 410 qui sont
identiques de la commission avec un avis
défavorable du gouvernement qui est pour
contre qui s'abstient et donc sont donc
adoptés le 451 monsieur sotareg est
retiré
le 160 est retiré merci
390 madame Goulet il est pas retiré donc
je le mets aux voix donc défavorable
commission gouvernement qui est pour
ah oui
c'est contre
qui s'abstient donc adopter
amendement 32 même guides retiré vous le
maintenez donc défavorable commission
gouvernement qui est pour
qui est contre
ça tient pas adopté et l'amendement 137
monsieur Vial retiré merci
alors
je vais reposer une question est-ce que
vous pensez qu'en un quart d'heure on
finit complètement le texte
il reste une vingtaine non non le
président dit quoi
[Musique]
non non n'était pas
je crois que c'est très simple il faut
faire une présentation en 3 secondes
voir sur défendu écouter la réponse de
la ministre voté voilà
donc on fait ça si on fait ça je vous
rappelle que samedi il y a grève des
trains donc plus personne va pouvoir
revenir
alors qui n'est pas d'accord sur
ces amendements juste
descendus qui n'est pas d'accord ok on y
va
alors donc l'amendement 139
159 pardon monsieur sautarelle merci
Madame présidente ils vise à fixer une
liste complémentaire défendue au nom de
mon collègue Jean-Baptiste blanc
avis de la commission avis de la
commission
la commission monsieur le président
demande de retrait madame la ministre
aussi s'il vous plaît il est retiré
monsieur sotarel retirez merci Monsieur
Marie pour le 638
défendu à vie de la Commission
retrait
merci
alors deux amendements
identiques le 21 de la commission même
la ministre
et le ah oui et puis celui de Monsieur
Hervé commission des lois
requêtes monsieur Guénet sinon des
favorable des favorables donc je mets
aux voix c'est amendements donc de la
commission avec des favorables qui est
pour
contre qui sont donc adoptés
deux amendements identiques le 22 de la
commission madame la ministre vous avez
dit que vous étiez favorable on est
d'accord donc voilà et commission des
lois même avis donc je mets aux voix qui
est pour contre qui s'abstient et sont
donc adoptés
article 45
293 de la commission des lois Monsieur
Hervé les défendus
voilà madame la ministre
avis de la commission
favorable position du gouvernement et
favorable dans le gouvernement donc je
mets aux voix donc l'amendement donc de
la commission des lois défavorables de
la commission des finances favorables
par le gouvernement qui est pour
qui est contre qui s'abstient donc
adopter je me ouvre l'article 45 et pour
contre qui s'abstient adopter
à mon deuxième moment
identiques 143 monsieur Vial défendu
merci
Monsieur
Madame Gatel défendu
avis de la commission
défavorable merci même Gatel vous
retirez monsieur VIAL
donc je mets aux voix cet amendement
donc avec des favorable de la commission
du gouvernement qui est pour
qui est contre
alors vous allez lever les mains quand
même donc qui est pour ces amendements
qui pour lesquels on a deux avis
défavorables
qui est contre
ne sont pas adoptés
je mets aux voiles 45 Waters qui est
pour contre qui s'abstient adopter
mon en 440
monsieur Tissot défendu
avec la commission
même la ministre défavorable merci
retirez merci
alors 4 amendements dans l'objet d'une
discussion commune le 447 monsieur
Sautarel défendu
et fendu merci
3 amendements
identiques un sous amendement alors le
50 monsieur Delcros
il était fendu et je veux attirer
l'attention sur le fait que on a prévu
les crédits pour cet amendement
pas pour le précédent
monsieur delcro je n'ai pas entendu
c'est bon voilà
226 c'est pas défendu
non il y a personne
le 397 madame Delattre défendu
et le sous-amendement 997 monsieur le
Président Gontard défendu il est défendu
merci donc avis de la commission
bien plus globalement sur tous ces
amendements on est favorable sur le 50
de Monsieur Delcros sachant que ce soit
clair et de cette manière bien entendu
il sera intéressant que les autres se
retirent notamment le 447 le 987 et que
le 226 et 3
on est défavorable
sous amendement
avis du gouvernement madame la ministre
sagesse et sinon même à vie
sagesse sur le 50 et sur le sous
amendement
comme la commission merci
donc le 447 monsieur sautard elle vous
retirer
merci alors je mets au voile le 50
il est sous amendement donc avis
défavorable la Commission du
gouvernement qui est pour
qui est contre
non ça c'est le sous-amendement qui est
alors qui est contre le sous-amendement
voilà merci avec des favorable ok donc
tendu et le 50 donc à vie favorable de
la commission et sagesse du gouvernement
qui est pour
contre ça tient et donc adopter sont
adoptés
le 398
voilà voilà alors le 398 madame Delattre
il est défendu même de madame la
Présidente de Lattre le 398 est défendu
merci avis de la commission
défavorable merci même la ministre du
gouvernement mais ma vie
merci je me vois l'article 46 qui est
pour contre qui s'abstient donc adopter
alors le 651 monsieur buy
bon d'accord défendu merci beaucoup avis
de la commission
favorable
et favorables ok donc je mets aux voiles
cet amendement 151 vif favorable qui est
pour contre
le
852 pardon monsieur buis défendu
défendu avec du gouver de la commission
favorable favorable donc je mets aux
voix donc le 650 de avis défavorable de
la commission favorable du gouvernement
qui est pour
qui est contre
on refait
avis défavorable de la commission
assez favorable
il avait dit des favorable d'accord donc
c'est favorable commission et
gouvernement donc qui est pour compte
qui s'abstient donc adopté ça va
beaucoup mieux ainsi
madame Noël n'est pas défendue
le deux amendement identique le 134
monsieur Vial est défendu merci beaucoup
et même Gatel défendu merci avis de la
commission
ces deux amendements identiques
merci avis du gouvernement
retirée
oui retirer merci beaucoup maman 466
monsieur benaroche
je pense qu'il faut dire défendu ça
c'est bien
merci beaucoup avis de la commission
benaroche
d'accord donc je mets aux voix
défavorable commissions et gouvernement
qui est pour contre qui s'abstient ils
ont pas adopté c'est un procédé au vote
nous allons procéder donc au vote des
crédits du compte spécial avant ce
collectivité territoriale figurant à
l'état d je n'étais saisi d'aucune
demande d'explication de vote avant
l'expiration du délai limite je vous
rappelle que la commission des finances
est favorable à l'adoption des crédits
du compte spécial je me vois les crédits
du compte spécial qui est pour
qui est contre qui ça tient ils sont
bons
monsieur
le président gonta
c'est un rappel au règlement oui
oui merci madame la Présidente non juste
un rappel au règlement par rapport à je
comprends tout à fait qu'il faut se
dépêcher que on est voilà et que il y a
pas de train samedi etc il y a pas de
souci et on a joué le jeu mais je trouve
quand même que c'est pas c'est pas très
sérieux enfin voilà c'est vrai qu'on a
passé un certain nombre d'amendements
sans pouvoir les défendre sans discuter
et que ça pose quand même la question de
l'organisation générale de la et de la
manière dont on étudie ce budget et que
je pense que voilà on peut pas se
satisfaire en tout cas de cette manière
de fonctionner merci à tes données de
votre appel au règlement alors je vais
suspendre la séance elle sera reprise à
21h40 pour l'examen de la mission
agriculture alimentation forêt et à
faire rurales la séance est suspendue